order order and invite the house to rise
and observe a minute silence in memory
of a late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II
foreign
before I call the prime minister
it is with the greatest sadness that I
Rise to say a few words in tribute to
her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth
almost all of us in the house have
experienced no other Monarch this
country's throne but her late Majesty
though indeed only ascoroso members in
this house will have already been born
let alone who can recall the time when
she wasn't the queen
she's wet in our minds with the Clone
and all it stands for
after accession in February 1952 she
first came to the Palace of Westminster
to open the session of parliament in
November
1952 when Winston Churchill was the
Prime Minister and speaker William
Morrison was in the church almost 70
years ago
57 complete sessions of parliament have
passed since then and as she was here to
open all but three of them
parliamentarians we've celebrated with
her for silver golden diamond jubilees
and of course marked her Platinum
Jubilee this year in which the lamp
standards have been unveiled in New
Palace yard
in this place her Reign saw 10 different
speakers occupied the chair during a
Reign there were 18 general elections
and I'm sure the Prime Minister will
remind of us how many of her
predeceptors she welcomed two and always
am sure with quiet wisdom
as the longest serving Monarch this
country has known
she would have been assured of a notable
entry in our history books even were it
not for the magnificent in which she
undertook the role as Queen but from a
magnificent surface and water service
that entailed
not just as head of the nation but head
of the Commonwealth head of the Armed
Forces and supreme governor of the
Church of England
over the rain chassis unprecedented
social cultural technological Church
through it all so the most conscientious
and dutiful monarchs
but while she understood the inescapital
nature of Duty which sometimes must have
weighed upon her heavily
she also delighted in carrying it out
for she was the most devoted mother
as well as Queen she was a wife a mother
a grandmother and great-grandmother role
she carried out with the same sense of
vocation as well as humans and kindness
as the role of Queen
her life without unhappiness and
troubles but our memories of her will be
filled with that image of a gently
smiling Dedication that showed
throughout her life
indeed
while this is a time of very
considerable sadness those memories of a
noble gracious lady who devoted a life
to a family the United Kingdom and those
Nations around the world whom she served
as Queen will bring us some consolation
and joy
my deepest sympathies are with his
majesty the king and other members of
the royal family to whom I commend all
our sincere condolences and support at
this very very sad time
yeah
order we are meeting today for tributes
to her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth
I would like to inform the house that we
will sit today until approximately
10 p.m for tributes at approximately six
o'clock the house will be suspended
while his majesty the king makes his
broadcast the nation
members presence will be able to watch
the broadcast on screens in the chamber
we will then resume our proceedings to
continue with tributes
the house will then sit again tomorrow
at one o'clock the first business will
be all taking for a small number of
senior members members to be invited to
take the old tomorrow are being
contacted by my office all of the
members will have an opportunity to take
the oath when the house returns after
all taken tomorrow tributes will be
continued the house is expected to sit
till approximately 10 pm the house is
not expected to sit on Sunday I now call
the Prime Minister Elizabeth Trust
thank you
Mr Speaker in the hours since last
night's shocking news
we have witnessed the most heartfelt
outpouring of grief of the loss of her
late Majesty the queen
the crowds have gathered
flags have been lowered to half-mast
tributes have been sent from every
continent around the world
on the death of her father King George
VI Winston Churchill said the news had
stilled the clatter and traffic of 20th
century life in Many Lands
now 70 years later in the tumult of the
21st century life has paused again
her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II was
one of the greatest leaders the world
has ever known
she was the rock on which modern Britain
was built
she came to the throne at just 25 in a
country that was emerging from the
shadow of War
she bequeathes a modern dynamic nation
that has grown and flourished under her
reign
the United Kingdom is the great country
it is today because of her
the Commonwealth is the family of
Nations it is today because of her
she was devoted to the union of England
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
she served 15 countries as head of state
and she loved them all
her words of wisdom gave her strength in
the most testing times
during the darkest moments of the
pandemic she gave us hope that we would
meet again
she knew this generation of britons
would be as strong as any
and as we meet today we remember the
pledge she made on her 21st birthday to
dedicate her life to service
the whole house will agree
never has a promise been so completely
fulfilled
her Devotion to duty remains an example
to us all
she carried out thousands of engagements
she took a red box every day
she gave her a cent to countless pieces
of legislation and was at the heart of
our national life for seven decades
the Supreme governor of the Church of
England she Drew on her deep faith
she was the nation's greatest diplomat
her visits to post apartheid South
Africa and to the Republic of Ireland
showed a unique ability to transcend
difference and heal division
in total she visited well over a hundred
countries
she meant she she met more people than
any other Monarch in our history
she gave counsel to Prime Ministers and
ministers across government
I have personally greatly valued her
wise advice
only last October I witnessed firsthand
how she Charmed the world's leading
investors at Windsor Castle
she was always so proud of Britain and
always embodied the spirit of our great
country
she remained determined to carry out her
duties even at the age of 96.
it was just three days ago at Balmoral
that she invited me to form a government
and become her 15th prime minister
again she generously shared with me her
deep experience of government even in
those last days
everyone who met her will remember the
moment
they will speak of it for the rest of
their lives
even those who never met her her late
Majesty's image is an icon for what
Britain stands for as a nation
on our coins on our stamps and in
portraits around the world
her Legacy will endure through the
countless people she met
the global history she witnessed and the
lives that she touched
she was loved and admired by people
across the United Kingdom and across the
world
one of the reasons for that affection
was her sheer Humanity
she reinvented monarchy for the Modern
Age
she was a champion of freedom and
democracy around the world
she was dignified but not distant she
was willing to have fun
whether on a mission with 007 or having
tea with Paddington Bear
she brought the monarchy into people's
lives and into people's homes
during her first televised Christmas
message in 1957 she said today we need a
special kind of Courage
so we can show the world that we are not
afraid of the future
we need that courage now
in an instant yesterday our lives
changed forever
today we show the world that we do not
fear what lies ahead
we send our deepest sympathy to all
members of the Royal Family
we pay tribute to our late Queen and we
offer loyal service to our new king
his majesty King Charles III Bears an
awesome responsibility that he now
carries for all of us
I was grateful to speak to his majesty
last night and offer my condolences
even as he Mourns his sense of Duty and
service is clear
he has already made a profound
contribution through his work on
conservation education and his tireless
diplomacy
we owe him our loyalty and devotion
the British people the Commonwealth and
all of us in this house
will support him as he takes our country
forward to a new era of Hope and
progress
our new Carolian age
the crown endures
our nation endures
and in that spirit I say God Save the
King
I know called the leader of the
opposition
thank you Mr Speaker
today our country our people this house
are united in mourning
Queen Elizabeth II was this great
country's greatest monarch
and for the vast majority of us it feels
impossible to imagine a Britain without
her
all our thoughts are with her beloved
family our royal family
at this moment of profound grief
this is a deep and private loss for them
yet it's one we all share
because Queen Elizabeth created a
special personal relationship with us
all
that relationship was built on the
attributes that defined her reign
her total commitment to service and Duty
her deep Devotion to the country the
Commonwealth
and the people she loved
in return for that
we loved her
and it is because of that great shared
love
that we grieve today
for the 70 glorious years of her Reign
Our Queen was at the heart of this
nation's life
she did not simply Reign Over Us
she lived alongside us
she shared in our hopes and our fears
our joy and our pain
our good times and our bad
Our Queen played a crucial role as the
thread between the history we cherish
on the present we own
a reminder that our generational battle
against the evil of fascism
or the emergence of a New Britain out of
the rubble of the second world war do
not only belong to the Past
but are the inheritance of each and
every one of us
a reminder that the creativity the hard
work the Enterprise that has always
defined this nation is as abundant now
as it ever was
a reminder that the prospect of a better
future still Burns brightly
never was this link more important
that when our country was plunged into
lockdown at the start of the pandemic
her simple message
that we would see family again
that we would see friends again
that we would be together again
gave people strength and courage when
they needed it most
but it wasn't simply the message that
allowed a shaken Nation to draw upon
those Reserves
it was the fact that she was the
messenger
covid closed the front doors of every
home in the country it made our lives
smaller and more remote
but she was able to reach beyond that to
reassure us and steal us
at the time we were most alone
but a time we'd been driven apart
she held the nation close
in a way no one else could have done
for that
we say thank you
on the occasion of the queen Silver
Jubilee in 1977
Philip Larkin wrote of her reign
in times where nothing stood but
worsened or grew strange
there was one constant good
she did not change
it feels like we're once again in a
moment in our history where as Larkin
put it
things are growing strange
where everything is spinning
a nation requires a Still Point
when times are difficult
it requires comfort
and when direction is hard to find it
requires leadership
the loss of our Queen robs this country
of its stillest point
its greatest comfort
at precisely the time we need those
things most
but our Queen's commitment to us
her life of public service was
underpinned by one crucial understanding
that the country she came to symbolize
is bigger than any one individual or any
one Institution
it is the sum total of all our history
and all our endeavors
and it will endure
the late Queen would have wanted us to
redouble our efforts to turn our collar
up and face the storm
to carry on
most of all she would want us to
remember that it is in these moments
that we must pull together
this house is a place where ideas and
ideals are debated of course that leads
to passionate disagreement of course
temperatures can run High
but we all do it
in pursuit of something greater
we do it because we believe we can make
this great country and its people
greater still
at this moment of uncertainty
where our country feels caught between a
past it cannot relive
and a future yet to be revealed
we must always remember one of the great
lessons of our Queen's reign
that we are always better when we rise
above the petty the trivial the
day-to-day
to focus on the things that really
matter the things that unite us
rather than those which divide us
our Elizabethan age may now be over
but her Legacy will live on forever
and as the children of that era it falls
upon us to take that Legacy forward
to show the same love of country the
love of one another
as she did
to show empathy and compassion as she
did
and to get Britain through this dark
night and bring it into the dawn
as she did
we joined together today not just to say
goodbye to our Queen
to share in our morning
but to say something else important
God Save the King
because as one era ends
so another begins
King Charles III has been a devoted
servant of this country his entire life
he has been a powerful voice for
fairness and understood the importance
of the environment long before many
others
as he ascends to his new role with the
queen consort by his side
the whole house
indeed the whole country
will join today to wish him a long happy
and successful reign
Mr Speaker the emotions we see Across
the Nation today
are echoed across the Commonwealth to
which Our Queen was so committed
in the church to which Our Queen was so
devoted
and in the armed forces which she led
and her family served
around the world people will be United
in mourning for her passing
and United in celebrating her life
we've already seen beautiful tributes
flow from across the world it will be
impossible to capture them all here
but each one is a reminder of the esteem
in which she was held
of what she achieved on behalf of her
country
of the shared values we treasure
the reason our loss feels so profound
is not just because she stood at the
head of our country for 70 years
but because in spirit
she stood amongst us
as we move forward
as we Forge A New Path as we build
towards a better future
she will always be with us
for all she gave us and all she will
continue to give us
we say thank you
May Our Queen rest in peace
God Save the King
I now call on the father house said
Peter bottomley
yeah
the constituents will wish me briefly to
record their love respect and gratitude
to her late Majesty
we can give continuing life to her
values and virtues of kindness
aspiration perseverance and pride
we thank her
we miss her and we should say what she
would wish God Save the King
yeah
[Music]
I now call on the leader of the SNP in
Blackford
thank you Mr Speaker it is of course
with great sadness that we unite to
offer our prayers
focus our subtle
and gather our Collective thoughts on
the passing of her majesty the queen
on behalf of the Scottish national party
I would like to offer my condolences as
we hold the queen and our family and our
thoughts and prayers at this difficult
time
the grief and mourning which
reverberates around this chamber and
across the world
will be all the more acute for the king
and members of the royal family only
they can understand the deep personal
loss of a close family member and people
across Society who have similarly lost
loved ones will understand the pain that
they must feel as we ensure our
heartfelt condolences are with them
today
over the coming days people up and down
these islands will seek to come to terms
in their own private way with the loss
of one of the true constants in our
lives
in that regard my thoughts are also with
our own prime minister just days into
office and having to come to terms with
the enormity of the loss of the head of
state and show the leadership that is
now required in her position
we can also help but dwell on The Late
Queen who right to the end fulfilled her
duties by appointing the new prime
minister
but of course many will feel this as a
deeply personal loss
for the Queen's continuous and abiding
presence and the leadership she has
shown over seven decades will be the
enduring marker to a remarkable tenure
as our head of standard
Her Majesty the queen has been Head of
State for longer than most of us have
been alive and the majority of us have
never known a public life without the
queen at the helm
for many she has been a steady hand
guiding the ship
and the Perpetual symbol of stability
15 Prime Ministers and five first
Ministers of Scotland have benefited
from our institutional knowledge and of
course our wise counsel
as the figurehead of the Commonwealth
she was a unifying force recognized the
world over visiting at least 117
countries and was committed to
celebrating the diverse values and
cultures around the globe all born out
of a duty to serve
during her Reign the world has changed
immeasurably
through the good times and the bad times
through War and Peace through boom and
bust through the advances in technology
and communication and the dawn of the
internet age to many she was a Guiding
Light ever present as she bore witness
to the evolution of these islands into
the modern era
a thread of continuity running through
the fabric of the Commonwealth at one's
time societies to her shared histories
and making new history
I like many others in this chamber was
fortunate to meet the queen on a number
of occasions and was always struck by
the strands the intellect the Mother's
Day the humility
and often the humor with which she
approached her royal duties
and while I have always met her in a
professional context as Monarch I'm
struck with just how many people across
Scotland and indeed across the United
Kingdom have had a first-hand encounter
with the queen
whether they have been invited to her
Hollywood Garden parties or had the
pleasure to meet with her and the many
hundreds of events walkabouts and
official openings including that at our
Scottish Parliament or whether she had
taken them Holy by surprise with chance
encounters on the countryside or
Villages near Balmoral people on the
Lenten Brent of Scotland have their own
Tales of their individual meetings with
the queen
because she was a monarch who reigned
with compassion and integrity
and established a deep connection with
the public
and the affection which the queen had
for Scotland and that Scotland had for
the queen
cannot be underestimated
on the Queen's first visit to Scotland
following her coronation the moderator
of the general assembly of the Church of
Scotland said to her today you and I are
Scotland greeting with all that we have
to offer of love and Duty our gracious
young Queen
we can today do back on these words and
say that for as long as her majesty
reigned both she and Scotland held true
to these values of love and Duty for one
another
speaking when she reconvened her
Scottish parliament in 1999 Her Majesty
set at the obligation on members
to set lasting standards of vision and
purpose of debate and discussion not
just for our own generation
for future Generations
and it is clear that members across the
Scottish Parliament and I trust in this
place from all walks of political life
have moved forward with that sense of
vision and purpose in mind
[Applause]
there is a deeply held sense of
responsibility across political parties
to govern for the betterment of future
Generations
in our case to uphold the values of the
Scottish Parliament which are described
in the ceremonial maze wisdom Justice
compassion and integrity the values that
set the aspirations for a modern
Scotland the values that so often
embodied by her majesty herself
and in what was sadly her final ever
address to the Scottish Parliament her
love of Scotland and its people was
clear
when she said
it is the people that make a place and
there are few places where this is truer
than it is in Scotland
the relationship between Scotland and
the queen was one of shared admiration
indeed while she was everyone's Queen
for many in Scotland
she was Elizabeth Queen of Scots
Her Majesty's roots in Scotland Run Deep
she was descended from the Royal House
of Stuart on both sides and her family
of course her mother was from glams and
Angus
it is clear that these Family Ties gave
way to a great and enduring affection
and Scotland was a place that was truly
held dear to her not only in an official
capacity but in a private capacity as
well it is well known that Balmoral with
its beautiful and Atmospheric scenery
was the Queen's favorite home
Borough was a place where she was able
to enjoy Freedom peace and the ability
to indulge a love of The Great Outdoors
whether that was walking with our dogs
riding with horses hosting picnics and
barbecues or from behind the wheel of
her Land Rover
it is clear that balmoro has been a
place of peace and Sanctuary for her
throughout her whole life and perhaps
particularly so following the death of
her husband life companion and love his
Royal Highness Prince Philip Duke of
Edinburgh
it is therefore perhaps fitting that she
has met her final piece at Balmoral
place where she found such enjoyment and
comfort
and as someone of demonstrably strong
faith she will now have enduring peace
with herself and of course to be
reunited with Prince Philip
Her Majesty was a life of Grace and
wisdom defined by its service to the
public and by the lives that she touched
her Legacy and her enduring presence
will live on
God bless the queen
may she rest in peace
God bless the King
Boris Johnson
thank you Mr Speaker I hope the house
will not mind if I begin with a personal
confession a few months ago the BBC came
to see me to talk about her majesty the
queen and we sat down and the cameras
started rolling and they requested that
I should talk about her in the past
tense
and I'm afraid I simply choked up and I
couldn't go on I'm really not easily
moved to tears but I was so overcome
with sadness that I had to ask them to
go away
and I know that today there are
countless people
in this country and around the world
who have experienced the same sudden
access of unexpected emotion
and I think millions of us are trying to
understand why we are feeling this deep
and personal and almost familial
sense of loss
perhaps it's partly that she's always
been there a changeless human reference
point in British life the person who all
the surveys say appears most often in
our dreams
so I'm varying in her pole star Radiance
that we have perhaps been lulled into
thinking that she might be in some way
eternal
but I think our shock is Keener today
because we are coming to understand in
her death
the full magnitude of what she did for
us all
and think of what we asked that 25 year
old woman
all those years ago
to be the person so globally trusted
that her image should be on every unit
of our currency
every postage stamp
the person in whose name all Justice is
dispensed in this country every law
passed to whom every minister of the
crown swears Allegiance and for whom
every member of our armed services is
pledged if necessary to lay down their
lives
think what we asked of her in that
moment
not just to be the living embodiment in
in her DNA of the history and continuity
and unity of this country
but to be the figurehead of our entire
system
the Keystone in the vast arch of the
British State a role that only she could
fulfill because in the brilliant and
durable bargain of the constitutional
monarchy only she could be trusted to be
above any party political or commercial
interest and to Incarnate
impartially
the very concept and essence of the
nation
think what we asked of her and think
what she gave
she showed the world
not just how to Reign Over a people she
showed the world how to give
how to love and how to serve
and as we look back at that vast Arc of
service it's sheer duration is almost
impossible to take it she was the last
living person in British public life to
have served in uniform in the Second
World War
she was the first female member of the
royal family in a thousand years to
serve full-time in the armed forces
and that impulse to do her Duty carried
her right through into her tenth decade
to the very moment
in Balmoral as my ride on rupender said
only three days ago
when she saw off her 14th prime minister
and welcomed her 15th and I can tell you
in that audience
she was as radiant and as knowledgeable
and as fascinated by Politics as ever I
can remember
and as wise in her advice as anyone I
know if not wiser
and over that extraordinary span of
public service with her naturally
retentive and inquiring mind I think and
that lists many of the 15 would agree
that she became the greatest Statesman
earned Diplomat of all and
she knew instinctively
how to cheer up
the nation how to lead a celebration I
remember
innocent Joy
more than 10 years ago after the opening
ceremony of the London Olympics when I
told her that the leader of a friendly
Middle Eastern country seemed actually
to believe that she had jumped out of a
helicopter
in a pink dress and parachuted into the
stadium and I remember her equal
pleasure on being told just a few weeks
ago that she had been a Smash Hit in her
performance with Paddington Bear
and perhaps more importantly
she knew how to keep us going when times
were toughest
when this country and this democracy
faced the real possibility of Extinction
she gave a broadcast
aged only 14 that was intended to
reassure the children of Britain
she said then
we know every one of us that in the end
all will be well
she was right
and she was right again in the darkest
days of the covered pandemic when she
came on our screens and told us that we
would meet again and we did
and I now speak for other prime
ministers
when I say x Prime Ministers when I say
that she helped to comfort
and guide us
as well as the nation because
she had the patience and the sense of
History
to see that troubles come and go and
that disasters are seldom as bad as they
see
and it was that indomitability
that humor
that work ethic and that sense of
History which Together made her
Elizabeth the Great
and when I call her that I should add
one Elizabeth the great I should add one
final quality of course which was her
humility
her single bar electric fire
Tupperware using refusal to be grand
and unlike us politicians
with our outriders and our armor plated
convoys I can tell you as a direct
eyewitness
that she drove herself in her own car
with no detectives and no bodyguard
bouncing at alarming speed over the
Scottish landscape to the total
amazement of the Ramblers and the
tourists we encountered
and it is that
indomitable spirit with which she
created the modern constitutional
monarchy
an institution so strong and so happy
and so well understood not just in this
country but in the Commonwealth
and around the world that the succession
has already seamlessly taken place
and I believe she would regard it as her
own highest achievement that her son
Charles III were clearly an amply follow
her own extraordinary standards of Duty
and service
and the fact that today we can say with
such confidence
God Save the King
is a tribute to him
but above all to Elizabeth the great who
worked so hard
for the good of her country not just now
but for generations to come
that is why we mourn her so deeply
and it is in the depths of our grief
that we understand why we loved her so
much
of the house are at home
thank you Mr Speaker and what an
excellent speech from the right
honorable member for Oxbridge which I'm
sure will have resonated in every member
of this house and indeed everyone in
this country it was a brilliant speech
um I'm grateful for the opportunity to
make my tribute to the queen and to do
so on my own behalf but also on behalf
of my constituents particularly Those
Who coming from commonwealth countries
in Africa and the Caribbean held the
queen in such high regard we're a
constitutional monarchy and for we MPS
the queen was ever present in the
interwoven relationship between the
Monarch and her Parliament she
underpinned our democratic system for
over 70 years underpinning it but never
interfere eating in it she was always
Salient but never meddled
she avoided controversy not by staying
in the background far from it she
performed her role to the utmost but she
did it by respecting the boundaries
she carried out her duties and gave us
her full commitment for us to carry out
ours
when many denigrated she always
respected and supported Parliament and
we should be very grateful for that
between her ministers and not just Prime
Ministers there was regular contact
after Labor won the election in 1997 I
went up to the Palace where likely other
new secretaries of State she pointed me
to the privy Council and bestowed on me
the seals of office they are actual
seals which are given to you and you
take back to your department to be
locked in a safe
but when just a year later I was sacked
Wheels
taken out of the safe and taken back to
Buckingham Palace my diary was empty and
my phone stopped ringing uh my office
was astonished to get a call from
Buckingham Palace no one else wanted to
have anything to do with me but the
queen wanted to see me I was invited to
take Queen to take tea with the queen
for her to thank me for my service as
Secretary of State
the point my point is that the
relationship between our Queen and
Parliament and our Queen and government
was never just on paper but was always
active and always encouraging
she radiated British values of Duty
patriotism
internationalism charity and service but
while she embodied British values she
never intervened in politics
and that is constitutional Alchemy
nothing less
it's evident that everyone even those
who don't agree with the hereditary
principle of the monarchy cannot but
Marvel at her personal qualities
and I want to Marvel at how she could do
all this flawlessly not just over so
many decades but as a woman starting her
reign in what was emphatically then a
man's world
we have to remember what attitudes were
at the time the order of the day was men
were in charge and women were
subservient the man was head of the
household and the role of a woman was to
get married have his children and
support him
in the 1950s when she was crowned I was
a child and I remember my mother warning
me that people thought men knew more
than women that men's views were
valuable whilst women's were to be
disregarded and so it was in that
atmosphere that she stepped up as a 25
year old married woman with two children
to take her place at the head of this
nation and play a huge role on the world
stage
what determination and courage that must
have taken the Prime Minister she dealt
with were mostly men mostly twice her
age
things were very different a huge change
has taken place during her Reign things
were very different when six years ago
she threw open Buckingham Palace for us
to celebrate the 70th anniversary of
BBC's women's hour to celebrate how much
women had achieved
as Sir Tony Blair said she was the
matriarch of this nation a matriarch for
us on the world stage
and a matriarch II at home in her own
family
as well as being our Monarch she was the
mother of four children had many
grandchildren and great-grandchildren
and it is to her family that I extend my
deepest sympathies for their loss and
condolences for their grief which we all
share
Theresa May
thank you Mr Speaker it is with great
sadness that I Rise to pay tribute to
her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II
on my behalf and on behalf of my
maidenhead constituents
yesterday was a day that we all knew
would come sometime
but in our hearts of Hearts we hoped
never would
but as we mourn a beloved monarch we
must always remember that she was a
mother a grandmother and a great
grandmother and my thoughts and prayers
are with King Charles III
and the whole of the royal family
and I also remember the close members of
her royal household
Queen Elizabeth II was quite simply the
most remarkable person I have ever met
I am sometimes asked among all the world
leaders I met who was the most
impressive
and I have no hesitation in saying that
from all the heads of state and
government the most impressive person I
met was her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth
II
she gave a lifetime of service as she
promised to do when she was 21.
her selfless devotion to duty was an
inspiration and example to us all
she was respected and laughed
not just here in the United Kingdom and
in her other Realms and the Commonwealth
but across the world
and that love respect and admiration was
born not out of her position
but because of the person she was
a woman of dignity and Grace
of compassion and warmth
of mischief and joy
of wisdom and experience
and of a deep understanding of her
people
like so many until last evening
I had never known another monarch
she was a constant throughout our lives
always there for us uniting us at times
and difficulty
and as others have said most recently
during covert when she gave us hope that
we would once more come together
her passing marks a generational change
not just because of the length of her
service but because of what she lived
through when we marked the 75th
anniversary of the D-Day Landings in
2019 she was with the world leaders not
just as Queen
but as someone who had worn uniform
during the second world war an
experience which quite apart from
anything else had taught her how to
strip an engine
the queen was always interested in
people
when she walked into a room the faces of
those present were lit up and her
magnificent smile would calm nerves and
put people at their ease
as I said on her platinum and Jubilee I
saw that at chogham in 2018 when there
was a reception at Windsor before a
lunch and the leaders were gathered and
talking amongst themselves and I knew
her majesty was going to join the
reception but they didn't
the minute she walked into the room
the sense of love and respect was
palpable and they all turned and they
all wanted to speak to her
they loved her and she loved the
Commonwealth and the Commonwealth today
is a significant part of her Legacy
but I also saw that on other occasions
including on what was one of her last if
not the last appearance she made in
public when she came to open Thames
Hospice in my maidenhead constituency
in July
the moment she walked through the door
the atmosphere in the room changed you
felt the love and respect of the people
there for her
and as she spoke to staff and patients
she exuded a warmth and Humanity which
put people at their ease
she was Queen but she embodied us
across the nations of the world and for
so many people meeting Queen Elizabeth
simply made their day and for many will
be the memory of their life
of course for those of us who had the
honor to serve as one of her prime
ministers those meetings were more
frequent with the weekly audiences
these were not meetings with a high and
mighty monarch but a conversation
with a woman of experience and knowledge
and immense wisdom
they were also the one meeting I went to
which I knew would not be briefed out
[Laughter]
what what made those audiences so
special was the understanding the queen
had of issues which came from the work
she put into her red boxes combined with
her years of experience she knew many of
the world leaders in some cases she had
known their fathers
and she was a wise and a Droid judge of
people
the conversations that the audiences
were special but so were weekends at
Balmoral where the queen wanted all her
guests to enjoy themselves and she was a
thoughtful hostess
she would take an interest in what books
were put in your room
and she didn't always expect to be the
center of attention
she was quite happy sometimes to sit
playing her form of patience While
others were mingling around her chatting
to each other
my husband tells of the time he had a
dream
he dreamed that he was sitting in the
back of a Range Rover being driven
around a Balmoral estate and the driver
was her majesty the queen
and the passenger seat was occupied by
his wife the Prime Minister
and then he woke up and realized it was
reality
[Laughter]
Her Majesty loved the countryside and
she was down to earth and a woman of
Common Sense
I remember one picnic at Balmoral which
was taking place in one of the bosses on
the estate the hampers came from the
castle and we all mucked in to put the
food and drink out on the table
I picked up some cheese put it on a
plate and was transferring it to the
table
the cheese fell on the floor I Split
Second decision to make
[Laughter]
I picked up the cheese put it on the
plate and put it on the table
and I turned round to see that my every
move
had been watched very carefully by her
majesty the queen
I looked at her
she looked at me
and she just smiled
and the cheese remained on the table
this is indeed a sad day
but it is also a day of celebration of a
life well spent in the service of others
there have been many words of tribute
and superlatives used to describe her
late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II
but these are not hype they are entirely
Justified
she was our longest serving monarch
she was respected around the world
she United our nation in times of
trouble
she joined in our celebrations with joy
and a mischievous smile
she gave an example to us all
of faith of service of Duty of dignity
of decency
she was remarkable
and I doubt we will ever see her like
again
may she rest in peace and rise in glory
so Ed David
it's a real pleasure to follow the right
honorable lady
and can I congratulate her on her lovely
heartwarming speech
Mr Speaker liberal Democrats join
members from all sides of the house
expressing our deepest condolences on
the passing of her majesty the queen
we are mourning a profound loss
the queen was a formidable monarch
who Faithfully served our country for
all her life
and was loved the world over
she represented not only duty and
courage but warmth and compassion
and she was a living reminder of our
Collective past
of the greatest generation and their
sacrifices for our freedom
for many people myself included Her
Majesty was an ever fixed Mark in our
lives
as the world changed around us and
politicians came and went she was our
nation's constant
in challenging times he was always a
source of calm and comfort
and she tied our Nations together
embodying an unwavering pride in our
country
showing us that patriotism is not
defined by political allegiance
and reminding us of the many things that
bind us all together even when it
doesn't always feel that way
we saw this so vividly during the
Platinum Jubilee celebrations in June
I'm proud to represent the oldest Royal
Borough in England
Kingston upon Thames
and our Jubilee Street parties certainly
lived up to that status it was truly
wonderful to see such an outpouring of
affection from people across Kingston
from all walks of life school children
who baked Jubilee cakes neighbors who
shared bunting choirs who sang hymns of
praise
and it was incredibly fitting wasn't it
but after so long kept apart by covid it
was the queen
and a celebration of her match this
Reign that brought our communities back
together so joyfully
just as the whole country is United
today so sadly in grief
the Deep morning across the country now
just like the celebrations have a
jubilee a few months ago
comes not from a sense of Duty
but from genuine and heartfelt affection
Love
an admiration of her majesty
it was not because we were her subjects
but because she was truly Our Queen
what she meant to us is perhaps best
summed up by phrase on so many people's
lips over the last 24 hours
I can't imagine our country without her
for almost everyone in our country she
has been there our whole lives
times of national grief and National
Jubilation she has never not been there
for us
so it's hard to accept that she is gone
and hard to see how we go on without her
but we will
our great United Kingdom has a great
future
because the Queen's Spirit of strength
Grace and resolve lives on in her people
one of the greatest privileges of being
a member of this house
was the chance to meet her majesty
like when she visited Kingston on the
occasion of a golden jubilee
when I was deeply privileged to sit next
to her at lunch at Windsor Castle
I was initially confused by a silver
cylinder beside her place setting
I wondered to myself what Treasures it
might hold
I had my suspicions when a dessert was
served her beloved corgis will let him
and nestled themselves around her feet
and the queen lifted up the lid of the
cylinder
plucked out some digestive biscuits
and began sneaking them to her Grateful
Dogs
yeah
whenever I met her I was struck by her
warmth her wisdom and her humor and I'm
looking forward to hearing similar
stories from honorable and writing
members across the house
as they give glimpses of the wonderful
person beneath the crown
Steve will remembered With Honor
as a monarch who guided our country out
of the shadow of a terrible War
who helmed us calmly through Troubled
Waters
and brought us safely into a new
millennium
and she will remembered so fondly
as the Monarch who leapt from a
helicopter with James Bond
and showed Paddington where she kept her
marmalade sandwiches
and for the Royal Family
she will be remembered simply as a
beloved mother grandmother and
great-grandmother
our thoughts prayers and condolences are
with them all as they bear this terrible
loss
or a light after a lifetime of dedicated
and tireless service to our country and
our Commonwealth
Her Majesty has gone to her Eternal rest
may God Rest her soul
and may God Save the King
now come to Sir Ian Duncan Smith
Mr Speaker I'm grateful um
so much has already been said I don't
intend
to repeat it much but I just want to say
that it is a sad day for all of us it's
tragic news
bringing to the end a remarkable career
spanning 70 years endless prime
ministers
and endless leaders of the opposition to
but for those 70 years Majesty carried
out her duties with charm humility not
often mentioned real humility and also
endless humor
she was quite remarkable in a way and
she learned that from somebody that we
haven't mentioned today her father
who in his own way someone who never
expected in a way to be
the Monarch who suffered a very
significant problem in a speech
impediment
and yet he showed her
that it was possible to rise above the
challenge
and to deliver your service to your
country at an incredible time and that
service and Duty there is no question
she learned at the knees of her father
overcoming his own difficulties and
putting his country and their service
first something quite often forgotten
about
and a couple of things that come to mind
because in fact so often we've taken her
majesty for granted we expect her to be
there
the way the crowds whenever anything is
good or bad in our country they gather
at Buckingham Palace whether she's there
or she was there or not there they
gathered it was almost as though they
could touch the the railings and draw
some sucker or some support for some
sort of mystical help and there they
were again last night in pouring rain
outside Buckingham Palace
well quite often in all of that Mr
Speaker we often forgot that she was
also a human being
with her own family issues and problems
and I remember particularly during that
period when two of her sons were facing
marriage breakups which were being
widely reported in the newspapers in the
media with everybody speculating in
public about all that was going on I
wonder how many in this house
could ever have borne something like
that in such public domain such a sad
tragedy for their mother and then to top
it all Windsor Castle burns down
a place she loved deeply and felt
responsible for
and nobody seemed to take her in a way
into consideration until
when she approached a speech with a
interesting cold
and she said that the year for her had
been her anus horribulus
I think the public stopped
we all paused and we realized actually
that we had forgotten that we owe as
much Duty and service to her as she had
shown us without complaint I thought
that was a remarkable moment really when
the country came back from where it was
to recognize that Duty and service
and the other was when
Diana then Princess of Wales
tragically died in that terrible car
accident
and everybody again gathered
outside Buckingham Palace and they
demanded
that the queen should come it got more
and more shrill with the newspapers
banging on about how she had to come
back
but there she was in Balmoral
trying to do what almost any single
mother grandmother wanted to do which is
to put her arms around her grandchildren
Comfort them and protect them from what
she knew was going to descend upon them
and finally when she came down I grew to
the realization that actually
it wasn't that they were angry that she
wasn't there
it was at the British public needed her
there to be able to show their own
emotion as she was the focus for all of
that and when she came
everybody cheered and applauded because
she was there and now they could grieve
properly because she was the focus for
that grief
and of course we have anecdotes about uh
what we did and I remember when I had
ceased being leader of the conservative
party it happens quite a lot really
I I think she was pretty used to it
actually yes
but she kindly asked me to take leave of
her officially which I thought was
pretty kind really as uh said earlier on
nobody else wanted me to do it so it was
decent over to do it um and I remember
when I came to the palace and I was
ushered into her drawing room small
personal sitting room I was struck by
two or three things one was the two bar
electric fire which had a very strange
piece of cardboard cut out in the shape
of flames colored with crayons I suspect
by some uh somebody in the palace yellow
and red surrounding the two bar fire
which I thought was peculiarly dangerous
but
notwithstanding that I'm sure it had a
purpose the other one was the Tupperware
Ray radio sitting next to her which I
hadn't seen since my parents smashed
their last one and then she very sweetly
asked me how I was being clearly
sympathetic about what had happened and
I just Shrugged and said Well ma'am
nobody died and I'm still here whereupon
she roared with laughter and the funny
thing was as she did she paused looking
at me not sure whether I'd actually made
a joke or whether I'd not
I laughed too and then she laughed again
whether at me or with me I couldn't
figure that out
that was something to relish and the
other uh anecdote I just wanted to share
with the house for a second was
slightly different it was when I was in
one of those privy councils and for some
reason we were offered drinks to have at
the end of the privy Council didn't
happen very often so I took full
advantage and ordered a whiskey and
while we had finished the privy Council
she came round to talk to those of us in
the preview Council and chat
and she came to me and uh like everybody
else nervous as anything I I stumbled
through and then I said oh Ma'am I
remember I just been doing reading some
stuff about one of Churchill's speeches
and I suddenly recalled something that
he had said
um at the time it was 1941 and President
Roosevelt had sent a note over with the
person that he had just defeated in his
third election and in it as Churchill
said he had written in his own hand a
verse from Longfellow now remember in 41
we didn't know whether we would survive
or not
and Churchill read it out and I started
to speak it and she started speaking it
as well and I just want to share it with
the house
it was Ceylon Ceylon o ship of State
Ceylon o Union strong and great Humanity
with all its fears with all its hopes
for future years is hanging breathless
on thy fate
she said it perfectly
she smiled slightly and I did detect a
little dampness in her eye and then she
moved on and in a way it suddenly struck
me
that that was exactly her
she is was the ship of State
we looked to her for everything good and
in difficult times
she loved the union with a passion
and she loved Scotland
I think probably most of all
the track was that was who she was she
was that ship of state and somehow we
have too often taken her for granted but
she has never complained and she always
gave us service
and now for that Union of hearts
if the house would indulge me
I want to
quote from wh Warden with a few changes
stop all the clocks
cut out the telephones
prevent the dogs from barking with the
juicy bone
silence the piano and with muffled drums
bring out the coffin
at the mourners come
she was a north or south east and west
a working week and our Sunday rest
our noon our midnight our talk Our Song
we thought that love would last forever
we were wrong
may God bless her and keep her
and hold her in her hands
and may we bless the Royal Family
God Save the King
I'm now going to bring Sir Jeffrey
Donaldson in but can I just warn others
that I would hope to get someone in
today that please if we can use up to
three minutes after Sir Jeffrey
Donaldson so Jeffrey
thank you Mr Speaker remember half of uh
my colleagues in the Democratic unionist
party and on behalf of Benny across
Northern Ireland I wish to offer our
sincere sympathy to his majesty the king
and to other members of the royal family
on the passing of our dear Sovereign
Queen Elizabeth II
in counties Antrim and Arma down and for
Mana
Londonderry and Tyrone individuals and
families will gather in their
communities to remember a great monarch
a monarch who stood with us
in our time of trouble
Her Majesty the queen has been a
steadfast and unshakable Head of State
for the United Kingdom
and for the Commonwealth and her
gracious approach has been as others
have said a constant throughout our
lives
in 1952 during her first Christmas
broadcast Queen Elizabeth asked the
nation to pray
and I quote that God may give me wisdom
and strength to carry out the solemn
promises I shall be making
and that I may Faithfully serve him and
you all the days of my life
she certainly fulfilled her promises
and today we mourn her passing
but we do so with tremendous honor for
one who served God and her people
Faithfully
Her Majesty led by example in Northern
Ireland and reached out the hand of
friendship to help with the
reconciliation process
we are Judy boned to build on that
Foundation
the royal visit to the Republic of
Ireland in 2011 was groundbreaking
and the warmth with which Her Majesty
was received demonstrated that she was
revered and respected far beyond this
United Kingdom
I remember with fondness Her speech
during that visit where she again
referred to her Christian convictions
and reminded us that forgiveness lies at
the heart of her faith and that it can
reconcile divided communities
her visits to my own constituency in
Lagoon Valley to the city of lisburn to
dramour and of course to Royal
Hillsborough
invoke Precious Memories for the
residents and for all of us
and I know that her death will be felt
acutely in Hillsborough and in the
surrounding communities
during the most traumatic of Days of Our
troubled past in Northern Ireland
Her Majesty visited with us many times
to show solidarity with her people
in their darkest of ours
her presence conveyed a deep sense of
stability
and offered hope to so many
one such visit was in 1976 in one of the
most violent years of the troubles
in her Christmas address later that year
Her Majesty spoke of the need for an end
to the conflict and pointed the way to
peace and Reconciliation
she reminded us that the following year
was her silver jubilee
and expressed in Hope
that and I quote the gift I would most
value next year is that reconciliation
should be found wherever it is needed
a Reconciliation which would bring peace
and security to families and Neighbors
at present suffering and torn apart
yet just a few short years later her
majesty too was touched by the violence
of the troubles
and her family endured the hurt and the
Deep pain of losing a loved one
following the assassination by the IRA
of the Earl mountbatten at molloch Moore
in County Sligo in August 1979.
she shared the sense of loss felt by
countless victims under empathy and
understanding offered Comfort to so many
from all backgrounds
she Rose above that sense of loss to
reach out across divided communities in
Northern Ireland and to offer hope
this is real leadership
yet it took us almost 20 long years to
complete our journey to a peace
agreement
an agreement that offered the prospect
of bringing about that reconciliation
that her majesty Queen Elizabeth yearned
to see
some 25 years on from that agreement
interests Mr Speaker we still struggle
to deal with the legacy of our troubled
past
your majesty
on an island driven by conflict and
Division
you were a bridge builder
reaching out to those from opposite
sides of the divide and your work of
reconciliation helped to heal wounds and
to encourage change
your historic visit to the Republic of
Ireland was a cathartic moment in
British Irish relations
the way you conducted yourself the
language you used and the message that
you brought
helped to lay to rest many of the ghosts
of our shared history
that I've cast their Shadows over
relationships on these islands for
centuries
it is my hope that your passing
and the example you set will inspire us
to even greater Heights
and to complete the journey that will
bring true healing and Reconciliation to
our troubled land
your majesty
this United Kingdom has been truly
blessed to have you as our head of state
a sovereign who's dignified and faithful
service has inspired a nation
I can do no better than quote the words
of a book that contains the values you
sought to uphold throughout your reign
well done
good and faithful servant
our United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland is stronger for urine
unto his majesty King Charles III
I say this
we must all work to build this Kingdom
that it is even stronger
and more united
and we on this side
will use all our endeavors
to achieve these objectives
God Save the King
with many of the very passionate
comments that we have heard already this
afternoon Mr Speaker and there have been
many thousands of move-in and heartfelt
tributes from across the world
Our Queen was loved cherished respected
and admired for her deep Devotion to
public service and to the people and of
course we meet in circumstances that we
all knew would happen one day but of
course none of us wanted to see and Mr
Speaker was so poignant yesterday that
the heavens opened and cried with the
country as a devastating news broke that
this period of national mourning began
for most of us if not all in this
chamber and of course people across the
country and the Commonwealth and across
the world but in you our queen as the
head of state once offering a lady one
monarch
and the late Queen Elizabeth's second's
life was one that of course was
dedicated to public service but was
deeply deeply inspiring and of course
she held that dignified presence that
ability the Charisma that this house has
heard so much of already this morning to
lead our nation through dark periods but
also through the most joyous moments
that we have celebrated as a country
and of course from the horrors in the
world wars to the fears of the pandemic
she was one who never ever faltered in
her Duty and of course as my rotable
friend has already said she was that
wrong but she was there as that model of
assurance that pillar that would give us
the strength and support that we would
need through the darkest times
but of course Mr Speaker for each and
every one of us and for all of our
constituents in particular a royal visit
was one of the most joyous moments and
occasions that we would all celebrate
they were wonderful they were memorable
they were great events and in particular
when the visitor of course was her
majesty the queen
and a few months after my election to
Parliament in 2010 I of course witnessed
that excitement when her majesty the
queen visited that very famous Village
of tiptree in the Whitton constituency
yeah where the Royal warrant told in
Wilkin and Sons Jam makers to mark their
125th anniversary
the affection and warmth that was shown
towards her majesty of course was
astonishing to see not astonishing to
see I should say and of course Queen
Elizabeth reciprocated where she touched
everyone's Hearts taking the time to see
everyone to speak to everyone as well he
also when including the famous
inspections of the world famous jams
including the production lines off the
Christmas puddings that so many people
in this house in particular have
recently enjoyed and of course despite
those huge undertakings year after year
each and every person that she touched
felt special and that was a tremendous
Mark of her own humility and that day
now nearly 12 years ago remains fresh in
the minds of my constituents who are
more in sadly with the entire nation
today
and of course it's not just raw visits
that marked her majesty and gave us all
that moment of excitement to have seen
her majesty the queen for those of us
that enjoy horses and enjoy racing in
particular she herself was well known
across not just the country but also
around the world for her love and
passion of horses whether it was the
famous visits to Ascot or Epsom the
Derby itself all of those who attended
wanted to just snip that moment with her
to get that glimmer hoping to get that
rural way or Reason of famous Racing Tip
as well and of course no one did more to
Champion horse racing in this country
than the late Queen she loved the sport
she loved her horses and in return the
whole racing industry loved her and will
miss her enormously hello Majesty led a
remarkable life Mr Speaker and delivered
an era and rain that will stand out as
being the most magnificent in the long
great history of of our nation
as we mourn the end of her 70th year
reign we commemorate the great life that
she lived and of course the long service
to distinguished service that she gave
to our country
we reflect on the importance of the
Monarch in our public life of course and
at this particular time a moment in time
our thoughts and prayer are naturally
with her family and we offer our
wholehearted support and of course our
commitment to the King King Charles III
and the years ahead while we face of
course while the faces on our notes and
coins and stamps will of course change
her late Majesty will always occupy a
special place and an affectionate in the
hearts of our nation go to rest her soul
and God Save the King
Dave Margaret Beckett
yeah
thank you Mr Speaker
um I've heard it said that on occasions
like this most of us talk about
ourselves and that's inevitable because
we're talking about the links we have in
our memories with the person who is gone
but I think perhaps I'm one of the few
in this house who does remember when the
Queen's father died
I must admit my memories are twofold
first how surprised I was that people
thought 25 was young
[Laughter]
and secondly that when she came to the
throne we all got a bar of chocolate
I first encountered Her Majesty at one
remove soon after I was first elected to
this house in October 1974 and I do
recognize that many honorable members
here were not born then
by 1975 I was a junior government whip
we had a small majority and a large
legislative program and there was a duty
that usually fell to a very senior whip
one of writing every day by hand
direct to her majesty the queen to tell
her what was happening in her Parliament
I was told this had probably originated
with the first Prime Minister who wrote
To The King to tell him what was
happening in the house and I was asked
to undertake this duty to help my
colleague
it seems to me
I was told by the way this is very
important that this was a personal
message
from a member of the government to her
majesty for her eyes only
that is relevant
and it seemed to me that there was very
little point in telling her the things
she knew from her red box or that she
had read probably in the chat column in
the in the Delhi Telegraph
so what I wrote to her about was the
stuff that I thought she wouldn't get
from either of those sources I wrote to
her about the gossip
occasionally slightly edited
and I wrote to her about the rose that
people were having behind the scenes in
committee rooms or in corridors
there was no feedback but there wasn't
any rebuke either
but then a day came when the queen went
on an overseas visit now I knew of
course that official correspondents
always goes through official channels
when the queen is out of the country
but I was a very new MP and I thought
that something that was marked from me
personally to the queen personally that
no one would have the impertinence to
read that
some busybody in number 10 however did
perhaps a little unfortunately and and
not unknown to members in this house
there was something of a dispute going
on at the time about the issue of our
relationship with the European community
and I chose the queen what we thought
about it and what we were saying about
it and where where I thought the
Ministers of the day were sometimes
getting it wrong
and the house may not be surprised to
learn I I will not Sully your ears but
there's a short pithy phrase that common
usage that encapsulates encapsulates
really exactly what happened next but
suffice it to say that I was summoned to
the chief Whip and after a brief and
spirited discussion
um the job returns to the person to whom
it is
it was many years later but rather
typically that I heard very indirectly
and subtly that perhaps Her Majesty had
slightly regretted a return to normal
service
and I I thought that was that was
comforting
about that
uh
it was many years later after a short
involuntary
um
break in my service in this house that I
returned for my present constituency
where we have had the great honor to
entertain her majesty on many occasions
not least in everybody's memory when she
opened our new football stadium and
indeed our brand new hospital to which
she was gracious enough to agree we
could give the title of the royal Derby
Hospital which in which it rejoices to
this day
and
over the years three years for example
as president of the council I was
fortunate enough to have many encounters
with her majesty and can absolutely
endorse everything that has been said
and will be said no doubt about her
intelligence her awareness and her
attitude I was also fortunate enough to
be present after the death of our
colleague John Smith the commemoration
of D-Day on the 50th anniversary and to
be in the Queen's company and observe
her and her
utter respect
for the veterans and for the sacrifice
of those days over that period but as I
said I had many encounters with her as
president of the council and indeed as
foreign secretary accompanied her on
state visits where like the right
honorable lady the former prime minister
I heard for example her observations
about the comments made to her by the
mother of a former president
um about the the then present incumbent
and very interesting it was
so I would just testify
to the qualities that of which everyone
else has spoken unto which I'm sure
everyone else will give to give
testimony of her intelligence her
knowledge her sense of humor one of my
Abiding and favorite memories is fairly
not not very recently but some of recent
years people will probably recall it's
often been on the news it's one of my
favorite clips of I think the Duke of
anywhere is being chased by a persistent
B and there's a picture of the queen
coming through an archway giggling
uncontrollably and clearly quite unable
to suppress how hysterically funny she
found it and I think that's very much
sums up
the person that you could see and admire
she was a remarkable person
a remarkable monarch and we are the
poorer for her going
Douglas Ross
thank you very much Mr Speaker often
this place can be criticized for the
debates we have but I think it has risen
to the occasion today in memory of the
late Her Majesty the queen and the
contributions from all sides of the
house show the heartfelt thoughts of
members who have had close experience
and those of us who have met at the
queen very infrequently I met at the
late Her Majesty Queen Elizabeth at the
opening of the Scottish Parliament last
year and I had a short conversation with
her as the leader of the main opposition
party and she moved on to the other
party leaders but I have a picture of
the queen shaking my hand with the
beaming smile that we saw in her last
picture that was taken ample model on
Tuesday and her majesty the queen loves
Scotland and Scotland Loved Her Majesty
the queen and I think it is right that
that picture it was taken by an
excellent Scottish photographer Gene
Barlow who captured Her Majesty looking
very calm very happy and very at home in
Balmoral which she loved I also want to
speak briefly on behalf of my
constituents in Murray who enjoyed
meeting the queen on many occasions at
the most recent visit and her last visit
to Murray was in November 2014 when she
arrived on the Royal Train at Elgin
train station and she went to meet her
Armed Forces at Aria philosomoth and
Atkin Los Barracks because it has been
mentioned today but the armed forces are
important and were important to her
majesty and are important to King
Charles III and will play an extremely
important role in the coming days and
weeks but that visit to November 2014
was accompanied with the late Duke of
Edinburgh and it was their 67th wedding
anniversary and it showed that the
public commitment to service and the
dedication of both her majesty the queen
and the Duke of Edinburgh it meant that
they went about their duties when others
would be celebrating a milestone
anniversary but that was what the queen
provided commitment and dedication at
every opportunity to deliver for people
across the country
we will over the next few days and weeks
remember that commitment from her
majesty the queen and we will in our
thoughts and our prayers think about
King Charles III and the royal family
who are grieving the loss of a loving
mother grandmother and great grandmother
but as we join together to grieve and
mourn we also unite to give thanks and
to celebrate
to celebrate a life well lived to
celebrate a life committed and dedicated
to Public Service a life which has shown
a light throughout the United Kingdom
the Commonwealth and around the world
and the tributes we've heard in this
place today and from leaders across the
globe showed the respect rightly held
for the late Her Majesty of the queen
may she rest in peace and God Save the
King
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I
think probably unlike every previous
speaker I only met the Queen Once and
that was when she visited appropriately
enough the Queen's theater in porn
Church which was then my constituency
when she left she went on and she always
did to go from strength to strength I
left to be ejected from Parliament by
the voters at the following election who
had slightly different experiences after
her visit as the as the leader of the
liberal Democrats has said it's
difficult to imagine the world without
her and that's absolutely true but it's
worth remembering something that is very
rarely remembered and that is that in
1936
after the abdication crisis the monarchy
teetered on the brink
and according to most polls at that time
most British voters thought the monarchy
might not survive for very long now
since 1945
the monarchy has been the most popular
institution in Britain and has pulled
something like 80 percent there's no
institution that's pulled anything like
that level of popularity over such a
sustained period of time now that's not
an accident
it happened for two reasons
both because the queen and her father
George VI had that iron dedication to
Public Service which possibly started in
the most spectacular way when George VI
decided to remain in London during the
war instead of following the advice to
leave London and go elsewhere perhaps
even to Canada as one advisor told him
that started then but the second reason
is that both George VI and Elizabeth II
had an absolutely clear understanding of
the Constitutional parameters of the
role of the monarchy and neither of them
ever strayed outside that role and in
the case of the queen despite repeated
attempts to pull her into Political
controversies including the one that the
first one I can remember was in 1974 we
had a home Parliament
and there were there was Article after
article in the press in those days
saying that the queen should intervene
should pull the parties together the two
big parties perhaps of three big parties
to form some sort of coalition
government and she refused to do it and
she was absolutely right to refuse to to
to do it and she was persistent in that
all the way through and that's her great
legacy that the monarchy has survived is
that popular institution because she
observed those absolutely correct
constitutional parameters and I think we
can all hope that if the new king as I'm
sure he will
observes those parameters and has that
dedication to Public Service which he's
already demonstrated he can reunite and
draw together a nation which is as
bitterly divided as I can remember
game Andrea ledson
yeah yeah
thank you madam Deputy speaker
today was strange to wake up to the
first day without our much loved and
hugely respected Queen Elizabeth II
there is a sense of personal loss as
well as shock
somehow her long years of service
commitment and Duty felt as if they
would never come to an end
as one of the older members of my family
told me just this morning things changed
so much in her and our lifetime and
sometimes we feel hopelessly out of date
and rather uncomfortable she was our
figurehead and for that we are truly
grateful
the Queen's Reign was somehow Timeless
listening back this morning to her first
televised Christmas broadcast in 1957
and then to her broadcast to the nation
during covid Queen Elizabeth II proved
continuity right from the post-war years
through 15 different Prime Ministers
from Sir Winston Churchill to my right
honorable friend the member for
Southwest Norfolk and to the
extraordinary heartwarming Royal digital
performances with James Bond and with
Paddington Bear for me her handbag will
now always contain a marmalade sandwich
I always remember being sworn in as a
privy counselor it was the same day as
my right honorable friend the member for
Uxbridge and we were given the usual
briefing on how you kneel on a footstool
with your right with with your right
hand by your side your left hand holding
a Bible and and my right honorable
friend and I looked at each other and
we're like what what if you fall off
your footstool and we were told very
straightfaced don't worry the queen will
find it very amusing
we didn't find reassuring but luckily it
doesn't happen
as Lord president of the council during
the hung parliament of
2017-2019 I had the honor of regular
audiences with the queen ahead of privy
Council meetings on those occasions I
was always struck by the warmth of the
welcome and the frankness of the
conversation the queen was always
interested to hear updates on the
progress of legislation and the mood of
the house she was very well informed and
also quite challenging at a time of
extraordinary events from brexit to
Donald Trump's visit to behavior
scandals here in Westminster
once a year the leaders of the commons
and Lords would be invited to Windsor
Castle for lunch with the queen and
Prince Philip
these occasions felt quite overwhelming
but at the same time after a pre-lunch
drink in the sitting room and getting
into a conversation about how well the
restoration of Windsor Castle was
presided over by Prince Philip compared
to our own efforts to restore the Palace
of Westminster baroness Evans of Bose
Park and I were very soon distracted as
we sought to defend the indefensible
a happy memory for me is going to
Sandringham for privy Council one
January with log fires burning in the
Queen's corgis pottering around
I recall the queen saying what a very
busy Christmas she'd had and I suggested
well at least her family don't need to
pause Christmas lunch for the Queen's
speech which she told me they most
certainly did as for all of us her
family would pause lunch and watch the
Queen's speech and Princess Charlotte
had run over to the TV screen and said
look there's gangan very heartwarming at
each of the audiences it would strike me
Anew that privy Council meetings were
just one of the many daily duties of the
queen and that her cheerfulness and her
twinkling eyes were always a constant
truly she was a monarch who put the
comfort of others above herself and she
never faltered in her promise to spend
her life devoted to service and as we've
prayed every day sitting in this place
that Queen Elizabeth the first may
always incline to thy will and walk in
thy way so I believe we can now pray
with confidence that after this life she
may attain Everlasting Joy and Felicity
through Jesus Christ Our Lord
Queen Elizabeth II spent her life
building relationships in our nation our
Commonwealth and across the world in her
achievements we can all take comfort and
know that as the crown passes to our new
king we will have the example of her
Legacy to unite Us in loyal allegiance
to her successor King Charles III God
Save the King James
yeah thank you very much Madam Deputy
speaker and it's an honor to
um pay a tribute to her late Majesty
Queen Elizabeth II on behalf of my
constituents in Wallace who were in
shock and mourning today one of the
things that strikes everyone
contemplating this sad news is the sheer
span of the length of time of her Reign
at the longest ever reign in UK history
Someone who lived through an era
profound upheaval and change but who
represented continuity and certainty
amidst the tumult when she was born it's
hard to remember that in 1926 only 10
women had ever been elected into this
place into this House of Commons and at
that time women did not exercise the
vote on the same terms as men thankfully
that has now changed though I always say
that at work to achieve equality is
never done but she as the mother of the
house said earlier LED just by example
she led by being she demonstrated as our
head of state who was clearly obviously
a woman and a wife and a mother how
possible it was uh even if that had been
granted to her by Fate by Destiny to
combine the roles of uh the uh pressure
that she had on her with a family life
her coronation was the first to be
televised now the monarchy has a
presence on social media platforms seen
by billions her Reign has seen the
transition from Empire to Commonwealth
from conflict to peace in Northern
Ireland but also from complacency to
climate emergency which demonstrates to
all of us that we have much to do and
many problems to confront us the values
she personified
um our clear and have been clear from
the comments in this house utter
commitment to public service and Duty a
woman who dedicated her life to the
service of our nation and when she said
at 21 in a broadcast I declared for you
all that my whole life whether it be
long or short shall be devoted to your
service that is a vow that she delivered
as we now know
Faithfully write up until the very end
she personified wisdom and experience
but she did as The Honorable lady who's
just spoken has just said had that
twinkle in her eye whenever you were
waiting in line to meet her majesty you
could see the twinkle and it put you at
ease she first visited rural in 1957 but
during my time in this house she first
came to birkenhead when she opened the
Europa pool in 1996 and finally came to
wallacy for the second time in 2011 to
open the newly rebuilt floral Pavilion
in New Brighton thousands upon thousands
of official duties many many thousands
of my constituents looked forward to her
visits and have fond memories of them
she was always interested always
engaging and always smiling and
reassuring when she interacted with
people who lined the roots to see her on
these fantastic occasions so her loss
will be mourned it's a terrible but
inevitable loss she left us in a place
where we know we can survive the
transition because of the strength she
gave to the institution so may she rest
in peace Madam Deputy speaker and we all
wish the greatest condolences to the
royal family who are going through such
terrible loss now and we look forward to
supporting the new king as much as we've
supported our now sadly Lost Queen
Elizabeth II
such a Javit
it's a pleasure to follow the right
honorable lady Madam Deputy speaker I'm
filled with great sadness as I Rise to
pay tribute to the life and the memory
of her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II
our thoughts are with the royal family
and who have lost a mother a grandmother
and of course a great grandmother
Her Majesty lived an extraordinary life
of service and the touching tributes
that we have already heard from right
honorable and honorable members so far
along with the outpouring of emotion
from across the world including from my
own constituents in bromsgrove District
reflect the Deep affection and love in
which she was held
for over seven decades she was a source
of our strength and comfort a
representative of our closest held
values and beliefs a defender of faith
and an embodiment of the very best of
public service and Duty
she was our North Star
a symbol of strength in difficult times
to put it simply
she was our Queen
right honorable and honorable members
many have shared their their times of
when they were privileged to meet her
late majesty and and I was able to do so
on many occasions and I always welcome
the the huge wisdom she would share the
advice and of course the The Good Humor
I will never forget during the occasion
of the final privy council meeting of
2017.
as the formalities ended
Her Majesty suddenly said
gin and tonic anybody and proceeded to
press a buzzer and with that her staff
promptly burst through the doors of the
1844 room in Bucking Palace armed with
trays of GNT and nibbles
now I'm not much of a g t Drinker myself
but I will certainly was not going to
turn down the opportunity of enjoying
one with her late Majesty
I later learned that she'd like to make
the last preview council meeting of the
Year extra special
so that she could wish everyone a Merry
Christmas
Madam Deputy speaker our country faces
immense challenges and at home and
abroad and the person that has always
been there is there no longer
however in the wake of this terrible
loss it is an opportunity for
parliamentarians from across this house
to renew their commitment to the values
that were embodied by her late Majesty
public service
Duty the national interest
if we can leave this place having
achieved but the smallest fraction of
what her late Majesty achieved our
country would be the better for it after
a lifetime of service
her late Majesty is now at rest
may she rest in peace and God Save the
King yeah let's have a Roberts
I would like to offer my sincerest
sympathies and condolences to him I just
see the Queen's children and her
extended family as they come to terms
with their grief
Queen Elizabeth II has been a constant
presence throughout all our lives she
stood as a figure of stability in a
world that is changing at a rapid and
sometimes frightening Pace the loss of
the continuity that her majesty embodied
is a source of sorrow and anxiety for
people across the world up to her final
days
she conducted her duties with an
extraordinary Dedication that has been
an inspiration for so many of us her
values of Duty service reconciliation
and forgiveness are values that the
people of Wales hold very dear
in Wales we respect people who embody
that sense of dedication to society and
to Public Service who put their public
duty first
Her Majesty the queen personified that
Duty for so many people for so many
years
and her majesty had a canny ability to
put people at ease in the midst of
Palace formality when I was appointed
fortunate to be appointed to the privy
Council three years ago I remember being
being nervous being intimidated by the
protocols and the rules that govern
interactions with the royal family your
mind as it would do tops up an infinite
checklist of everything that could
possibly go wrong
and what struck me was something she
said she said you may well be worrying
that you'll do something wrong or in the
wrong order don't worry whatever could
possibly go wrong I've Seen It All
Before there's nothing that you could do
that would Shock Me Now even among all
the Pomp and ceremony there was that
characteristic warmth and courtesy to
the queen and her majesty was a
magnificent role model for older women
across the world
historically of course older women have
disappeared from public life the queen
was a constant visible figure throughout
the 70 years of her reign
from historic buildings and Charities to
football she always shows an interest in
Wales people of all walks of Welsh life
have been touched by the Queen's Keen
interests and constant support of Welsh
organizations she attended every
official opening of the Senate and
showed due respect for Wales nationhood
and our growing democracy she was Patron
to organizations as diverse as the Royal
Welsh Agricultural Society the Football
Association of Wales Cardiff Royal
infirmary and the Welsh Pony and Cobb
Society her love of horses from
thoroughbreds to Native ponies Sean
through you see it in those sparkling
smiles
everyone in public life knows you have a
public smile but the photos with the
horses that was her real smile
we now see one era drawing to a close
and a new one at its very beginning
for now we will say
thank you very much your majesty
th may she rest in peace bendistu out of
Brennan
God's blessing on the king
Matt Hancock
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
I Rise to share gratitude for the life
of her late Majesty the queen
share sadness for her especially for her
family
and also sadness for the country and the
world that the loss of the greatest
Statesman of our time
I also want to
mark my own personal gratitude for the
advice that her majesty gave me
for her role in particular as has been
mentioned by the most recent former
prime minister for her role in the
bringing the country together and giving
hope in dark times during the pandemic
and I'd also add for taking the rare
step of going public with her health
status when declaring that she'd taken a
vaccination and showing further
leadership
she was much loved of course and loved
across my West Suffolk constituency but
perhaps no more
anywhere than in Newmarket which she
visited so often Newmarket of course is
the jewel in the crown of horse racing
certainly domestically and probably
across the world
and on her many many visits there
she showed that she could walk with
sovereigns and the general public alike
she visited many times it was where I
first met her the first time I met her I
was I was lucky to be with my small
daughter who handed her a Posey and it's
my daughter's first memory and no doubt
will be an abiding one for the rest of
her life and it reminds me of the many
times that I've Seen Her Majesty meeting
the public
and been
impressed and inspired by her sheer
ability to ensure that each person she
meets understands that she is focused
entirely on them and she listened so
well to them knowing no doubt that for
each person she met it was a moment that
that person would remember for the rest
of her life her fortitude at continuing
to do that well into her 90s was
incredible to behold now we in Newmarket
are not always known for our humility
but the one thing we do know is that the
reason that her majesty loved to come to
New Market was not because of us
two-legged beings but because of the
four-legged beings and the her love of
horse racing was perhaps her greatest
love outside her duty to her family and
her country the twinkle that we've heard
so much of and the genuine smile that
came on her face was probably the smile
was probably broadest when at a
racecourse as she demonstrated in what
was probably her last social public
occasion at Ascot I remember it
particularly at a visit when she came to
open the National Horse Racing Museum
which is in Newmarket she went down the
line of dignitaries she went down and
met the public she gave them her
customary Focus but she was clearly
doing her Duty because the museum is
full of retired racehorses and it was
only when she got to the horses that she
really lit up
this was her majesty at her best we have
lost a great servant we she is replaced
by another great servant of our nation
God Save the King
oh thank you I think what's been so
remarkable in the words that have been
spoken since uh Her Majesty's the Queen
Elizabeth's death is just how many
people's lives she uh she touched it
wasn't just simply the length of her
ring nor her complete commitment to duty
but I think it was her character and the
way in which she did her work that meant
that she was loved by so many and would
be missed by us all
many of us here today have the privilege
of meeting her and talking to her and
like the right honorable member for
chingford and Woodford green I too had
the drinks at Christmas and wished I
knew a bit more about cocktails but went
for the safe gin and tonic at the time
um I want to remember her at the start
of her Reign and then recall two of the
times when I was with her I was eight
when Queen Elizabeth was crowned
um just to say to the uh right my right
order of a friend of member for Derby
South we were so rationed in those days
if she remembers so the reason that the
chocolate was so uh welcome was it was
rationed chocolate we didn't care about
the eggs and the Beet being Russian but
the chocolate being Russian was really
important we didn't have a television in
our home uh so we cuddled and crowded
around a small black and white
television in one of our neighbors
houses but I really remember seeing the
coach
seeing the glittering jewels on her
crown and seeing her stunning white
dress it was simply like a fairy tale a
Cinderella or a snow white coming true
and that magical moment of beauty hope
and goodness has stayed with me all
through her long reign
uh there were two occasions when I met
her that also remained strong in my
memory firstly in the early 80s when I
was leader in Islington the queen
visited saddle as Wells and we laid on a
session for her with a group of old age
pensioners women living in Finsbury and
we were running there a keep fit dancing
class under the tutorship of Sadler's
Wells teachers
Queen walked into the room and the
warmth of her smile as she entered the
room and the utter joy of the women at
being watched by her majesty and the
calm way that she put them at ease when
she talked to them was just simply
brilliant
and for the queen I think it was
probably just another day but for the
women it was probably one of the most
eventful days in their lives
the second was when the queen kid came
to visit barking and dagenham in July
2015 when she was nearly 90 to Mark the
50th anniversary of the creation of the
borough she spent almost the whole day
there opening a community center
launching a little launching a local
theater she visited schools and she
watched a swimming display
thousands of my constituents came out to
see her and many met her and she did
enjoy a Rapture susception and the fact
that she's chosen to spend so much of
her time with us on what must have been
a tiring day if he was getting on for 90
demonstrates I think her total
commitment to duty to us to her people
and among the Sea of Union Jacks that
met her I just remember the placards
which said welcome our Queen We love you
Madame Deputy speaker at a time of
constant change Queen Elizabeth II gave
us stability at a time of uncertainty
tension and conflict she always provided
a path to reconciliation and as a nation
and Community she provided leadership
that brought recognition respect and
status and love to all of Great Britain
and all of our people we will miss her
night United
thank you madam Deputy speaker uh it is
with great sadness that I Rise to speak
in the tributes to her late Majesty the
queen not only on my behalf but on
behalf of my constituents in Selby and
density
the news the whole nation had been
dreading brings the reign of the longest
serving Monarch in British history to an
end
as we've heard as a child she was not
expected to be Queen but her Destiny in
that of our nation changed when her
father acceded to the throne as King
George VI
she as we have heard
um as a 21 year old young woman pledged
to live a life of service
there can be no one anywhere Madame
Deputy speaker that can say she did not
deliver on that pledge
vividly recall the celebrations for the
Queen's Silver Jubilee in my Village and
Across the Nation it's also incredible
that she has also celebrated golden
diamond and platinum jubilees
her life spanned some of the most
amazing Milestones over the last century
from the discovery of penicillin the
moon landings and the invention of the
World Wide Web
she was also a monarch that
circumnavigated the world visiting
hundreds of countries including those
commonwealth countries which she held
with such affection
and Madam Deputy speaker the queen also
visited Selby in my constituency
alongside her beloved husband the Duke
of Edinburgh this is in 1969 when they
came to present Monday money to 43 men
and 33 women at Selby Abbey
10 000 people lined the town streets
that day to welcome and catch a glimpse
of their monarch
now like many honorable and right
honorable members I've had the privilege
of meeting the queen uh both times at
the palace and I cannot tell you madam
Deputy speaker how nervous I was uh as
we lined up to meet her
all my nerves were be calmed however
once I'd been greeted by the beautifully
warm smile and a welcoming words
that warmth that smile is what's
comforted our nation over the decades
through good and challenging times
the word constant has been widely used
and that's exactly what her late
Majesty was
it will be difficult to imagine life
without her and it feels like we've all
lost a grandmother
my rational friend the member for
Uxbridge in his touching speech referred
to her late Majesty as Elizabeth the
Great
is absolutely right to do so yeah yeah
she was a truly great monarch
and in some ways the greatest mark
a late Majesty was also a mother
grandmother and great grandmother
and my thoughts and prayers are with her
family
especially with King Charles III who
succeeds a to the throne
and as my right honorable friend has
also said it is a tribute to her
that we can say with great confidence
God Save the King
Madam Deputy speaker we owe her late
Majesty a great debt of gratitude
may God bless her
and keep her
may she rest in peace
and if I may paraphrase a small bear
from darkest Peru
mom
thank you for everything
thank you madam Deputy speaker the warm
tributes that have already been paid to
Queen Elizabeth II by honorable and
right honorable members today tell their
own story about the great respect and
deep affection that so many from such
diverse and different backgrounds had
for her it is an affection and a respect
that transcends mere political
difference and speaks to your position
as a leader and an example of Public
Service as others have already said
the queen was one of the most
consequential Civic figures of the last
century as political leaders came and
went as public opinion ebbed and flowed
she remained a constant an unyielding
and Limitless source of strength and
comfort for her people in times of
national pride and sorrow this scale of
her Reign lasting more than 70 years
found that Embers of conflict following
the second world war to the peace
process between our islands and our
peoples during that time she forwards a
legacy that will Outlast all of us here
but I hope that lays the foundation for
enduring relations between these islands
in spite of the challenges we now face
as leader of the sdlp I had cause to
meet with Queen Elizabeth on a number of
occasions believe me when I say this it
is difficult to think of two people more
divorced from each other in terms of
background and aspiration but in any
dealings I had with her I can only
recount a person of great one character
and an enduring passion for the
interests and needs of people that I
think is the reason for the longevity of
our support among the British people
but as a leader of Irish nationalism I
want a place on record my deep
appreciation and respect for the Queen's
role in forging new bonds of friendship
between our islands and between our
people
it is also easy to forget now
but she was also a victim of the
conflict that the people of these
islands were subjected to for 40 long
years I know that the murder of her
cousin Lord my button and Malik Moore in
August 1979 had a profound effect on her
an honorary extended family she
experienced the sharp pain of loss but
in common with the people of Ireland she
took risks for peace and played an
enormous role in reconciling the
Traditions that share our Islands at no
time was this more visible than during
her 2011 visit to Ireland I believe the
Queen Elizabeth's visit to The Gardens
of Remembrance in Dublin and the ways he
stretched herself to be an example of a
good neighbor to Ireland in those
moments contributed in a very
significant way to Healing the wounds of
our past those couple of [ __ ] up those
few words of Iris I hooked around August
acharger president and France was a
symbolic Embrace of the Irish people and
it was deeply deeply appreciated
the blessings of a long life doesn't
make the burden of saying goodbye any
later my sincerest condolences are with
the Queen's immediate family with right
honorable and honorable members here
today and most particularly with those
in Northern Ireland for whom she held a
cherished place in their lives and in
their hearts I know how difficult it is
to lose your hero but there is comfort
in the lasting Legacy that she will
leave having helped shape our common
history the story of our peoples is
fundamentally and inseparably
intertwined we all live in each other's
Shadow I hope that we continue to build
on the Legacy that Queen Elizabeth II
helped forwards may she rest and peace
audio just a reminder that the speaker's
guidance was uh three minutes in order
to be able to get in as many uh people
as possible David Jones
thank you madam Deputy speaker and as
other right honorable and honorable
members have mentioned it is impossible
for virtually all of us
and our constituents to remember a time
when her majesty the queen was not there
I was born a matter of weeks after she
acceded to the throne
and throughout my life and indeed all
our lives hers has been a continuous
reassuring presence providing wise
guidance for the country through good
times and bad
she was both an anchor and a lodestone
for our nation and it is indeed hard to
contemplate life without her
for seven decades she was there for us
and I think that many of us thought that
she always would be
she had a rare innate ability to
generate affectional respect and loyalty
not only from the people of this country
but from countless Millions throughout
the Commonwealth and Beyond
hers was arguably the most recognized
face on the planet
and it's not only here that she will be
missed but in other lands across the
world even in the few countries that she
never visited during her long reign
at the time of her Platinum Jubilee the
BBC broadcaster a remarkable documentary
called Elizabeth the Unseen Queen
which was part narrated by the queen
herself
and in the documentary she spoke the
following words of an Australian
Aboriginal proverb
we are all visitors to this time this
place
we are just passing through
our purpose here is to observe
to learn
to grow to love
and then we return home
and Madam Deputy speaker while we and
our constituents feel the most profound
grief at her passing
and our mourning will undoubtedly
continue long Beyond her funeral
we must find comfort in the knowledge
that our Queen
strong in the Christian faith that's
sustained her throughout her life
has returned home
and is at peace
God bless the lovely memory of her
majesty God Save the King
thank you madam W speaker I rise at a
time of great sadness for our country I
do so on behalf of my constituents in
Doncaster North and I know Madam speaker
I speak for you and your constituents in
Doncaster Central indeed right across
donkey stuff
I I would say also my number speaker the
house has been at its best today with
some wonderful speeches and memories of
her majesty Queen Elizabeth
I was a leader of the opposition as the
house will no and I know that it is
noted that the queen experienced 15
Prime Ministers I think perhaps it has
been lost count of how many leaders of
the opposition that she went through
which says something about leaders of
the opposition uh perhaps but but it is
in that spirit in my experience that I
want to talk briefly to the house
because I think one thing that has come
through so much since Her Majesty's
passing last night is the words public
service and I want to reflect on some
qualities some extraordinary qualities
that she showed in terms of Public
Service First of all her ability to
bring people together and unify our
country I was at the state banquet in
2014 for the president of Ireland
a state banquet attended by Martin by
the late Martin McGinnis
it showed extraordinary
selflessness courage
and an ability to heal that her majesty
invited Martin McGinnis given the
history of what happened to Lord
mountbatten but it was the person that
she was
her duty to our country her duty to
bring people together came first
secondly I think she taught us about
kindness
in leadership
the rightful member for chingford who is
not in his place talked about his
experience when he was deposed as leader
of the opposition I I was deposed by the
British people rather than at my party
but but
and and I I should um I I should say
that to the house that uh as my career
nose Dives nose dive my wife took off
and she became a high court judge in
2019 and became a Dame and so we were
both invited to
um The Palace to meet her majesty and
her majesty
fixed me with a gaze as we saw each
other and said oh it's you she said
what are you doing here knowing full
well knowing full well why was that and
we had a wonderful conversation and
there she was at 93 still full of Vim
Vigor and humor
and there is a lesson for us all in the
kindness she showed to me and other
members of this house and and thirdly I
want to say something about her sense of
humor because I go back to a time in
2008 when I had been recently appointed
at the minister the Secretary of State
for climate change and I went to my
first ever privy council meeting and her
majesty was reading out
um laws that had were being passed
and as she did so she paused for a
moment
and said
because she was having trouble reading
and she said
yes it's these new long life light bulbs
that we've introduced
[Laughter]
hahaha
and she fixed me with a beauty game
and a twinkle in her eye and I smiled
and that was a sense of humor that she
showed
she was an extraordinary Monarch but I
do also want to say a word about King
Charles III
and and here again I speak on behalf of
my
constituents
he has been
an extraordinary Warrior on the issue of
the environment long before
it was fashionable and when I was
climate change secretary I always
thought of him as an extraordinary
National Asset on this issue and he
remained so but he's not just a fighter
for big causes he is also someone and
here he has inherited this from his
mother of extraordinary kindness
generosity and compassion we see it in
his work to heal social divisions in our
country but I've also seen it in my
constituency which was hit by floods in
both 2007 and 2019.
and on both occasions including on the
first when part of my constituency was
still underwater King Charles III
came
to to see us to see my constituents to
talk to them to be with them including
on the second occasion just before
Christmas
because he knew that his presence at
this time of Anguish and grief and
anxiety for my constituents would make
an enormous difference to them
and indeed it did so
I say to the house
we have lost an extraordinary monarch
who has had an extraordinary and
distinguished Reign for seven decades
she is followed by someone who I know
will live up to all of the hopes of our
country will bring that same sense of
unity that sense of compassion and that
sense of Public Service long live the
king
Chris craving
Madame Deputy speaker I'm very grateful
to be able to participate in this solemn
occasion one that we all knew would
happen but one we all really in our hard
part wouldn't it is a day of mourning
for all of us individually for us
collectively as a house and for the
whole nation and not just the whole
nation I was struck last night to see a
picture of an American baseball diamond
with the teams lined up in a minute
silence in recognition of the loss of
the queen and of course she was a global
figure I remember when I hosted the
global law Summit in 2015 and the queen
very kindly hosted a reception of the
palace the U.S justice secretary a
powerful man in that country coming up
to me after he'd been introduced to the
school the queen guy I feel like a
nine-year-old it's just amazing I'm here
it's extraordinary and that's what the
world thinks about
thought of her and that's why they will
all be mourning with us now
and I have a particular reason for
morning two reasons actually my
constituency is one of the places she
came to every year
uh I I say committed racing Watcher to
attend the Derby and she will be much
Miss there in the future and I have an
email from constituent this morning
saying we will miss now that moment
every year when she drove up the road at
the end of our street and we could all
see her and waver she went past she'll
be missed by everybody in it but I'll
particularly miss her because I had the
privilege of serving for five years
first to say Lord Chancellor and then as
Lord president of her Council and in
those two roles one gets to spend not as
much time as the Prime Minister but a
considerable amount of time with her and
she was an extraordinary welcoming kind
smart person I remember the moment when
the current Lord the current
Archbishop of Canterbury was sworn in
and we've been through the formula that
you go through on these occasions and
then when we're finished she and the
Archbishop who used to work for Shell in
Nigeria embarked in the most
extraordinary conversation about the
politics of Nigeria and she knew it
inside out she was incredibly
knowledgeable about what was going on in
this country and elsewhere
she was incredibly welcoming
all those of us who've had the privilege
of spending time working with her in in
our various capacities we know she was a
kind person or a warm person always
welcoming always that a twinkle in the
eye that the right honorable member
referred to a moment ago
always a lighthearted conversation
sometimes about great issues sometimes
about simple matters like how you manage
all the dogs and Sandringham at
Christmas time
I remember
so many occasions going in with this
incredible Global figure and being made
to feel welcome been made to feel that
she was interested in what I and we were
doing and to feel incredibly proud that
she was our monarch
and I joined the writable member in
Wishing all the very best to King
Charles III he has had a long
apprenticeship he will I believe be a
great Monarch and I know everyone in
this house will wish him all the very
best the Lord is a very difficult time
for him we'll also want to extend their
condolences to all members of the royal
family who've lost their grandmother and
their great-grandmother it is a very sad
occasion for them
but I particularly today think back to
one conversation I had with her we were
before privy council meeting talking
about
the way technology is changing the world
and
so it's extraordinary the world's
changing so fast who knows where it will
be in 30 years time
and she said the only thing I know is I
won't be there
and sadly Madam Deputy speaker she isn't
that we all miss her Hilary
yeah thank you very much indeed Madam
Deputy speaker I rise on behalf of my
constituency Leed Central
as we together mourn the Queen's party
offer our heartfelt condolences to his
majesty the king and to the Royal Family
on their private grief born so publicly
and to mark an extraordinary life
it was at my first meeting of the privy
Council that I came to understand that
the queen was determined that things
should be done correctly
we were waiting outside the door and one
of the footmen opened it to see what was
going on and as he closed it he turned
to his colleague and said
she's moving the footstools again
to which he received the reply she's the
queen if she wants to move the footstool
she can move the footstools now hers was
a life that Above All Else embodied
constancy we have known no other
and we feel the Queen's passing so
keenly precisely because she was always
here
her Devotion to duty to service and to
representing our country
ran like an unbroken thread through the
decades and through each of Our Lives
like the passing of time and the
changing of the seasons she was always
here
and although as we have heard so many
things changed during her reign she did
not change
above the noisy clamor
of politics and public debate she
carried on and showed us what service
means carried out with Grace and with
humor
and now the day has come as we long
feared but knew it would that she is no
longer here and as the people of Leeds
and of Yorkshire and of the country come
to terms with their deep sense of loss
at this moment in the history of our
nation our United Kingdom
let us give thanks for her uniquely long
and well-lived life
and just as faith hope and love abide
so will our memories of the queen
her constancy has served and her
profound sense of Duty
thank you for everything that you did
Mom
and may you rest in peace eternal
understands
thank you madam Deputy speaker
I had the very great privilege of
serving as the vice Chamberlain of Her
Majesty's household between July 2018
and April 2019 a role and a title given
to the fourth most senior government
whip it's a role that the right
honorable member for Derby South spoke
about earlier in her fantastic
contribution it's a role that most
honorable and right honorable members
don't know even exists apart from when
they see one of the government whip
stood at the bar of the house wearing a
tail coat and carrying what appears to
be a snooker cue
it's it's also a role that only people
hear about when they realize that
somebody has to be held hostage at the
palace before her majesty would come to
Parliament for the state opening
however the role is much more than that
in that alongside your day-to-day
activities in the whips office you would
write a daily note to her majesty
keeping her updated with parliamentary
business giving her all the gossip and
then going to Parliament to discuss
those matters I'm just very glad that
unlike the right honorable member for
Derby South the chief whip nor the Prime
Minister ever read my notes
given my period in office coincided with
some of the most acrimonious brexit
debates a confidence vote in our prime
minister my right honorable friend the
member for maidenhead and the 2019 voter
confidence there are very few issues her
majesty and I have not discussed indeed
my final week in office as the vice
Chamberlain included nude protesters
gluing themselves to the glass in the
public gallery and the Chamber being
suspended after Water started pouring
through the ceiling into the Press
gallery perhaps it was quite symbolic as
to how broken our Parliament was at that
time
however despite this being an immensely
stressful and politically charged period
on every occasion I met her majesty I
found her calm warm and reassuring
like all who have spoken today I was
struck by her interest in current events
and her lifelong service to our nation
as our longest reigning monarch and the
world's longest serving head of state
she had an incredible insight into
current affairs and was a great symbol
of continuity in a rapidly changing
world
I remember vividly a discussion we had
about the online abuse that many members
across the house face on social media
Her Majesty recalled a conversation
she'd had with sir Tim berners-lee the
inventor of the world wide web and
talked knowledgeably about the subject
despite social media being something
most people in the 90s wouldn't know or
care anything about
we also discussed interviews that she'd
watched on the BBC News at 10 the night
before demonstrating that Her Majesty's
desire to stay on top of current affairs
stretched well beyond the papers she
received in her daily Red Box
all these meetings took place with a
Majesty standing throughout and were
often sandwiched between multiple other
official engagements that she was
undertaking
I less I last Met Her Majesty the queen
on the 19th of July at her last every
ever privy council meeting when I was
sworn into the privy Council and
presented with a Bible which I carry
with me today I believe that made me the
1336th person and final person to be
sworn into her late Majesty's Ruby
Council
it is an incredible honor as a minister
for the past five years to get to meet a
remarkable caring informed and witty
Monarch who's overseen huge change
during her Reign but never stopped
working day in day out for our country
and it is an incredible honor for me as
a lancastrian MP to see the love felt
towards her majesty Duke of Lancaster by
so many of my constituents in Pendle who
I will be joining with in Remembering
and celebrating her life over this
period of national Mourning may she rest
in peace and God Save the King
who Henry
thank you madam Deputy speaker I never
had the pleasure of meeting the late
Queen personally but I have met her son
the new King on several occasions and I
can testify personally to his deep love
for the highlands and I know that my
constituents are never asked near and be
knocking stress be will want to join me
in holding him in our thoughts as he
deals with us most personal losses that
of his mother but of course as we know
the late Queen was also a grandmother
and a great grandmother and she acceded
to the throne as a young woman at the
age of 25 and was a inspiration and icon
for many young women and as we've also
heard this morning became an inspiration
and an icon for many older women to she
was someone as we can see from the
tributes internationally who was
respected and admired far and wide the
vast majority of my constituents whether
they be monarchists or republican or
anything in between have never known a
time when she was not our head of state
our sympathy goes to our family and all
of those who are so deeply affected by
her passing
yeah
Savannah Jenkins yeah thank you madam
Deputy speaker on behalf of the
constituents of Harwich and North Essex
I Rise to pay tribute to her late
Majesty
whose whole life was the greatest
example of public service we shall ever
Witness
whose kind heart sharp intellect huge
wisdom was such a gift to the nation
who had love in her soul for everyone
under Serenity which even now calms the
nation in these troubled times
she inspired so many good causes
I single out one the Commonwealth
in 1952 a mere eight Nations
which she led
from being an emerging relic of a Lost
Empire
to become a network of Nations
representing two and a half billion
people in the network world we now live
in
just one of her achievements but what an
achievement what a legacy for future
Generations
including may I say the Commonwealth
Youth Orchestra whose Foundation she
supported about which she spoke to me
with such passion knowing that we both
had such interest in music
her diversion brought her to every
corner of the Kingdom where she would
show her humor and Humanity
when in 2004 she came to Harwich to
commemorate the 400th anniversary of the
Town Charter when Ivan Henderson was
still a member of Parliament
her program included seeing the historic
carvings in the town jail
but when the late Andy Morrison the
mayor announced you will now be taken to
the jail your majesty a Paul fell over
the Royal party so he attempted to
rephrase the invitation
but Prince Philip just retorted that
wasn't much better
and she threw back her head and roared
with laughter
later that day as she stepped into the
crowd on Harwich key she said to the
Marist Pam Morrison
my dear don't let me miss any children
a three-year-old boy was duly lifted
over the barrier who gave his flowers to
the Maris at first
but her majesty unfazed chatted to the
boy and Charmed him and he saw her take
the little bunch of flowers which he had
given her
into her own hands and she carried them
for the rest of the tour
so she combined Global Leadership such
principle and dedication with such
humanity and care
she has gone to the light who sample God
who inspires us all God Rest her soul
may he Comfort all those who were
closest to her God Save the King
thank you madam Deputy speaker it is an
honor to be able to pay tribute to her
late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II and to
offer my condolences and those of all of
my constituents to King Charles and the
whole of the royal family as they face
their personal loss honorable and right
honorable members of rightly praised Her
Majesty's admirable work ethic her sense
of Duty which has never wavered and her
unparalleled dedication to Public
Service Her Majesty served us right
until the very end forever committed to
her people and her country she lived and
symbolized the very best of our
constitutional system the value of a
royal family what it gives to our
country and the part that they play in
our national life one of the proudest
days of my life was when my dad was
awarded an Obe at Buckingham Palace my
whole family we just could not get over
that we would get the chance to hang out
in the Queen's house on that day it fell
to the Queen's daughter the Princess
Royal to hand out the honors but the
whole All Occasion was made magical
because it followed precisely the exact
example of the queen herself and I will
also never forget arriving in this place
for the very first time in 2010 standing
in front of the speaker's chair taking
hold of this House's copy of the Holy
Quran upon which I swore my loyalty to
her majesty the queen as one of this
House's first ever female Muslim members
of parliament her relationship with
Birmingham was strong and written and in
return we brummies had a deep affection
for her and gratitude for the time that
she devoted to us to us in the 70 years
of her Reign Over the years she visited
Villa Park the bull ring many of our
Railway stations the NEC the
International Convention Center Pebble
Mill and the Hippodrome and of course we
have just hosted the Commonwealth Games
an important moment for our city that
has such a deep connection with a
commonwealth and which is inextricably
linked with the queen herself like so
many thousands of brummies as much as I
am a child of Birmingham of England and
of Britain I am also a child and
grandchild of the Commonwealth millions
of British citizens have a similar
family history making them a part of the
Commonwealth family and we recognize her
majesty as the loving matriarch of the
Commonwealth its guardian and its
Guiding Light her commitment to the
Commonwealth and her championing of it
recognized and respected Our Heritage
she gave institutional and spiritual
meaning and the Heart and Soul of
belonging to those of us who are
citizens of our great nation equal
before the laws of our land but who do
not have centuries of Birthright claim
upon these our islands and we thank her
for it for me her Christian faith also
is something that always stood out she
was a committed Christian as we know
Supreme governor of the Church of
England it might surprise some that her
commitment to her Christian faith could
mean so much to those of us who practice
observe and belong to other Faith
communities but in a speech at Lambeth
Palace to Mark her Diamond Jubilee the
queen said and I quote the concept of
our established church is occasionally
misunderstood and I believe commonly
underappreciated its role is not to
defend anglicanism to the exclusion of
other religions instead the church has a
duty to protect the free practice of all
faiths in this country she was defender
of the faith but she was a queen for
those of us with other faiths and indeed
for those of none may God make it easy
for her may he give her loved one
strength and if I may offer this house
an Islamic verse which Muslims recite
when someone dies and which I hope will
resonate with the Queen's Christian
faith too
God we belong and to God we all return
s Deputy speaker I rise on behalf of uh
well to make my own tribute but also on
behalf of the constituents of Northeast
Hertfordshire in Royston Baldock
buntingford and Letchworth the queen was
very much loved and admired in our area
a remarkable woman and a wonderful head
of state she knew our area well from
visiting her mother's family who live in
a village near Hitchens and Paul's
Walden we were lucky that the queen was
able to be with us for some of our most
important events she opened the new
North Hertfordshire Leisure Center at
Letchworth Garden City and later in my
first year as MP in 1993 she came to
open a new housing development at Beech
Hill and a sheltered housing scheme at
table Court in Letchworth and ledgework
was also proud that she chose the Marmot
pram as the baby carriage for the new
king made in Letchworth on these
occasions what struck me was that the
queen was able to put people at their
ease and to get them to talk to her and
she was kindly and had that dry sense of
humor on the sense of humor I do
remember one privy council meeting when
the country was having difficulties so
similar but in a different period to
those that the right honorable member
for Derby South mentioned with the
European Union
but at this particular privy council
meeting she approved the high Hedges
order for Guernsey and then afterwards
she said with a twinkle in her eye well
I'm so pleased we've sorted out those
High hedges in Guernsey is there
anything else going on
um
and uh
people in Northeast Hertfordshire love
the queen and we will miss her our
thoughts are with the royal family and
long live the King
James Diana Johnson thank you madam
Deputy speaker I think there have been
some wonderful tributes to her late
Majesty the queen particularly I just
want to comment on the contribution from
the my honorable friend the member for
Birmingham ladywood who talked about the
Commonwealth and the importance of Faith
to the late queen and I think this is my
opportunity just to say a few words on
behalf of my constituents in whole North
I was very pleased indeed that the
leader of the opposition my right
honorable friend referred to the words
of the adopted son of Kingston upon
whole poet Philip Larkin he penned those
words 45 years ago for the Silver
Jubilee celebrations and as with all
great poets the words resonate as much
on this day as they did in 1977 I'm just
going to repeat them
in times when nothing stood but worsened
or grew strange there was one constant
good
she did not change
now my city of Kingston upon Hull has a
rebellious history with the monarchy
slamming the city Gates against the king
in the Civil War
but the city took Queen Elizabeth to our
hearts and I would say we were very
firmly in the royalist camp during the
second Elizabethan age Her Majesty
visited the city many times and met the
people of the city
during her Reign she was in Hull on some
of the most important days in the life
of the city and the region these include
the opening of the iconic Humber Bridge
in 1981 celebrating the city's 700th
birthday in 1999 and visiting Hull in
2017 when we were the UK city of culture
her first visit to the city was actually
to Hall Royal infirmary in 1957 and she
came again 50 years later to open the
Queen's Cancer Center at Castle Hill
Hospital in 2009 the city will miss her
and although the sovereign's passing is
a historic moment for the United Kingdom
and our Commonwealth and for many others
around the world at this time we must
remember above all else that a family
has lost a beloved mother a grandmother
and a great grandmother and like many
others this loss to the nation resonates
very personally with the loss of One's
Own parents or grandparents and in
particular I remember my auntie Betty as
staunch royalist who loved the queen and
was also born in the same year as the
queen
1926. so on behalf of the people of home
my thoughts and prayers are with the
royal family at this saddest of times I
also want to express condolences on
behalf of the Commonwealth wargraves
commission which I sit as a member and
although there is great sadness at this
time let us also remember a long life of
service
so well lived devoted to this nation a
life that should be celebrated the queen
was a member of that greatest Generation
who herself as we've heard served in
uniform in World War II helping to
secure our democracies the right
survival against tyranny
this was also a queen who embraced
change throughout her life and saw us
into the digital age and I just wanted
to end by saying it was a special honor
to be sworn in as a privy counselor over
Zoom during the covid pandemic so I
didn't have any of the worries about the
footstool and falling over and so the
queen was on a very large screen in
front of me
she looked entirely at ease and was
taking this new technology completely in
her stride perhaps rather more so than
the Lord president of the council at
that time the right honorable member for
North East Somerset
so to conclude
like the vast majority of britons alive
today I have known no other Monarch but
sadly we now have the point where change
has come
and we alongside the condolences uh to
the royal family we look to the new King
Charles III one era is ending a new one
is beginning Queen Elizabeth II would
want us to go forward as a great nation
in all our faiths and beliefs proving
that she was never mistaken in hers God
saved the king so Roger Gail
yeah yeah thank you madam Deputy speaker
in paying tribute to her late Majesty
may I on behalf of my constituents in
Northern
simply say that our condolences are with
his majesty King Charles the queen
consort
and all the members of the Royal Family
the then Prince Charles uh speaking at
the Jubilee
opened his remarks by saying your
majesty
mummy
and I think we all need to remember
that this family has lost a mother a
grandmother and a great grandmother
and we all feel their pain and our
thoughts really are and prayers really
are with them Madam Deputy speaker I was
nine years old when King George VI die
I can remember it fairly vividly
and rather like the right honorable lady
the member for Derby South
the next I think most memorable event in
my connection with the royal family was
the bar of chocolate
that we were all given coronation and I
seem to remember we got a coronation mug
as well
and for 70 years so far as I am
concerned this great lady
has been my lowest down my monarch
I was listening on the wireless
I think some people call it a radio
this morning
on my way up from Kent
to a caller who said
if we really want to honor a Majesty's
memory
then it will behove us well to emulate
the way that she lived and served in her
life and I think that's something
actually that in this house we might all
bear in mind
but those of us who had the privilege of
meeting her majesty face to face
without exception I think all remember
what has been referred to over and over
again this morning is the twinkle in
those beautiful eyes
and the smile that is now lighting up
heaven
may she rest in peace God Save the King
yeah Caroline Lucas
very much Madam Deputy speaker it is a
privilege to speak on behalf of the
green party of England and Wales and pay
tribute to Queen Elizabeth II
above all else she was a mother a
grandmother and a great grandmother and
I know I speak for the people of
Brighton Pavilion when I offer my
sincerest condolences in particular to
her immediate family and her loved ones
they've lost someone very dear to them
on a deeply personal level and our
thoughts are with them all
but we have lost her too
perhaps the most recognizable public
figure in the world today the queen has
been a uniquely enduring part of the
fabric of Our Lives for nine remarkable
decades
in moments of national crisis and in
moments of national pride she was always
there
through turbulence through uncertainty
she was always there as a fixed point
as a steadying guiding figure that we
all felt we knew
and of course for most of us she is
indeed the only monarch that we have
ever known
I too was torn to the lines of Philip
Larkin and I find it symbolic that so
many in the house have been drawn to the
words that he wrote and which are
engraved on a memorial in Queen's Square
in Bloomberg Bloomsbury erected to Mark
Her Majesty Silver Jubilee and I hope
the house will indulge me just when I
bear repetition to them again
in times when nothing stood but worsened
or grew strange there was one constant
good she did not change
listening to the radio watching the news
over the past 24 hours or so I've been
struck by just how much that
dependability and stability meant to
people
by how many people's lives she touched
in a very direct way by the memories
from those who met her of her deep
Humanity
and I know that there are millions of
people in Britain who are not
necessarily monarchists but who are
nonetheless deeply mourning the queen
who feel a profound sense of loss and
who also had huge respect and admiration
for her
they we saw in her an extraordinary work
ethic a deep stoicism and an
extraordinary wisdom gained over so many
years we saw the values of selflessness
and sense of Duty and also of course the
personal side of her character that
humility
kindness and the famous sense of humor
that has been spoken about so much today
from the marmalade sandwiches allegedly
secreted away in her iconic black
handbag to joining James Bond on the
zipware she was a queen unafraid to be
playful and so many speak of the twinkle
in her eye and of her genuine interest
in the world across which she traveled
so extensively
that determination to be seen to connect
with people saw her become the most
troubled Monarch in history making over
285 State visits
she broke many other records too not
only our longest serving Monarch but as
the one woman from the British royal
family to ever have served in the armed
forces and the only modern head of
states to have served during World War
II
all of which speaks to her driving
purpose that deep sense of Duty
today young and old people of all faiths
and none royalists and Republicans
across our four nations the Commonwealth
and the world
are united in that recognition that she
worked so tirelessly and did so until
the very last days of her remarkable
life from all walks of life and all
corners of the globe people want to pay
their respects
and her majesty did Inspire genuine
respect as well as admiration love and
affection
she is part of the world's Collective
understanding of britishness the epitome
of faith and steadfastness
so I want to thank her for her devotion
of her dignity
her enduring Legacy will be as
multifaceted as she was herself in life
but I believe that she would want the
most abiding aspect of that Legacy to be
hope and solidarity as symbolized by the
double rainbow that stretched across the
skies of our Buckingham Palace yesterday
shortly after the announcement of her
death
rest in peace your majesty and thank you
Mel stride
Madam Deputy speaker and I Rise to pay
tribute to a very remarkable and
wonderful lady not just on my behalf but
on behalf of the constituents of central
Devon Queen Elizabeth II a longest
reigning monarch uh passionate head of
the Commonwealth for which she did so
much loved admired and of course
recognized throughout the world a life
that spans so much when she came to the
throne of course World War II was a very
fresh memory that was still rationing
man had yet to walk upon the Moon
she ran through sewers the Cuban Missile
Crisis she saw the Beatles
a solitary football World Cup victory
she saw Concord fly
she witnessed industrial unrest on an
industrial scale within her own family
she suffered of course great personal
tragedy
she was there alongside us for the dawn
of a new millennium
she joined James Bond for the opening as
we have heard of the London Olympics
in Paddington for the Jubilee and she
said of the lionesses
and their recent Triumph you have all
set an example that will be an
inspiration for girls and women today
and for future Generations
that could equally be said for her
Elizabeth as we have heard
was has always been here she's always
been a part of our lives a part of our
world and perhaps in essence that is why
she will be so sorely missed
she was certainly with us in Devon and
the West country Madam Deputy speaker
she would have known my constituency
well along with no doubt the
constituencies of all of us in this
house
she was a frequent visitor to the South
West as recently as the G7 Summit where
she first for the first time met
President Biden one of 13 presidents of
the United States with whom she was to
make an acquaintance all of them since
Harriet's Truman with the acceptance the
exception of Lyndon Johnson
when she was 13 she accompanied her
family including her father King George
VI to the Britannia Royal Naval College
in Dartmouth and she was to remember
this as the first time that she met a
then young Cadet her future husband
Prince Philip of Greece and Denmark
now that is something Madam Deputy
speaker of which Devon can be
particularly proud
at his Queen she returned to Dartmouth
with Prince Philip of course before the
coronation
many of us have shared today our
personal reflections of the contact that
we have had with her majesty mine came
through being the control of the royal
household in our whips office and also
briefly as Lord president of the council
my impression of her in the small number
of private meetings that I had with her
was that she was sharp
that she was kindly that she was
humorous she had that twinkle in her eye
and indeed before I went in to see her
for the first time the equity turned to
me to put me at ease I think told me a
little anecdote about an ambassador that
had gone in to see her for the first
time and on approaching her his phone to
his horror had sprung into life and
started ringing and he looked panicked
and after he turned it off she turned to
him and said well perhaps you should
have answered it it might have been
somebody important
I thought perhaps the
verse on occasion I didn't know her well
enough to be sure of that but I was
certain of the fact that she could be
great fun that was something that Shone
through when you met her and wise of
course based on her huge experience of
life from the world and just as
everybody told me
she was somebody who put you at your
ease somebody it was good to be with she
made you feel special yeah
it was the honor of my life Madam Deputy
speaker to have spent just that little
time with her Queen Elizabeth thank you
you gave us all so much
rest in peace God Save the King
thank you madam Deputy speaker ring out
the old ring in the root new wrote
Tennyson on the death of his much-loved
friend and we Proclaim The Queen Is Dead
long live the king
but it feels too sudden too soon too
sharp a turn in our lives because the
death of the queen is painful
it hurts we don't have to ask oh death
where is thy sting because we know
the nation feels that sting of death
it is as if a member of our own family
has departed and weirdly we feel as if
we ought to tell the members of our
family who've already long Departed the
news even Google with its brightly
colored logo is gray today which is sort
of ironic for her majesty who wore every
color Under the Sun at some point in her
life
the poet priest and Member of Parliament
John Dunn said when preaching to
Whitehall in 1627 that the best
protection and against a fearful death
was a life devoted to a calling
well that's exactly what it was wasn't
it a life devoted to a calling
how often must you have thought not
another opening not another Royal
Variety performance not another unfunny
comedian not another prime minister
um yeah she did her Duty in in the words
perhaps of the Boy Scouts and the guides
um promise to do my best to do my duty
to God and to the queen
she did her Duty
to herself
and I pledged my allegiance to her ten
times as a clergyman and as a member of
Parliament and of course we all have and
to her heirs and successes and in one
sense that's not personal at all our
Allegiance was to her as head of state
the embodiment of our shared life as
United Kingdom
but I suspect we all also felt we owed
allegiance to her personally
because she had earned her moral
Authority
she donned a uniform to do her bit to
fight fascism
she could not lead us into battle or
give us laws or administer justice but
she gave us her heart and her Devotion
to these old islands and to all the
peoples of our Brotherhood of Nations as
she herself Faithfully promised in 1957.
there have been there are other queens
I've met a few
and but then again too few to mention
but we and I note also the president of
France only call one the queen
um her face was on the coins my
constituents started producing at the
Royal Mint and slantrisant in 1953 but
to mix my poets she knew our little
systems have their day we are dressed in
a little brief Authority
I know some people deify the monarchy
but I think that's to miss the point the
point is the humanity of the monarchy
Richard II under whose great hammer beam
ceiling Her Majesty will lie and state
in a few days time
is given a great speech by Shakespeare
which ends you have mistook me all this
while
I live with bread like you
feel want taste grief need friends
not just bread of course marmalade
sandwiches as well
most movingly of all I think she was as
human as any other Widow in losing her
husband her consort her life companion
none will forget her sitting alone at
Phillips Funeral
it is a sign of their enduring love
that her and Philip's deaths came closer
in time than any other reigning monarch
and their consort in our history
and I thank God
that it was in her reign that men were
able to declare their love to one
another and women were able to do the
same
I end with words
that have never felt more appropriate I
think than for our longest reigning
monarch who lived through Holocaust and
War and led us through years of
unimaginable turbulence
the weight of this sad time we must obey
speak what we feel not what we ought to
say
the oldest hath born most we that are
young shall never see so much nor live
so long
God saved the king
do you want to remind honorable and
right honorable members that they um
speaker did ask that remarks be confined
to three minutes David Mandel
ier Adam Deputy speaker Her Majesty
Queen Elizabeth II had a lifelong and
deep felt love for Scotland which we've
already heard about and that was
reciprocated by the people of Scotland
who held her and indeed still hold her
in deep affection and I had the
opportunity myself to see that close up
both as a member of the Scottish
Parliament uh when it reconvened in 1999
and subsequently a Secretary of State
for Scotland and I do recall that the
opening of the Scottish Parliament uh
the queen declaring I have trust in the
good judgment of the Scottish people I
have faith in your commitment to this
service and I am confident in the future
of Scotland and it was a belief in a
commitment in Scotland that she
reaffirmed on each subsequent opening of
the Scottish Parliament although she
told me that she always found it very
amusing that as soon as the Scottish
Parliament was a formally opened it went
on Research says or as holiday as she
referred a to it as we've had she was
also somebody who was extremely well
informed about everything that was going
on in politics and in my first
substantive conversation with a
secretary of state that had been a major
incident in Parliament when rather more
members of the Scottish national party
had been elected in 2015 and might have
been anticipated and there was a little
bit of conflict about who should sit on
the bench opposite and the then member
for bolsover and some other labor
members were not so keen on SNP members
occupying those positions so the queen
was very familiar with this situation
and sought to interrogate me on the
rights and and Wrongs of the issue and I
found myself blutting out on your
majesty that's buttock gate and I
thought
hey my first meeting with the queen I
have said the word buttock
what is to happen
but rather than me be taking off a uh to
the Tower or to a uh some other a police
the queen just laughed she found it all
very amusing but also you know she was
interested in what was happening in
Parliament and and the day-to-day event
she'd had many uh connections with my
own a constituency from opening the
Dumfries at Royal infirmary to visiting
the town of Lockerbie after the
devastating effects of the air disaster
but I think most tellingly I found a
clipping from a 19
1956 edition of the Glasgow Herald
newspaper and it stated previously Royal
visits to Scotland having neglected to
include bigger in South lanarkshire the
queen decided to make amends in October
1956 as a paper observed a thoughtful
gesture by her majesty added 90 minutes
in time and 35 miles in distance to her
program but she felt that bigger was the
only County Town admitted from recent
Royal tours and that was the queen she
wanted to include every Community across
the United Kingdom and of course the
people of bigger turned out in their
masses to thank her for that a very a
generous gesture
Scotland as a and the whole of the
United Kingdom has lost not just the
queen but we've lost a deer and true
friend who's like we shall not see again
God bless her and God Save the King
Mary thank you very much Madam Deputy
speaking it's a great pleasure to follow
very honorable gentleman's buttocks
um I'm very
first time he's had that as well I think
I'm very grateful
for the opportunity Madam Deputy speaker
to pass on my condolences to the royal
family but also to pay a tribute to her
late Majesty the queen on behalf of my
own family constituents in Edinburgh
South and from people all over her
beloved Scotland Her Majesty Queen
Elizabeth was a mother a grandmother and
a great grandmother to her own family
but she was also the mother grandmother
and great grandmother to the nation
we'll all remember where we were when we
learned of her death yesterday we will
always remember that was in Scotland
where she spent her last weeks and days
and as we've heard already she loved
being in Scotland and particularly the
Balmoral estate the Tranquility The
Great Outdoors and the complete absence
of any speed limits the queen loved
Scotland and Scotland loved the Queen
the ties between Scotland and our
longest reigning monarch are plentiful
from our very first public speech as a
young princess in Aberdeen at the
opening of the British sailor society
and the yarn of our wedding dress being
woven in Scotland to her royal yacht
betrayal being built on the Clyde and
retired to the fourth the opening of the
first fourth bridge and the second one
53 years later and she always looked
forward to the Royal week in Edinburgh
each year Scotland was as she described
it her special place she said at the
opening of the Scottish parliament in
1999 that and I quote if I may make a
personal Point Scotland occupies such a
special place in my own and my family's
affections I remember my own childhood
the Traditions which revolved around her
late Majesty every Christmas she was
part of her family as much as the
rituals of the the tree in the turkey
was every generation of our family
clouded around the television for our
three o'clock Christmas address she
transcended Every Generation all the way
to my two-year-old daughter who now
knows who that was drinking tea with
Paddington I've yet to explain to Zola
that paddington's friend has passed away
over the last 24 hours I've tried and
struggled to find the language to
describe her but the one word that a
constituent said to me late last night
was iconic and she's a very definition
of iconic she doesn't every pound I ever
spent admittedly less than fewer than
many others because I'm a Scotland every
letter that I've ever sent her name is
on dozens of plaques and buildings all
over my constituency in tens of
thousands all over the country she
embodied what it means to be British she
epitomized public duty decency and
dignity she picked us up when we were
down and when our grandchildren and
their grandchildren look back at this
time it would be Elizabeth II above all
else they will remember as a thread
through every part of our post-war
history she was truly our greatest
Monarch I'd love to tell a humorous
anecdote and hope someone else will tell
it about the visit to Balmoral that she
had with dick Griffin one of her former
protection officers that Madam Deputy
speaker there's no time to do that that
someone else may tell that shortly I
never met her majesty but we all think
we'd dead because she was such an
integral part and influence on her
lights and everyone thinks they did meet
her because anyone that dead never
stopped telling you that's the impact
that she had on each of their lives
finally Madam Deputy speaker I can only
imagine the pain and grief the royal
family are having today and that pain
and grief compounded by the duty that
King Charles of Charles III now has to
lead this nation I the people of
Edinburgh South and the people of
Scotland simply say thank you for
everything man rest in peace and God
Save the King
whose videos
I'm not a deputy speaker I feel I can't
match the eloquence of of the many
wonderful speeches we've heard today but
I do want to share for a few moments my
personal sadness at this terrible loss
and I'm sure that sense of sadness is
shared also by my constituents in
chipping Barnard
her late Majesty was a woman of
remarkable charm warmth and kindness
typified by that lovely smile that
adorned so many hundreds of millions of
images published of her during her
70-year reign
she could come out with rather
unnervingly direct comments sometimes on
the news on matters on the news often
with a twinkle in her eye deploying that
mischievous sense of humor about which
so many this morning have spoken
I have to say when I met her I was so
Starstruck in her presence that I
scarcely felt able to string a sentence
together if she noticed she was far too
kind and polite to mention this
her enthusiasm for Northern Ireland is
something which featured in many of our
conversations during my time as
Secretary of State at an audience she
kindly granted me at Hillsborough Castle
she remarked gleefully that she always
felt a sense of such excitement flying
into Belfast and catching sight of the
Harland and wolf cranes
she said you know there is only one
place in the world you can be when you
see those landmark cranes as Northern
Ireland secretary I and my team had
provided some suggestions on the
itinerary for the 2014 Royal visit and I
felt they might be a little more daring
than what had been that the previous
plans for the visit so it was with some
nervousness that I arrived at the first
stage of the program at St George's
Market which saw her majesty mingle
amongst the crowds in a way which would
have been inconceivable in Belfast just
a few years previously later a walk by
her majesty around the set of Game of
Thrones in the paint Hall Studios was a
social media phenomenon but politely and
probably wisely she declined the
invitation to sit on the iron throne
but history I'm confident will record
her role in promoting peace and
Reconciliation on the island of Ireland
as one of the greatest achievements of
Queen Elizabeth II
as we've heard and as we all know she
herself suffered personal tragedy at the
hands of the provisional IRA
and yet she was willing to shake hands
with the late Martin McGuinness and even
welcome him to her home in Windsor and
her visit to the Republic of Ireland in
2011 was a truly Landmark moment written
in Ireland share hundreds of years of
contested and often violent history
and for centuries to come I'm sure
people will recall that 2011 State visit
as a turning point which played a
significant role in moving us on from a
conflicted past towards a better future
in conclusion Her Majesty was the last
Head of State anywhere in the world to
have donned a uniform in World War II as
our new prime minister said Queen
Elizabeth was the rock upon which we
built the Modern Nation we are today
she has been an unchanging constant in
all our lives there for us in good times
and bad
as we move on from the Elizabeth to a
new carolingian age this loss truly
marks the end of an era
without her presence life in this
country will never be the same again God
saved the king well done yeah yeah
my thoughts prayers and condolences and
those of communities across Newcastle
North are with his majesty the king the
royal family and the country as we mourn
remember and celebrate the incredible
life of her majesty as I learned the
news of her passing yesterday as I'm
sure is the case for many I shed a tear
I was asked by one of my children what
the queen meant to me and it was only
when I thought about how I would answer
that question to them that I realized
the profound impact that her ever
presence had had a strong steadfast
matriarch unwaving in her calm measured
dignified approach no matter the
challenges thrown at her or at our
nation and there have been many
so often she captured the mood of her
country shared our Joys provided comfort
her intervention during the pandemic a
time of such anxiety and unease was
Pitch Perfect and soothed the nation the
tributes have been Global as was her
reach yet at the same time so deeply
personal a unique unrivaled and personal
connection to millions of people across
the globe as I'm sure with many members
across this house on every school visit
I make I'm asked whether I know the
queen
Newcastle can seem a very long way from
Buckingham Palace Her Majesty is felt
very closely
we've been privileged in Newcastle to
have had many visits from her majesty
over the years images of her visits show
sheer joy that she brought every time
she came whether it was opening
newcastle's Eldon Square visiting the
Millennium Bridge or her visit to the
city library indeed I was only just in
Eldon Square buying new school shoes for
my children and we stopped and remarked
upon the plaque that is very prominent
there of her visit when she opened it in
1977. her Legacy will live on for many
years to come
Her Majesty had a particular connection
with our Metro service first opening the
tainaway metro in 1981 which included
naming the Queen Elizabeth II Metro
bridge over the time and traveling on
the 4020 Metro Car for the golden
jubilee and for this year's Platinum
Jubilee the original Metro Car from 1981
received a makeover and in the golden
jubilee she got to travel in a golden
Metro car but it's her love and
knowledge of horses that is of course
legendary so we were really honored to
have her majesty visit Newcastle Gosford
Park Racecourse in my constituency for
the famous Northumberland plate race day
the photos from that day show her
beaming from ear to ear only in the way
that racing can bring about there is
such a rich life of Duty of service of
deep Faith to reflect on there is so
much to learn from her life and her
example and there is so much to do to
ensure her Legacy ensures May Perpetual
light shine upon her may she rest in
peace
to edwardly
I'm sure I speak with our father
colleagues when I say that when a
debate's been going on for three hours
one feels more and more inadequate about
what one's going to say and how I can do
True Justice to This Magnificent
tapestry the speaker when he opened the
debate so there's only a score of
members who were alive in the previous
Reign I must confess I was one of them
but my memories of the previous Reign
are very dim indeed I was so young when
the present Queen came to the throne and
she has been as so many people have said
an extraordinary guiding star to us I
think some of the best parts of the
debates
have of course been wonderful literary
Illusions
but also personal memories
and I I remember when I when I was
talking to her once through my time on
the Public Accounts committee I was very
nervous because we were trying to
abolish the Royal Train
a train which was so expensive and so
slow that it could only travel during
the night but when I raised it with her
she immediately defused the whole issue
she was charm itself and despite our
efforts I think the Royal Train carried
on running for many years after that
and still does
and I remember at a private council
meeting I was quite nervous although
quite proud to to mention to her that my
father many or decades before I'd been
Clark the privy Council I was pretty
nervous because when I mentioned that as
a younger man very proudly the Duke of
Edinburgh he said that the whole private
Council was a bloody waste of time
indeed it's quite formal egg I think
when Nick Clegg was leader of the
council uh he he actually turned over
two pages of orders and nobody noticed
apart from the queen who immediately
stopped the proceedings but when I
mentioned my father how kind she was the
president Clark of course had no memory
of one of his predecessors four decades
before but she immediately remembered my
father and thanked me for his service so
what a wonderful kind and superbly
astute person she is before I sit down
may I just mention one thing and I was
very struck by the wonderful speech from
The Honorable member for ladywood who
taught on behalf of Muslims now I'm not
an Anglican and indeed under the first
Elizabeth us Catholics had a bit of a
torrid time
indeed one of my ancestors was hung
drawn and courted merely for being a
Catholic priest and we didn't do so bad
well under the second chance either but
I think she is played if I may put it
this way an absolute Blinder in the way
that she has carried out her role as
Supreme governor of the Church of
England
we all know that so many top politicians
just don't do God they're embarrassed to
talk about religion they feel they're
putting themselves on the pedestal
they'll be dragged down but I think what
she realized and what she epitomizes is
when so many people talk about service
it comes from her deep faith that unlike
all the rest of us who have
spent so many years trying to get into
this place and serve the public she
never asked for this job but she has
been sustained for all her life by her
deep and Abiding Faith and when people
are sad or Mourning or in difficulties
when she gives that Christmas broadcast
she appeals and Comforts to people of
all faiths and none I think we should
really thank her for that because it's
so difficult and in one of those
Christmas broadcasts 50 years ago she
said
wise men since the beginning of time
have studied the skies whatever our
faith
we can all follow a star
indeed one must follow one if the
immensity of the future opening before
us is not to Dazzle our eyes
dear colleagues she has been our guiding
star
for all that time remember her first
broadcast was yes 80 years ago to
Children displaced by War she has been
our guiding star
Eternal rest Grant unto love unto her
May Perpetual light shine upon us
stand here and give a tribute to the
leak Queen on behalf of my constituents
in Israel for sure I know that Israel
future Council has opened a book of
condolence this morning and I know that
very many local residents will want to
use that opportunity to pay their
respects and share their memories of
meeting the late Queen and what she has
meant to them
and I know that for so many people in my
community and people far beyond she was
simply a constant
she was after all Queen for longer than
most of us here have been alive and
she's the only monarch that we have ever
known
her Reign has stretched across society
that has changed so much in the many
intervening years but the thing which
has not changed and never changed was
her Focus which remained unchanging on
her Duty throughout all of that time
and that sense of service and Duty and
her resolve to persist was a Hallmark
throughout her reign
and I don't think anyone will fail to be
moved by the knowledge that she
continued even this week dealing with
the installation of a new prime minister
in fact during her Reign the late Queen
saw 15 prime ministers
five first ministers 13 U.S presidents
and I think that that puts this into
perspective in every way this is the end
of an era
and our sense of public duty which spans
all of that era was very close to
everyone who came into contact with the
late Queen
I'll always remember the great regard to
that my grand had for her she always
followed the Queen's movements with
great interest they shared a birthday
and this was seen to her to be really
significant and she was very pleased to
get herself into the situation where she
attended a number of Royal visits now I
grew up in Anger switching means that my
home was not very far from glams and I
think that her interest actually stemmed
very much from knowing that there was
that local connection and the queen was
known to have spent many happy times in
the local area
and of course the late Queen was
involved in so many different local
areas so many places so many
organizations so many Charities and that
means that she will be missed in all of
these spheres too and I think that
people will feel that loss very
personally because they have had that
personal connection to her and feel that
this loss is also their loss
and I know that many will take comfort
from the words that they've heard today
I think that for all of her public
presence and for all of her influence
it's obvious that most of all she will
be missed by her family
and I hope that in time they are able
also to take some comfort perhaps by
looking back on a life of Duty that was
well lived and reflecting on the
memories that people across the world
will have shared
I'm sure we all know from our own lives
that very deep sense of grief and loss
that the king and the royal family will
be experiencing just now it's very
difficult to lose a loved family member
and my thoughts and the thoughts of
people in East Rand for sure are with
them today
thank you thank you speaker I returned
to Westminster after the dreaded news
from our home at Upton Crescent in
Shropshire having told us having told
this morning our Hanover Bell struck in
1701 in respect of the act of succession
I struck it 96 times in respectful
memory of her majesty farewell our
longest and most loved and devoted
Sovereign in the history of our country
and the crown in Parliament
she loved her people and they loved her
as did my constituents in stone for whom
I speak
they showed this in those heady days of
her 70th Jubilee
which they joyfully celebrated with her
never to forget the profound loss of her
dearly loved husband Prince Philip only
a few months before
as she requested God helped her keep her
vow of service which she made on her
accession to the throne in February 1952
but all as I was on the 10th of May 1940
the very day that Churchill became prime
minister
I so vividly recall the age of 11 at
that moment as the Headmaster they came
to us
the king is dead
God Save the Queen
I watched her coronation with Wonder on
a small television screen in black and
white on the 2nd of June 1953
just as Hillary climbed Everest and we
won the ashes and
it was a triple whammy because of the
coronation itself
she was graceful in her majesty and in
equal parts she was selfless she had
Christian faith and integrity she was
constant she was wise she had an
extraordinary spontaneous Beauty
she had the kindest and most expressive
eyes and her gentle and humorous smile
I was honored and privileged to meet her
and speak with her several times
what she said to this lowly backbencher
was more poignant than I deserved we
read you in hand side she said once
your majesty your majesty your majesty I
replied I'm very surprised very few do
T I said particularly on the issue of
Europe
[Laughter]
I thought that was really
I was proud to be United by the queen
herself at Windsor one of the greatest
honors of my life she was the mother of
our nation and of the Commonwealth she
was a supreme Diplomat for our country
and as many have said also in Ireland
she lived in the hearts of her subjects
who will always remember her and for
them she will never die
all our prayers are with the home of our
family mother
grandmother great-grandmother may she
rest in peace and God Save the King
Madame Deputy speaker at this very sad
time we remember the life of Queen
Elizabeth II with gratitude for her love
and service to our nation Her Majesty
lived her life Guided by a deep sense of
Duty a duty to her people her country
her family an overwhelming sense of
Public Service
she carried out her duties without stint
without complaint and through the
toughest of times and the darkest of
hours
as a politician I have also appreciated
her stability and constancy that she has
brought through recent difficult and
tumultuous years how she has been so
attentive to adapting through periods of
social change through her time and her
respect for our democracy
that's why we mourn Our Queen because
her sense of Duty her humor and her
warmth has touched the hearts of the
nation and indeed so many across the
world in her beloved Commonwealth and
Beyond
she has lived a truly remarkable life
she was purposeful in all that she did
young and old loved her and I know I'm
already not the only MP to know that
probably the first and most important
question we will always be asked in a
visit to a primary school is have you
met the queen
Madame Deputy speaker today I laid
flowers at Buckingham Palace on behalf
of my constituents with our thoughts and
prayers for King Charles III and all his
family
my constituents are sharing in the
National grief and I've been receiving
moving and thoughtful messages from them
one said news of the passing of her
majesty deeply saddened me her Reign
spanning over 70 years was a celebration
of leadership of courage and dedication
she led the nation with exemplary
steadfastness even while battling with
her own personal grief
another said rest in peace to an amazing
icon she was the face of Britain and was
loved by all
locally we recall the special memory of
a visit by her majesty to open the new
wing of the Gurdwara City Singh Saba on
Alice way in Hounslow in October 2004.
this kidwara has a wonderful Library
classes and Community well-being and
support services all of which she saw
her visit was just one example of her
deep and genuine interest in communities
across our nation and in all faiths that
saw people from all backgrounds feel at
ease respected and connected to her her
visit left a mark and a deep sense of
the local community and its story being
recognized and valued Her Majesty's
passing also caused me to reflect how
just in June we came together to
celebrate her Platinum Jubilee I
attended over 10 Street parties and
events over those few days she even at
96 had the power to bring people
together she was the inspiration for
parties in feldom in Heston in bedfont
in handworth and more widely organized
by residents local businesses and our
Royal British Legions people shared
their lives after two years of covid and
the events reunited friends and
neighbors still building their
confidence to connect after so much
isolation Madame Deputy speaker the loss
of a mother is truly the most painful of
moments and as King Charles III takes on
the role of Monarch we know he will be
leading in supporting the grief of his
whole family just over a year after the
sad passing of Prince Philip they do not
grieve alone and we stand with them at
this time her majesty was admired loved
and respected and revered she was the
best of us and brought out the best best
in us today we thank her we mourn her we
celebrate her God Save the King so John
Hayes
most people who possess power first seek
it indeed we know in this place many
people crave it
I'd like to see the queen neither salt
power
indeed you might say it was thrust upon
her truly
but when she wielded Authority she did
more fundamental good
he brought more benefit than almost
anyone here and of course for much much
longer
messing with influence expect plaudence
but for her majesty
the queen acclimation
when it became obvious
when it was clear to her just how much
she was loved it was greeted on her part
with humility
and with Grace
most those who lead expect to bring
change
but for her majesty
constancy
was the most fundamental thing she could
bring the nation a permanent part of Who
We Are
as a people each of us and all of us
it's not that she was behind the times
she was beyond the times
and I remember meeting her a number of
times particularly 20 years ago when she
said to me in Buckingham Palace do you
use computers in your office I said well
well yes we do your mattress there she
said yes you said but I have such
trouble printing things out
she said sometimes Pages get missed
altogether I've been caught out making
speeches like that twice
she went on to say that when her husband
Prince Philip printed things out or when
he couldn't in her words the air turns
blue
sense of humor was a was a part of a
charm which was so obvious so palpable
that she was able to charm even those
who weren't intuitively instinctively in
favor of the monarchy
I met her but I didn't know her few
people knew her well but we knew she was
there she was in our Consciousness not
many people think of the Sun and the
Moon I suppose astronomers and
astrologers do and thinking they're a
sort of fusion of Herschel and Russell
Grant
but we know they're there we expect the
sun to come up in the morning we expect
to bathe in the light of the Moon and
say it was with her majesty
well now
our days are a little dimmer now nights
were a little colder for her party
for her majesty the queen
was in all of our lives for so so long
she wore the crown but of course she
wasn't the crown
Crown has a permanent life it goes on
she graced
is secure in the hands of her Heir her
son our kid
This Woman This Woman Who
lost it so long in her life who
personally fighting the faith
who was grateful gracious
and by the way who brought up Beauty to
her job
for the was as my right Uncle friend for
stone said a beauty about her grace a
quiet and enduring and palpable Beauty
now that uh the crown passes to her Dear
Son our wonderful king must hope that he
in his grief
will know that he shares that grief with
everyone in this house
and with all her people
for whom she will remain not merely as a
member it was a presence in the crown
itself
may God
as he welcomes Her Majesty to heaven
keep and bless a successor our King
Charles
God Save the King
thank you thank you madam Deputy speaker
it is a solemn honor to pay tribute to
her late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II and
I want to begin by offering my
condolences on behalf of my Barnsley
constituents and myself to his majesty
the king and all of the royal family in
their time of grief
it's hard to believe that her late
Majesty the queen is no longer with us
for nearly all of us in this place and
Beyond her presence is all we've ever
known
there is a sense of loss in the country
so profound that it will take time to
mourn and to come to terms with she was
not only our Queen she was someone
embedded in our hearts
special place was earned by her Devotion
to each and every one of us she embodied
dignity dedication Duty and a service
that was unwavering throughout
her long life and remarkable Reign saw
our country through the best of times
but our late Queen was also a source of
strength in the worst of times not least
in recent years during the pandemic
her address to the nation in April 2020
was the tonic to a fear and hopelessness
that seemed almost insurmountable
she said we will meet again
and we did
we will miss her deeply
Madam Deputy speaker all of those who've
had the privilege to serve in our Armed
Forces know there will be a distinct
sadness amongst the Armed Forces
Community yeah this is because as our
head the late Queen cared about us
deeply indeed of course during the
second world war as a princess she chose
to serve in the auxiliary territorial
service
that closeness to and affection for the
Armed Forces was reciprocated by all who
have served
it wasn't just because we knew she was
formidable
we also knew that she had a great sense
of humor
many of us the honorable member for
Edinburgh South nodded to it have
enjoyed the story that was told during
the Platinum Jubilee Celebrations by a
former Royal Protection Officer Richard
Griffin
whilst accompanying her late Magister
Majesty on a walk near Balmoral a group
approached asking have you ever met the
queen
her response was no before pointing to
the Protection Officer and saying but he
has
people did not have to be close close to
the lake Queen to appreciate her sense
of humor and the world remembers and
will always remember the opening
ceremony of the 2012 Olympics when she
famously was seen to parachute out of a
helicopter with Commander James Bond and
who could forget of course her double
act with Paddington
I'm certain Madam Deputy speaker that
history will judge her late Majesty as
an extraordinary Monarch adored by her
people but it will also note that while
the world changed at a rapid rate the
queen struck the balance perfectly
between stability and tradition versus
change and modernization
a new era now begins and at this testing
moment we must now support the king who
is grieving for his mother while leading
our nation through a time of mourning
he has already lived a life of service
to others in so many ways serving in the
Royal Navy and the Royal Air Force
establishing the prince's trust and
being the patron of many many charities
just one example is his role as the
colonel in Chief of mild regiment the
parachute regiment
recounting the time he took the
parachute training course at Raf rise
Norton he said I felt I should lead from
the front or at least be able to do some
of the things that one expects others to
do for our country
it is clear that the king will follow
the example that has been set before him
to serve to lead the torch has been
handed to a new monarch and that sense
of Duty will continue to burn brightly
rest in peace Queen Elizabeth God save
King Charles
um I must urge colleagues again to try
to
um stick to the guidance of the speaker
which a reminder was three minutes just
so that we can think of each other and
make sure that we get everybody in
danger
ous with great sadness that I Rise to
pay tribute to her late Majesty the
queen on before on behalf of my
constituents in Basingstoke the late
Queen was held in the highest esteem in
my constituency and throughout the
borough of basing Stoke and Dean and
Amir councilor Paul Miller said only
today that the commitment that her
majesty made to her role and public
service the service that she has given
is matchless
my constituency has a proud loyalist
history in the siege of Beijing House
our our ancestors as committed royalists
supported an earlier King Charles and we
proudly but with sadness welcome our new
King Charles III as our Sovereign as we
all come together to grieve the loss of
her her late Majesty the queen we
remember the remarkable woman that she
was an inspiration for a nation and a
person who made us proud to be part of a
United Kingdom uh her loss will be felt
not only at home but abroad and
particularly
um by the people who make up our
Commonwealth and just two weeks ago the
Commonwealth parliamentary Association
met in Halifax Nova Scotia for its
annual meeting and we toasted her late
Majesty as our Patron and we will
remember her fondly
Madam Deputy speaker it uh helps at
times like this to share some of our
personal memories
um by way of grieving and I will always
remember the first time I had the
privilege of meeting her late Majesty it
was at Balmoral in September 2012 being
appointed as a privy counselor as many
have already referred to there are a
number of briefings when you have these
sorts of encounters and perhaps knowing
my shared love of dogs with her late
Majesty I was warned not to encounter
the corgis too closely
um because they can Madame Deputy
speaker be quite selective in who they
like and demonstrate their feelings
towards strangers quite uh overtly
um I kept my distance but my right and
will friend the member for chipping Barn
it did not
um she was far more daring with me uh
than me but left with all her fingers
intact uh Madame Doki Seeker I also
remember uh the great honor that I had
in hosting Her Majesty on Remembrance
someday uh on two occasions as Secretary
of State for culture media and Sport
walking with uh her late Majesty through
the foreign office can be a
nerve-wracking uh task in its own right
if you know the layout of the foreign
office it's quite complicated we reached
the top of the final set of stairs to
encounter the most enormous countdown
clock uh showing that we had a matter of
seconds to get out to the senatoth Her
Majesty of course trying to lighten the
mood simply said I hope you've adjusted
the timings I'm getting a bit older and
it takes me more time on the stairs
um her usual sense of humor at play and
trying to put everybody at their rest at
their ease I was humbled to receive a
damehood from her late Majesty's final
birthday honors list to Mark her
Platinum Jubilee
um and I will treasure that each of us
here today took an oath of allegiance to
her late Majesty
um to her heirs and successors so may
her late Majesty rest in peace and God
save the quick King
Julie Elliot
thank you madam Deputy speaker and it is
a huge honor to be able to take part in
this tribute session this afternoon and
on behalf of my constituents in
Sunderland Central and as has been said
before we must remember that Her
Majesty's family are grieving the loss
of them of the grandmother and great
mother grandmother and the loss of
someone in that position in a family to
those who've been through it is huge
immense and changes people's lives
forever and my sincere condolences go to
the family
the the rule of public service we all
chose to do the queen did not the queen
was born to serve and how she has served
for her 96 years to have seen that
photograph the other day receiving the
new prime minister
um she looked very frail
um clearly not in the best of health but
did any of us really think that a day or
two later she wouldn't be with us so
serving to the very end has been her
life and I think we are all grateful for
that and her wisdom and the way she has
done that has been immense I just want
to mention a couple of
um of of things in my life and memories
of the Queen the first time I saw the
queen was in the Silver Jubilee when um
the queen was traveling from gypsies
green stadium in South Shields to
Sunderland and the village I'm from is
right in the middle of those two places
and we all went to the course Road and
we only saw for probably seconds but it
felt like a lifetime and wood stood
there an hour but it was so exciting and
so uplifting and over the years every
time her majesty has come to Sunderland
you get hundreds and thousands of people
just standing just to see her car parts
I never dreamed in those days that I
would get to meet her majesty but I have
had the privilege of meeting her twice
in her Diamond Jubilee uh year and the
when she came to Sunderland that year
she came off a yacht and as she came off
the yacht in the port because it was the
most secure place for her to have slept
a Vulcan bomber went past and she came
off and she engaged and as everyone has
said that smile that engagement she had
with everybody as if you were the most
important person in the world and I'll
never forget that and finally I just
want to mention the uh the occasion I
visited London with my twin daughters to
uh to visit a concert and the traffic
stopped when we were at Trafalgar Square
and we thought all things coming past
and it was the queen so in our family
the nursery rhyme of when you go to
London to see the queen my daughters say
when we went to London we saw the queen
um but she's visited Sunderland many
many times the first time as Princess
Elizabeth and she she launched a ship
because I think it was just after the
second world war and we were the most
productive number of ships built in
Sunderland anywhere in the world but I
don't want to repeat everything that's
been said but her comforting calm
presence when she addresses the nation
is I think the thing I will miss most
the calming feeling that you got when
she addressed the nation as has been
said lastly in the pandemic of thinking
well we're all going to be all right I
think that is the thing I will miss most
that calming
nurturing feeling that we all had as if
we were one of her own so I think losing
her at the age she was
we have to celebrate a life well lived
and thanked her for her life of service
we remember her and we hope that she
rests in peace eternally
Alan cares
thank you madam Deputy speaker and on
behalf of the constituents of the
availability Morgan I Rise to pay
tribute and to give thanks for the life
of her majesty Queen Elizabeth II
amongst all the Recollections of right
honorable honorable members I will
remember her for her service Duty
humility and faith
we've witnessed many years of her
service as our longest reigning monarch
through unrecognizable change
the length of her Reign means that only
12 percent of the population has lived
longer than the time that she has been
on the throne
her duty to communities in all nations
of the United Kingdom to the union of
the United Kingdom and to the
Commonwealth was recognized across the
globe
in spite of the administer admiration in
which she was held and her standing here
and around the world her humility was
obvious in the way she acted the way she
spoke and the way she related to us all
this demonstrated her understanding of
of the challenges we all face
and at a time of increasing
secularization of society
she is someone who turned to her faith
for inspiration in challenging times and
to give thanks during the better times
Faith was something that she celebrated
rather than hidden way something that
was reflected On by The Honorable lady
honorable member for Birmingham ladywood
and I ran on with a friend for
Gainsborough
now I had the privilege of meeting her
majesty on many occasions
at one time the issue of pronunciation
of Welsh place names came up in
conversation
to my amazement
she said that the one she recalls best
was koid of heater Glen
at a property within my constituency
that even locals wrongly pronounce as
cadriglan
it turned out that she spent many
Summers during her childhood playing on
the estate of the late sir Canada
Glenn and she'd said that she was
determined during her childhood to learn
to pronounce the place properly
at these sad times we now owe the
service and commitment that she showed
to us to her son and to King Charles III
Madam Deputy speaker God Save the King
Tim fahren
thank you madam Deputy speaker
um Cumbria Mourns the loss of the
Majesty Queen Elizabeth II and I
personally and all of us in our County
want to express our genuine and deep
condolences to the royal family we have
lost our Queen and it touches every one
of us we can tell in the the
contributions so far today that this is
a personal loss for us but how much more
is it a personal loss for those who have
lost a mother a grandmother a great
grandmother we grieve with them and we
thank her for her service the news
reached us yesterday as we were winding
down the Westmoreland County show the
news was devastating and yet it caught
us while we were together and it feels
like an honor that that was the case
there had been a a tremendous couple of
days of thousands of us being in the
same place and those same muddy Fields
enjoying time together and then that
moment of dismal Unity came about but I
am glad it happened when we were all
together the landmarks of her Reign have
been the landmarks of each of Our Lives
Many who are even older than me uh will
of course remember her acceding to the
throne but I remember the Silver Jubilee
dancing around a maypole at the age of
seven in 1977 as a a father of a new
young child with the golden jubilee we
think of the Diamond Jubilee and the joy
earlier this year of the Platinum
Jubilee her life was our life and her
history has become our history they are
an Inseparable indivisible and we will
ever be touched by it and her Reign
United us her passing must also too and
I believe it has and it will already as
we transfer our allegiance to her
beloved Son King Charles the third
Cumbria the lakes and The Dales Were
Loved By Her Majesty the queen and we
loved her in return her visits to
Cumbria were always massively special to
us and relatively recently her visits to
Kendall and Windermere where she was
presented with Westland wildflowers to
honor her with Lakeland wool to warmer
and Kendall mint cake to sustain her and
my times of uh spending time with the
queen was relatively few but one in
particular I recall where I've been an
MP for a very short period of time at
this stage and she offered me some
advice about what you do in a
constituent who has had a letter from
you thank you for it and you don't
remember the details and she said that
happens to me all the time and I always
say it's the least I could do which is a
wonderful get out phrase and I confessed
a few of my constituents I have
occasionally deployed it and as has been
said her majesty did not seek her office
she practiced it with utter humility the
most famous human being on planet Earth
and yet she acted with the grace and
humility that none of us here no offense
please has ever managed to match so she
was a constant to us all and has been
said already but the constant in her
life was her faith in Jesus Christ now
let's remember this that for many people
you know it may have been but for her it
was not a perfunctory ceremonial faith
it was a living active faith in a living
savior let us remember this that we have
sung for 70 years God saved the queen if
her faith is accurate I am certain it
was God has saved the Queen We Now
transfer allegiance to King Charles III
who I am proud and honored to serve God
Save the King okay Robert genre thank
you madam Deputy speaker and I'm
grateful to you for permitting front
benches to speak from the back bench
although in my case it's sometimes hard
to keep up I'm aware that my appointment
with others was one of the last acts of
our late majesty and that is a thought
that will lie with me every day that I
go about my duties because she really
was the last of a generation that has
now passed a generation marked by
stoicism humility modesty and service
qualities too often neglected in our
politics and our public life and ones
that I like all of us in this house seek
to emulate
I am here to represent my constituents
in the loyal borough of Newark Upon
Trent loyal because in May 1646 we were
the last town to hold out in the English
Civil War a town that only surrendered
when the king himself a forebear of her
majesty another Charles said that we
must do so and at the end of the war the
town was wrapped with disease and
pestilence but all of the Contemporary
accounts show that no one regretted
their decision to stand by the Monarch
and that to me shows that even in a
hereditary monarchy and certainly in our
modern democracy loyalty of the people
to the crown is not something that
anyone or anyone can take for granted it
has to be earned
and from the speeches made across the
chamber today we can see that her
majesty the queen of the course of her
long and remarkable Reign earned the
respect and admiration indeed the love
of her people
she really has been the golden thread
that has run through the weave and the
weft of our national story my
grandmother stood in the crowds on the
Mao and watched her and her family
celebrate on VE Day my dad watched like
others have spoken on a small rented
television set the coronation marveled
at her beauty afterwards he went and
created a bonfire on the street and he
took the council years to fill in the
pothole so something fairly never
changed
I I met her majesty only a few times one
as has been said by other members on
Zoom at a privy council meeting
and as we all experienced during the
pandemic so many times the zoom failed
and then out of the darkness suddenly a
voice emerged and it was her majesty the
queen and she said well thank goodness
someone kept a landline
just the other day I went with my family
my children who are the great
grandchildren of Holocaust Survivors to
see Anne Frank's house
and my children came to me they were
ahead of us in the the tour and they
said that in the Secret Annex ahead
amongst the images on the walls were
photos of her majesty the queen princess
Elizabeth and her sister Princess
Margaret
and I later research with my daughters
why was that
and Otto Frank
their mother their father
is recorded later in life in saying
Anne Frank loved the Royals
but it wasn't just that
he wanted to put some photos on the wall
that would give the children strength
and Anne Frank said
it was also the beautiful smile that
kept her going
may she rest in peace
and God Save the King Valerie thanks
Madam Deputy speaking it's a pleasure to
follow the honorable member for the
loyal constituency of New York uh Madam
Deputy speaker it falls to our
generation to tell at the passing of our
gracious Sovereign of the passing of a
platinum Elizabethan age of a young
woman with responsibility thrust on her
but without a manual she wrote her own
story and in doing so wrote the story of
our nation through which we've all lived
we have known her as the young woman who
actively supported the war effort and
danced in the street when it was over
jumping out of planes showing us her
sense of humor at the Olympic ceremony
in 2012 that showed us we were more than
just medals I was in Walsall yesterday
when I heard the sad news of Queen
Elizabeth's passing I know my
constituents in walls all South are
grieving the owner a fortune cookie our
local Chinese Takeaway was in tears and
again like every other member every
school I've ever visited the question is
always asked have you met the queen and
Lorna based in Walsall South makes her
handbags I hope that link will continue
especially now that we know thanks to a
refugee from Peru she used to keep her
marmalade sandwiches to keep her going
as a lawyer all I ever knew was a
queen's bench division or Queen's
Council that like our stamps and notes
will change to Herald a new era having
been born in Aiden to go in parents I
had never imagined I would meet Queen
Elizabeth
but I did in the gallery in the other
place the British museum or at the privy
Council
those who had an audience with her can
testify to her wisdom and generosity of
spirit she had the ability to speak with
you as though she'd known you forever
whether to a winning jockey or a little
girl with a posey or working to the end
to welcome her 15th prime minister
like all of us she knew life is a roller
coaster but she never complained and
only ever mentioned one year as an anus
oribilis Our Queen carried out her
duties with dignity Grace and love for
us and her country and yet he Embrace
different countries and cultures through
the Commonwealth while always respecting
differences and dealing with changes
acknowledging past mistakes knowing that
life and history moves on
Queen Elizabeth reminded us that we are
human beings first and members of a race
second and our duty is to help each
other make this world a better place
and live in peace just as she said in
her first broadcast and how we will miss
those quiet reassuring messages to the
nation at Christmas and at difficult
times
Duty service defender of the faith and
love for her United Kingdom a constant
that brought us all together
the Brighton full moon Shone down last
night and there was a rainbow over
Windsor Castle and it reminded us of
God's promise
to his faithful
we pray for her grieving family to get
through this difficult time
and for especially for King Charles III
Eternal respondent Queen Elizabeth
Alexandra Mary winter may she rest in
peace
Tobias Elwood thank you very much Madam
Deputy speaker these are indeed the
saddest of times for us to gather here
today to pay tribute to the late Majesty
the queen
I suspect that we all will remember
where we were yesterday when news came
that doctors were Gravely concerned
about Her Majesty's health
our world was suddenly put on hold and
then came the announcement that we had
dreaded to hear our rock or stability
the one person who came to symbolize the
very best of Britain was no longer with
us
Her Majesty's
sense of Duty to serve was especially
appreciated by our Armed Forces
that phrase for Queen and country is not
just a catchphrase it's the allegiance
you pledge when you join Her Majesty's
armed forces the queen was our commander
in chief and she was only too aware
having served herself of the sacrifices
Personnel were willing to make all done
in her name
this emptiness that we now feel is a
testament to the admiration the respect
and the affection that we all had for
her
we have not known they Britain indeed
without her
perhaps we can consider ourselves
fortunate
that the nation was able to come
together this year to Mark the Queen's
Platinum Jubilee and celebrate with her
a most incredible life of service from
the street parties across the country
including in my constituency in
Bournemouth East
to that wonderful celebration outside
Buckingham Palace where the queen and
Paddington Bear stole the show
only on one occasion did I have cause to
formally write to her majesty and that
was to ask her if she would agree to
parliament's Clock Tower to be renamed
the Elizabeth Tower to Mark the Diamond
Jubilee ten years ago
I was truly honored when she accepted
that name was formally changed and we
now have a constant parliamentary
Landmark honoring her majesty
as we now mourn the person we knew we
should reflect the constant is also the
monarchy itself the British Monarchy
that has matured over centuries and
allowed our great great country to
advance to mature to thrive as a
democracy
her loss does of course leave a mark the
end of an era but in our new king who is
well prepared to serve the monarchy will
continue to play its role in how our
state functions
so yes we do mourn the loss of our Queen
but we also transfer our faith our
allegiance to our new king his majesty
Charles III long live the king
Angela Rayner
thank you madam deputy speaker and thank
you to call
to call across the house for their
moving work today
like other members I have found the
outpouring of affection from both our
Shores and across the world for our
Queen deeply heartwarming I hope the
royal family finds solace in this over
the coming days and weeks
I have always taken great inspiration
from our Queen she was a woman who found
herself in a position of leadership at
such a young age a woman who threw
herself into Service as not just the
most recognizable but also the most
admired of global leaders a woman who
stared those of us through loved times
of Joy darkness and always drawing on
her own experience and inner strength to
help those that most need it
and I'm in awe of the way she took on
this unimaginable responsibility
she got on with the job
she never stopped and she has set an
example for all of us
one of the most proudest moments of my
life and also for my family was when I
was sworn into the privy Council these
kind of things don't happen to a girl
like me
it was surreal to me her majesty the
Queen Elizabeth II herself via Zoom
she could put anyone at ease adapting to
the challenges and the circumstances and
the change
most of all though she was a loving
grandmother and for me as a grandmother
myself I know and understand the
complete love that she had for her
family her children and her
grandchildren were the center of her
life and I know the whole house shares
in both their pain and their pride
so what she was our Queen our national
figurehead and the greatest and longest
serving Monarch in British history
to them she was also granny
the loss of such a loving presence will
be heartbreaking and my heart goes out
to them
who Majesty the late Queen was a
constant figure of strength integrity
and service throughout our lives she was
an inspiration to women across the world
with complete Devotion to her Duty her
family and her country she set an
example of leadership for women
everywhere
the outpouring of condolences from
leaders across the world is Testament to
that
more recently we will never forget how
she guided us through the Despair and
loneliness of the pandemic and her
values of public service and dignity
never wavered
it is appropriate today that I speak
from the back benches because our Queen
was greatly loved and admired by the
people of my constituency she visited
greater Manchester many times and was
always welcomed With Love by the local
community and she was last in Manchester
a year ago to visit Coronation Street
where she the cast greeted her at the
Rover's return Pub to celebrate the
show's 60th anniversary and it's just
three months since the streets of
ashton-drowson and fellsworth were depth
with Union Jack flags as we came
together to celebrate the Platinum
Jubilee our local papers were proud and
our local community was proud
she's now gone but she will be forever
missed and always in our hearts
may she rest in peace
God Save the King
Alex job
thank you Mr Speaker and I pay tribute
to the extraordinarily warm and moving
tribute just played by The Honorable
lady right honorable lady
Queen Elizabeth II famously referred to
her late husband as her strength and
stay
but although she would never have
claimed it for herself it was she who
was the strength and stay of an entire
nation and indeed the Commonwealth
the constancy and humble commitment to
duty were the Hallmarks of her life she
embodied body values that the best of
our country in a world of increasing
noise and self-promotion she provided
that Counterpoint of quiet Poise and
dignity
we in Cheltenham are proud of a
lifetime's connection with Queen
Elizabeth II it was as a young princess
that she came to our town she gave her
name to princess Elizabeth way which
remains a major Cheltenham thoroughfare
and she did so by planting an oak tree
in 1951 to Mark its completion
later that same year she was at the
races the Cheltenham Gold Cup with her
mother Now history doesn't relate which
Cheltenham eventually joined more
opening the road or going to the races
we may have our suspicions but she was
far too professional to ever let on
Prince Philip was back in 1957 to open
an extension to what is now the
University of gloucestershire and in
2004 she was in Cheltenham to open gchq
or the donut as we refer to it
indeed she was a strong supporter of the
intelligence agencies and unveiled the
plaque in 2019 at gchq's first London
home
she had a quick mind as many have
observed and was very much up to speed
on current events and so when in
Cheltenham in 2004 she observed the
Magnificent hanging baskets which then
decorated the front of the municipal
offices she recalled a recent media
story about a hanging basket landing on
someone's head elsewhere she noted that
cheltenham's display was so magnificent
it could Wipe Out the entire Council
like many people I sat down with my
children yesterday age 10 and 8 and I
tried to convey the scale of what had
happened
children cannot and probably should not
bear as we do the aching pain of this
loss
but as we mourn let us explain to them
what her majesty Queen Elizabeth II
meant to this nation
just as her majesty the queen dedicated
herself to the service of our country in
1952 let us dedicate ourselves to
immortalizing her values Duty Integrity
selflessness country and kindness
as a woman of faith I hope she would
have approached the end with peace
yesterday as her death was announced I
thought of her family and those who were
close by as in the words of a young RAF
pilot in 1941
she slipped The Surly Bonds of Earth to
touch the face of God
Save the King
Ali thank you Mr Deputy speaker on
behalf of my constituents I Rise to pay
tribute to her majesty the Queen We
mourn the passing of an icon
she was admired across the world and
touched Our Lives is in so many positive
ways the queen was a constant example of
service of Duty of wisdom of dedication
to her people her country and the
Commonwealth these were her Civic
virtues needed now more than ever she
began her life of service as a child and
worked until the final days of her life
the tone was set during World War II
when the then king and queen chose to
stay in London during the Blitz and the
young princess Elizabeth joined the
auxiliary territorial Army when their
home Buckingham Palace was bombed the
Queen Mother famously said that she
could now look the East End in the face
ever since then
EastEnders have embraced the queen and
her family with a particular Bond of
love and loyalty
of course today's East End is different
is a very different place more diverse
and more connected to the rest of the
world and in particular the commonwealth
countries
Her Majesty reimagined Britain's
post-colonial place in the world and the
Commonwealth has grown to 54 nations
with nearly two and a half billion
people
Mr Deputy speaker I can personally
relate to the story of the Commonwealth
as a child born in a commonwealth
country Bangladesh which joined in 1972
And I remember in 1983 watching with
pride the queen visiting that very very
new country
with Prince Philip
it was a state visit and a big moment
for a new nation and it was a time and a
moment that made us feel proud to be
British made us feel we belonged not
only to this country but also to the
Commonwealth Family and across the
Commonwealth people are remembering when
the queen came to town with a great
sense of warmth and affection
and here at home in my constituency I
had the honor of receiving the queen
during the Royal London hospital visit
when he when the new facilities were
opened the hospital that was at the
heart of our national life and at the
epicenter of coping with the pandemic
the Queen's words during the pandemic
was so necessary to give hope and
comfort when constituents a like mine
were in constituencies like mine were
hit so hard and others have mentioned
the Olympic ceremony when when one of
the highlights was when it seemed that
the that her majesty and her most loyal
servant James Bond were parachuting into
the Olympic stadium in London's East End
Mr Deputy speaker we pride ourselves in
being the coolest part of the country
Her Majesty Her Majesty made us the
coolest place on Earth with that stunt
on behalf of my constituents
we we
our thoughts are with her children her
grandchildren her wider family and her
Heir and successor his majesty King King
Charles III Mr Speaker Her Majesty was
unique she radiated warmth she embodied
decency we will never see her like again
we will never know such a paragon of
civic virtue and a shining Beacon of
Public Service may she rest in peace
long live the king
crab thank you Mr Deputy speaker it's
pleasure to follow the excellent speech
from The Honorable lady for basketball
green and Beau I rise on behalf of all
of my constituents in prosely
pembrokeshire to convey our condolences
to his majesty King Charles III and all
members of the royal family at this sad
time and to say thank you for a
wonderful long and full life and an
extraordinary Reign that's been a
blessing to our nation for seven decades
Queen Elizabeth II was loved and
respected all across the historic County
of pembrokeshire where her family of
course had ancestral Roots through the
Tudor line
and we enjoyed her visits to
pembrokeshire to St David's Cathedral or
to visit so many of the excellent
Charities and Community groups that we
have in the constituency
for millions of adults and certainly for
children certainly when we meet them in
constituency school visits Queen
Elizabeth absolutely had something of
that mystique and Magic that we perhaps
associate with an earlier Queen
Elizabeth over the Disney fairy tale
queen but her Reign was also an
extraordinarily human and personal rain
as we've been hearing so often today
shaped as it was by her amazing capacity
to touch people at a very individual
level to raise their self-esteem to
touch their hearts in a very very
special way that left lasting lifetime
memories and for now Mr Deputy speaker
that joy that she gave to the nation to
people in all of our constituencies that
she met for now that Joy gives way to
grief and sadness in time we will
remember the rain with joy once again
but in the meantime we ask God to bless
her and to save King Griffith
very much indeed Mr Deputy speaker for
giving me this opportunity to speak in
tribute to her late Majesty uh Queen
Elizabeth II I would firstly like to
begin by expressing my most sincere
condolences to her family on my own
behalf and on behalf of the people
across the constituency of clanetti our
thoughts are particularly with the King
Charles III her other children her
grandchildren their families for them
this is a deeply personal loss and
whilst they've always had to share the
queen their mother and grandmother with
the public that is particularly hard at
this time immense grief and for them too
this follows so close on the loss of
their father and grandfather the late
Prince Philip I'd like to sit on record
my huge appreciation for the way the
queen carried out her duties shouldering
an enormous workload and responsibility
from a young age for a full 70 years
including working right into this week
appointing the new prime minister the
queen was absolutely exemplary in her
dedication and commitment an example to
all of us in public life
but she went above and beyond that
taking a personal interest in matters
and showing real empathy with people
and in Wales we were very privileged to
receive her visits on many occasions and
she's been with us for important moments
in our nation's history opening the
National Assembly for Wales in 1999 and
last year opening the sixth session of
the Senate in relation to that visit I
would like to tell you about a young
woman fiang weather from my constituency
who at the opening of The Centers was
tasked with presenting Her Majesty with
a bouquet of flowers but as you can
imagine as that moment approached she
was very very nervous
but you need not have worried the queen
looked at her and immediately understood
the situation and put her at ease asking
her gently are those flowers for me how
beautiful they match my outfit that's a
moment that film will never forget and
is just one of countless examples of how
the queen was always so kind and
thoughtful in her approach and knew
exactly how to handle the occasion and
put a young woman at ease and during her
Reign she would have touched millions in
the same way
but it's not only on Happy occasions
that the queen has visited Wales she
will always be remembered for her visit
to abervan in the aftermath of terrible
tragedy of 1966 when a slight Heap
buried the school
this has been put on record by Jeff
Edwards the last child to be rescued
from the school speaking about her visit
he stressed the community's appreciation
saying that people felt comfort from the
fact that Queen who was head of state
had come to a small mining Village and
had shown direct interest and concern
for her subjects who had gone through
this enormous event
but the Queen's role goes far beyond
Wales and Beyond the UK to the
Commonwealth there we have seen huge
changes a complex transition from the
Empire to today's Commonwealth with such
a range of Nations each with its own
particular circumstances it is no wonder
that sometimes tensions have arisen we
must recognize the crucial role that the
queen has played in maintaining what is
a unique family of Nations there is no
doubt that her wisdom and
professionalism her personal rapport
with individuals and very high esteem in
which he's held have been pivotal in
helping to smooth out transition and
keeping the Commonwealth together
and now as a deputy speaker going
forward the best tribute that we can
give is to follow her excellent example
and to try and serve our communities
with the same dedication and fortitude
that she's showed throughout her life
so as we turn to the Future long live
the king
thank you Mr Deputy speaker as someone
with the honor of representing the
faithful city of Worcester I want to
pass on the love prayers and good wishes
of constituents faith and Civic leaders
to all the royal family and especially
his majesty the king at this sad and
historic moment I can associate myself
with so many of the superlatives we have
heard from across the house today but I
want to focus on two things Her
Majesty's faith and her profound
connection as The Honorable lady who
just spoke was speaking about with
children her late Majesty swore at her
coronation to be a defender of the faith
and in so many messages over the decades
she not only defended but enhanced and
gently protected for role of faith in
our society not only for her own church
of England but as we've heard from
people of all faith and denominations
for people across the whole of the
United Kingdom of all faiths and none
when Princess Elizabeth first visited
Worcester in 1951 she was already the
mother of two small children and the
beautiful princess was greeted by flower
girls and a parade of out some guides
outside the cathedral as a lifelong
patron of the guides and former Girl
Guide herself as well as the fount of so
many Queen Scout awards she has inspired
millions of young people she returned as
Queen in 1957 and visited New Road the
most beautiful cricket ground in England
with her consort Prince Philip touring
the boundary in an open top Land Rover
to the cheers of 5 000 local school
children after more visits in the 1980s
when she distributed Monday money and
celebrated the anniversary of the city's
Charter her final visit to Worcester and
the proudest moment of my life was at
her Diamond Jubilee Her Majesty opened
the hive Library a joint City and
University Library which is the first of
its kind in Europe and a fabulous
repository of children's books and I was
fortunate enough to be among the
welcoming party on that visit so join
some volunteers from local charities and
children from local schools at the event
and being presented to her majesty the
queen what struck me is so many have
already reported was her smile her
bright humorous eyes had genuine
interest in the people to whom she was
introduced and the instant connection
she formed with the children most
recently children in schools up and down
our country were able to celebrate and
learn about her majesty at the
remarkable Platinum Jubilee and they
joined children in successive gen
Generations in singing dancing and
making wonderful art to celebrate a
jubilee of this longest serving
Sovereign she was described by one of
our former Prime Ministers as a
matriarch and of course that is right
but I think we've also lost the world's
favorite granny
um I would join with my honorable friend
for my reasonable friend for Pendle and
with Paddington there in simply saying
on behalf of us all thank you Mom for
everything yeah yeah I mean Thompson
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I'm here to
offer my and the condolences of the
people of the bloody and on this very
sad occasion and amidst the ebb and flow
of people politics and power Queen
Elizabeth has always been there a
steadfast figure in our shared history
with quiet dignity she made her Mark in
momentous Global events but perhaps more
importantly she touched people in a very
personal way across these Isles the
queen is part of the backdrop of the
stories of all of our Lives the queen
brought Grace warmth dignity and humor
to a role which in turn brought respect
from people across political divides and
her passing brings an unsettling time a
time of grief and Ruth lost
people across the nations may feel
understandably they've lost a loved one
of their own
yet already preparations are underway
and Duty occupies the new King Charles
III showing then the immortal words of
Terry Fletcher the truly the only thing
known to travel faster than ordinary
light is indeed monarchy
but regardless of our views and monarchy
the queen is respected for her
remarkable dignity with which she held
herself throughout trying times and we
appreciate the twinkle in awry her humor
her love of animals and humility with
which she held from far from Humble
office
she was the first Queen Elizabeth in
Scotland of course with lineage
stretching back to the Stewart Dynasty
and Mary Queen of Scots in Scotland
hosting Barbecues in the hills of
Balmoral it said that was where she was
happiest
older Generations were fondly remember
the Royal tour of Midlothian back in
1961 where she was out and about across
the county viewing aspects of everyday
life and visiting in Roseland Chapel or
the rural housing schemes at Temple the
carpet Factory in bonnyriggan to the
lone Head Memorial Park there was no
standing room left in the streets of
dalkeith at this time with crowds
climbing in the roof of the bus station
seeking a glimpse of the young Queen and
more recently she was warmly welcome
back to Midlothian for the reopening of
the borders Railway unveiling a plaque
at the station in Newton Grange where
she was welcomed with a wonderful
performance by the New England silver
band who expressed their condolences at
this time
people from all walks of life in
Midlothian wish to convey their respect
and make it clear just how fondly the
queen is remembered condolences have
been expressed online by Community
groups across Midlothian in addition to
midlothians Lord lieutenant and Provost
who have already held local tributes and
in line with many other places have
opened up book of condolence across
Council venues in midlothians allow
people to pay their own tributes and
master Deputy speaker is a previous
member in the current chair of the old
party group for the boys Brigade I've
always been keenly aware of our
Majesty's roles the organization's
Patron and they know that all in the
boys Brigade World wish to pass on their
thoughts and prayers of the entire boys
Brigade family at this time we're all
now getting our heads around the changes
that this will make to the basic things
that we all took for granted the ground
has shifted beneath our feet and the
lives at my local post office in Lone
head said every day we send hundreds of
letters and Parcels burning the Queen's
head and this will now be no more
what makes you rest in peace yeah Andrew
Morrison
Mr Deputy speaker I Rise with thee deep
and profound condolences of my
constituents in Southwest Wiltshire
a good and gracious lady has been taken
from us and we're all the poorer for
that
a lady who has shaped the Contours of
our national life for 70 years has gone
but a legacy endures and if you doubt
that just see the pictures of his
majesty in the hour of his grief
greeting the crowds that have gathered
outside Buckingham Palace today
Mr Deputy speaker grown men don't cry do
they
well they do
and I've cried twice in my adult life
once when my father died
and once last night
for a woman that I had only met once at
the aforementioned gin and tonic
opportunity that a number of honorable
right honorable members have cited today
but unfortunately on my in my case there
was no gin and tonic
and the reason it is so profound for
most of us is for most of our Lives all
of our Lives she has been a constant
somebody who has always been there a
rock a stable place someone to look to
and to admire and like many colleagues
around the house today when I go to
primary schools I'm asked two questions
usually one more difficult to answer
than the other have you met the queen
and how much you pay
last night I called my mother because I
knew she'd be upset and she was
in June 1953 she like many of her
generation lined the Streets of London
to watch another young woman go to her
coronation
that was a profound moment for her and a
extraordinary moment in the life of our
nation and very soon we will do
something again under altogether more
somber circumstances but her sense of
profound loss is certainly
replicated right across this land and by
people of all generations and if I can
say particularly since I remain a member
of his Majesty's Armed Forces
by the Armed Forces of this country who
have lost their Commander in Chief many
of whom live in the towns and Villages
around Salisbury Plain that I have the
honor and privilege to represent
now in 878 Alfred the Great
secured the future of what became Wessex
and ultimately the nation-state we know
today
the great is a descriptor that should
not be used likely
Queen Elizabeth II is The Benchmark for
monarchs in this age and ages past
she is Elizabeth the Great
as the Elizabeth bethan age closes and
the Caroline era dawns
we have to understand
that it will look and feel different we
will look and feel different
but drift difference will bring renewal
and it will bring opportunity
as his majesty has demonstrated today
rest well your majesty
God Save the King yeah we sell more
thank you very much Mr Temple sneaker it
is a privilege to offer the condolences
of my constituents to his majesty the
king and indeed to all members of the
royal family my constituency is
privileged to be able to thank her late
majesty and indeed at the time his Royal
Highness the Prince of Wales now of
course the king for securing so many
being being developed in my constituency
as the managing director of Sony UK told
me today thousands of my constituents
have benefited from the direct
intervention of her majesty and indeed
now his majesty
the site was opened by the lake Queen in
1993 and it was in fact the king in 1974
on a visit to Japan who said to the
Venture executive of Sony
if you consider putting something in the
UK please put something in my country
Wales
I think of her late Majesty in the forms
of fun and friendship and just like the
member for Southwest Wiltshire I'm
frequently Asked whenever I go to a
school visit be they teenagers or
primary schools have you ever met the
queen to which the answer is sort of
I've seen her
um I've been at the at the box in the
Lords for the for the queen speech
I once was asked following the question
have you ever touched the queen
I'm not sure who was more shocked me or
the head teacher who genuinely looked
like he was about to faint
the queen had
a healthy obsession with trees
and I can recall fondly
the talks that she held with the David
Attenborough that has been running on
Clips over the last few days about the
Queen's canopy and the work that he was
doing to talk about delivering this
right across our United Kingdom and she
joked that we her and Sir David would
not see that tree come to its 50-year
life they both laughed
and it's her humility that so many of us
will think of so fondly
I have had the privilege with Deputy
speaker in my brief time in his house to
have met now King Charles III twice the
first five days after I was elected in a
by-election in 2016. I was lined up by
the secretary of the Lord lieutenant and
told just stand there Mr Elmo he'll be
along shortly when he arrived came out
the car I was the second person to greet
him to which he said to me you're the
new one
and he said and I was quite nervous yes
yes your Royal Highness because I
wouldn't worry about it I'm terribly
nice
and I think that common touch
is what he has picked up from the late
queen and I know he will go on to serve
this country well to serve the
Commonwealth well
God bless and keep the queen and all
home on her and God Save the King I'd
like to thank chrisamo for keeping well
within the three-minute limit so please
could people look at their contributions
keep them as short as you can because we
want to get as many and as we possibly
can Esther McAfee
speaker there has been so many wonderful
moving tributes today it's been a real
pleasure to be in the chamber to listen
to them all and with your permission Mr
Deputy speaker I will make my tribute
Through The Eyes of the school children
of Tatton for so many MPS have mentioned
here today the Curiosity those children
have of the late Queen Elizabeth II and
the question they do ask particularly in
primary school and Junior School is have
you met the queen and when I say yes
there are literally squeals of delight
gasps of disbelief uncontainable
excitement Ripple through the class such
was the impact that this lady had on all
the people of this country of all ages
and of all parts of the country she
loved children and children loved her
and the clatter of questions that
followed were you nervous when you met
her how was she what's she like where
did you meet her so I try and describe
the queen to them as they sit and listen
Eyes Wide Open well I say she's
diminutive or she was diminutive yet she
was imposing she was gentle yet Steely
and that Powder Puff gray her she was
radiant and she Sean but it was her eyes
that were remarkable and memorable they
were penetrating and bottomless the
knowledge behind them Limitless you can
almost feel what she had seen and what
she had experienced you were in the
presence of wisdom and they are kind to
she was a curious blend quite disarming
and yet incredibly caring and was I
nervous without doubt you're in the
presence of greatness whose life has
spanned War and Peace and that
nervousness is Amplified by the Royal
protocol which she lives through and by
so when you made a privy counselor and
you've got steps to take Niels to Bow
it's meticulous choreography the timing
quick steps Neil's Precision of words
and taking Oaths and the Seal of office
2 at Sandringham it was magical it was a
whirl of rooms and doors opening
it was brevity but intensity and as we
left we were all handed a packed lunch
and also I could say it was thoughtful
but simple No Frills I think it was
nutritionally balanced there was no
there was no fuss whatsoever it was all
bother and nonsense and as Deputy chip
Chief whip I was also Treasurer To Her
Majesty's household but what she did
love and where I met her and spent more
time with the words at Windsor Castle
with her horses in her Stables which she
absolutely loved and she confided that
one of her best memories was the day
that estimate won the Ascot Gold Cup at
Royal Ascot trained by Sir Michael Stout
and she spoke to her trainers without
fail every week Nikki Henderson and John
Gosden but that was what she loved so
I'm absolutely delighted that the saint
Ledger is going ahead this weekend not
least because the queen won the Saint
Ledger and her Silver Jubilee year with
dunfer written by Willie Carson one of
her favorite jockeys but kind and
finally thoughtful and my final
conversation with her she
questioned social media and the impact
it had and she said could anybody these
days keep a secret
she talked about operation mincemeat the
deception that fooled Hitler and helped
us win the war and she said can people
keep things to themselves or do they
feel that they'd sooner tell everybody
and maybe spoil what should be done
so when I leave children I say have you
got discretion can you keep a secret are
you selfless can you think of the
greater good more than you can think of
yourself
and if you can then the queen has done
her job and her spirit and her qualities
will live on in all of us God bless the
queen God Save the King
thank you very much Mr Deputy speaker
it's a pleasure to follow the honorable
lady from tatman
um
Queen Elizabeth was just 10 years old
when her uncle abdicated and she became
heir to the throne
she was just 13 when war broke out and
in the six years that followed we saw
the pattern of her whole life to come
standing with her people in those dark
hours at home and across the
Commonwealth sharing in their grief
when her own Uncle fell in service
leading on national celebrations when
Victory and freedom was finally secured
and throughout the war setting the
perfect example by Rolling her sleeves
up and doing her bit for the collective
effort
yeah well the second world war inspired
Millions to incredible Feats and brought
out the very best in our country what we
saw in those years from The Young
princess Elizabeth was what we would
come to understand as her normal
for the next seven decades you continue
to set the perfect example of dedicated
selfless Timeless service and embody the
values that unite our people
she continued to share our grief when
tragedy struck the nation whether it was
abavan or dunblane or 7-7 when so many
people in Islington were killed and she
didn't Buckle when it touched her own
family she continued to stand with us in
our darkest and most fearful hours and
more so when
when she gave those messages of Hope and
courage that inspired all of us at the
start of the pandemic and she continued
to lead our national celebrations right
up to the point in recent years when the
biggest most United celebrations of all
were to Mark her own birthdays and
jubilees
she did all that for us
she lived her life
for us
and while she may have visited 200
hospitals or 2 000 schools she may have
cut 5 000 ribbons awarded twenty
thousand medals shaking the hands of
hundreds of thousands she never forgot
for one moment
that while on those those were daily
duties were nothing out of the ordinary
for her they were deeply special deeply
special for everyone that she met and
that she enjoyed that each of those
individuals would go away with a unique
memory
of what she had said to them how she had
smiled at them and the interest that she
took in their service to the country
which is for so many so many people
those encounters with the queen will be
remembered as the greatest moments in
their lives and I know that in Islington
there are at this moment lists being
compiled of the visits that she made to
our Borough and and and and and Stories
being shared of the many times that we
had the opportunity to see her and to
experience a meeting with her and so we
join today to thank the queen for nine
Decades of devoted service every one of
them
filled with
setting the right example filled with
giving her people courage sympathy and
joy
filled with making others feel special
and doing it all day after day year
after year write up until the very end
that record of Duty would be
unfathomable astonishing and worthy of
celebration in this house even if she
had been a humble librarian or a
long-serving charity volunteer
but to do all that in the pressure of
her roles as heir to the throne and head
of state places her public service on a
pinnacle which is unmatched in the
history of our country and the like of
which we will never see again
on behalf of the honorable artillery
company the Charter House found on
crossrail with all of whom she shared a
particularly strong links and on behalf
of the people of Islington South and
Finsbury who loved her so dearly I thank
you ma'am God Save the King yeah Stuart
Andrew
thank you thank you very much Mr Deputy
speaker and this is the sadness that I
offer my tribute to her late Majesty the
queen on my behalf and then of course on
behalf of the people of Pudsey horse for
the neighbor I suppose the first time
the queen came into my Consciousness was
as a small boy standing outside the
house waiting for some lady in a big
Posh car to go past as she marked her a
silver jubilee in 1977 and from then on
there were many occasions where we would
enjoy Royal occasions those jubilees the
Royal weddings all helped us to enjoy
Street parties on our estate
and I thought about those Street parties
when the Queen's 90th birthday was
coming and thought I haven't seen one in
our community for some time and so we
decided a group of friends of ours to
organize one and we were staggered when
thousands of people in the community
came out to celebrate Her Majesty's 90th
birthday
and we saw it also reflected in the Mal
just recently in the Jubilee where
literally hundreds of thousands turned
up and why well because they respected
and they loved her yeah because they
recognized that this was a woman of
great dedication and who wanted to serve
her country in the best way that she
could and that she would work to the
very last day as she committed to do all
those many years ago and last night a
couple of us went up to the palace and
again people were there meeting
strangers talking all sharing
conversations and memories about the
late Her Majesty the Queen the public
the British public showing how much they
loved her
and then she was there when we needed
her most many have talked about the
pandemics but also when our country has
had those awful terrorist attacks and
she has always given warm words
Comfort to those victims and to their
families and we will remember that
amazing speech he made in the hospital
in London where she said that they will
not change our way of life
I don't know about anybody else but
whenever I visit a constituent who's
celebrating their 100th birthday the
card from her majesty the queen is front
and center in the living room because of
course why wouldn't they there is such a
proud thing for them to have and many
have also mentioned about school
children asking have you met the queen
and for many years in this place I was
unable to say that I had until I was
honored to be appointed as the vice
Chamberlain of the household and I
remember my moment when I was going to
be I was being introduced to her waiting
for these doors to open and when they
finally did realizing that I actually
had become that little boy again
standing there with my knees knocking
and wondering how I might address Her
Majesty but as others have said she put
me at ease and she made me feel
incredibly welcome and as the vice
Chamberlain I also had to write the
daily reports from this place uh just to
say that she liked the gossip I
understand uh is is heartwarming but
also as Vice Chamberlain I was hostage
so I was taking hostage up there while
she came here to open Parliament and I
was offered a drink and they said would
you like tea or coffee and one of them
looked at me and thought you look more
like a Champagne Manor well I'm never
going to do this again so why not well
it was a big bottle of champagne and I
had a good time
a couple of months later we had the
general election and I had to do it
again and as her majesty was leaving
Buckingham Palace she turned to me and
she said and you have a good time again
won't you
know to conclude Mr Deputy speaker that
during the awful attacks of 9 11 the
queen said to the people of America
grief is the price we pay for love
well we are we all loved her and that is
why we are grieving and we send our
thoughts and best wishes wishes to his
majesty the king and his family and we
say God Save the King
say please look again at your
contributions so that they are sticking
to the three minutes Alistair Carmichael
Deputy speaker
um I'm grateful to you for the
opportunity to try and articulate the uh
very keen and profound sense of loss
that there is felt across the northern
Isles today our Majesty made a number of
visits to ordney and to Shetland over
the years of her Reign all of which
built a real connection between
arcadians and shetlanders and their
Monarch one of the biggest remembered is
in 1960 when she took the Royal yacht
LaTanya into stronzi and Sandy in a
sorry into strongsian Wesley in orkney
Prince Philip was given the job of
driving her around Westley in their then
most suitable available vehicle the new
12-seater school bus It produced one of
the best pictures of her majesty that I
think any of us will ever see she is
sitting in the passenger seat laughing
uproariously while Prince Philip is in
the driver's seat shall we just say with
our look of grim determination on his
face I don't know what it was exactly
that caused that Luke of grim
determination but having been there
myself with my wife on occasions I can
only guess
Her Majesty also visited Shetland in
1981 as shetland's oil came on stream
through the sudanvo terminal and she
opened the terminal then that was
Remembered in Shetland unfortunately
because it was a deep and the IRA
detonated a bomb in Shetland in the in
the power station there I mentioned that
because while we all speak about her
quite remarkable record of service we
should not forget that that service was
one which often came at personal risk
like others I Had My Moments a meeting
her majesty which I treasure as very
private and special moments I served as
control of the household from 2010 to
2013 and as such had a walk-on part in
the state opening of parliament it's
fair to see in 2013 we had The
Misfortune of a state opening of
parliament which classed with the first
day of the Windsor Horse Show and when
we returned to Buckingham Palace at the
end of the the state opening we were
left in no doubt that should this
unfortunate diary mismanagement happen
in the future it would not necessarily
be the Windsor horse show that we'd lose
out on that occasion
Mr Deputy speaker I I think back to my
the very first time I saw her majesty
inflation it was when she visited the
Isle of where I was growing up in 1977
as part of her Silver Jubilee tour she
often visited Isla privately as I guess
to the Morrison family and in passing I
would like to pay tribute not just to
her majesty but also to The Honorable
Mary Morrison who served for many many
years as one of Her Majesty's ladies
been waiting that occasion she visited
balmore Distillery
that was the first time she had visited
a Distillery and it came back to me in
2014 when I was president at Secretary
of State for Scotland at the naming of
the aircraft carrier HMS Queen Elizabeth
on that occasion as the aircraft carrier
was named there was a bottle of beaumore
whiskey for a smashed on the side of the
boat and the smell of that malt whiskey
draft drifted across the size and it
took me back to that day in 1977. I
mentioned that because I think like so
many people these are the threads that
our Majesty interwolves throughout our
lives they enriched the fabric of our
country that is why we miss her and that
is why we now played our new allegiance
to to his majesty the king God Save the
King Richard thank you Mr Deputy speaker
and I Rise to pay my own personal uh
tribute to the late Majesty Queen
Elizabeth II and on behalf of all my
constituents throughout the wreaking
constituency and Queen Elizabeth visited
Shropshire many times over her long
reign in particular her visits to the
reikin are still remembered with abiding
fondness and deep affection her visit to
Recon College in 1967.
her visit to the 13th century
buttercross in Newport in 1981.
a visit to Donington during the Falcons
war in 1982 and passing through
hierarchal another nearby villagers
and a last visit to the Rican in 2012 to
RAF cosford as part of her Diamond
Jubilee pageant where a huge crowd of
over 35 000 people turned out to greet
her
the late Queen Elizabeth was the
personification of Duty
Integrity selflessness
status
and resoluteness and always with a
superb sense of humor observation
and wit
yes spawn out of her own decency and
exemplary character but also born out of
her deep and abiding Christian faith
something she quietly attested to
throughout her long reign
and so often heard
through a comforting and unifying
Christmas Day messages which we will all
Miss
Mr Deputy speaker the wreaking love the
queen
loved the queen
she will abide in all our hearts and
memories
may she rest in peace
and rise in glory
long live the king
Marshall de Cordova
thank you uh Deputy speaker
um it's an honor to not only speak
um on my own behalf but also on the
behalf of my constituents in Battersea
and also pass on their condolences the
passing of her majesty the queen is a
great loss for the royal family and for
our country
our remarkable Queen dedicated 70 years
of our life serving our country as our
longest reigning Sovereign and devoted
her life to the betterment of this
country and today we celebrate her
service and express our thanks for her
steadfast leadership the queen was a
role model and someone who touched the
lives of so many in her own unique and
distinguished way
now over the course of her Reign there
was great transformation and progress in
the world yet she served as that
constant and reassuring figure during
periods of change that provided us all
with a sense of security the queen was
incredibly Resolute and principled and
she had a work ethic and commitment to
the duty and service which she placed
above all other considerations and we
can say even in her 90s and the days
before her death she was still working
and serving our country now her strong
and Abiding Faith In God was the golden
thread that guided her work and her
commitment to respecting everybody and
appreciating difference and serving
people now across Battersea people will
be reflecting on her selfless service
and Leadership of our country and the
queen visited the constituency on many
occasions including the then Children's
Home on the win Stanley estate and of
course Battersea dogs and cats home we
all know how passionate she was about
animals and their welfare and this was
shown by her patronist of the home and
as they have already said this week that
they were so lucky to have had such a
valuable relationship with with her
she wasn't just our queen as she was
seen globally by all the contributions
and tributes that have come her way
now as I close my thoughts and prayers
are worth his raw harness King Charles
and the royal family may she rest in
peace and rise in eternal glory
God Save the King
Greg hands
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and I Rise
to add my tribute to her late Majesty
Queen Elizabeth II on behalf of my
Chelsea and Fulham constituents at a
time of great sadness for the whole
country she was much loved in the Royal
Borough of Kensington and Chelsea and as
much so amongst my Fulham constituents
as well
she came at least once a year to my
constituency to the Chelsea flower show
indeed the first time and the last time
that I personally met her was at the
Chelsea flower show in 2010 and then
this year just three months ago
the Chelsea flower show was one of her
absolute favorite events she rarely if
ever missed it she may have been to it
more than 70 times
but in 2010 it was my first Chelsea
flower show and I was third in the Royal
receiving line and I was exceptionally
nervous
this wasn't held by the receiving line
taking around two hours
as almost the entire royal family comes
at 10 minute intervals started with
Princess Alexandra I think and
eventually the queen arrived and all
passed well I had bowed in the right
place and extended her my hand at the
right time we had a brief charming and
pleasant conversation I could relax
except I had forgotten one thing she
wasn't the last of the royal family to
come there was still the Duke of
Edinburgh moments after
and I realized my mistake and I almost
fell over having messed up my bow called
him your majesty
to which the trook smiled and said are
you new
and I pay tribute to him today to the
late Duke of Edinburgh as well the
Queen's beloved husband and the last
time I saw her was at this year's
Chelsea flower show which she toured
with great enthusiasm at age 96 in a
golf cart she was radiant and as ever
fascinated by the displays and it was
simply amazing to see her at the age of
96. she was much loved by my Fulham
constituents as well indeed one of the
iconic pieces of video footage from the
1977 Silver Jubilee was a clip of a
group of women on Kingwood Road in
Fulham arm in arm in Jubilee hats
singing all together maybe it's because
I'm a Londoner she'll be grieved and
warmly remembered the length of the
King's Road and as appropriately along
the new Kings Road as well
I also met her Mr Deputy speaker my role
as the government's deputy chief whip
many in this house will know that the
deputy chief whip is also the honorific
treasurer of the royal household and the
role comes with a wand of office which
looks like a long billiard queue which
unscrews in the middle referred to
earlier by my right honorable friend the
member for Pendle the day came in
October 2013 for the transfer of the
wand of office from my predecessors to
John Randall now Lord Randall to me in a
ceremony at the palace I was once again
nervous once again it all started well
Sir John handed the Queen the wand of
office she handed them to me the wand of
office
but I started fidgeting with this wand
of office I found it a fascinating
article as Sir John carried on speaking
with her majesty and I started
absent-mindedly Mr Deputy speaker
unscrew it
the wand of office
I had an alarmed look from her majesty
and an alarmed look from Sir John
Randall
who told me stop it
and I was told afterwards Mr Deputy
speaker that if I had unscrewed entirely
the wand of office it would have meant
rejecting the office and it would have
meant that Sir John would have had to
come back here still as the government's
deputy chief but that wasn't the worst a
minute or two later the queen suddenly
said to me and Sir John bear in mind
this is in 2013 at around the time a
growing European rebellion in the
conservative party the queen suddenly
said I do think Mr Baron has a point
with reference to my honorable friend
the member for billerici by now Mr
Deputy speaker I was a total wreck the
queen was seemingly pronouncing on the
greatest political issue of the time and
I had to give an answer on behalf of the
government but fortunately she saw my
difficulty and clarified it was with
reference to one of the honorable
gentlemen the member of belariki's many
other rebellions
in reference to regimental mergers
nothing to do with brexit at all Mr
Deputy speaker I conclude by just saying
I think the Queen's historic
significance the length of her Reign
everything that she's seen in fact she's
met every U.S president except one the
fact that her first prime minister was
Sir Winston Churchill born more than a
hundred years before my right honorable
friend the member of Southwest Norfolk
the fact that Joseph Stalin was still in
the Kremlin at the time that she came to
the throne showed her historical
significance I pay tributes on behalf of
my constituents of Chelsea Fulham and
wish
many many years of a happy Reign to King
Charles III yeah yeah I know many people
have got great stories and we do want to
hear them but I have to say that if we
have multiple stories and it goes on
then there are a lot of people who are
just simply going to be disappointed
even at 10 o'clock tonight so please be
mindful of your colleagues Jonathan
Jonathan Ashworth grateful Mr Deputy
speaker I Rise to express my personal
condolences to his majesty the king and
the royal family to associate myself
with the remarks that we have heard in
the debate so far and to express on
behalf of my constituents in Leicester
South and the City of Leicester our
tribute to her majesty her the late
Majesty
Lester is proud of its radical tradition
but notwithstanding our history as a
parliamentarian stronghold across
Leicester Her Majesty was held in deep
affection with deep reverence and deep
love and we are united in our grief
today
leicester's story today is one of
diversity
we have welcomed families from across
the globe from across the Commonwealth
to our city
sometimes families who were fleeing
persecution with nothing but a hastily
packed suitcase
and Her Majesty's leadership of the
Commonwealth not only stands as a
reminder of the bonds of solidarity
between the different nations of the
Commonwealth but it is also stands as a
symbol of inspirational hope for
families who were fleeing persecution
hope for a better future for themselves
and their children something that we
have been reminded of recently in
Leicester just last month as we recall
the 50-year anniversary of the expulsion
of the Asian Community from Uganda
and how much to herself celebrated our
diversity in Leicester also
she was proud of our different Faith
groups and today in Leicester I met if I
may say so our mosques at drummer
prayers have been recognizing Her
Majesty's death and expressing their
thanks
our Hindu temples have been placing
garlands over pictures of her majesties
there are prayers in our synagogues our
gurdwaras our Jain temples and we were
particularly proud ten years ago to host
Her Majesty for the start of her Diamond
Jubilee tour in Leicester and all of our
communities came together indeed for the
start of that Diamond Jubilee tour my
humble friend from Leicester West we
have the privilege of welcoming her to
the Montford University in my
constituency for the start of that tour
and as we were queuing up to greet her
majesty and his Royal Highness the Duke
of Edinburgh and we were waiting
nervously
and I think I caught uh just in the
color of my eye Her Majesty looking
somewhat bemused if not slightly a scans
our husband the Duke of Edinburgh who
had asked me in the member for Leicester
West whether we were Reds or Blues
I don't know what his opinion was of our
answer frankly
but not only did we celebrate her
majesty for the start of the diamond new
balito
a few months later we had we were
nervous in Leicester
because it was a few months later that
we discovered the remains of the last
yorkist Monarch in a Leicester city
council car park
this provoked all kinds of naughty
constitutional questions for the palace
today and what we were going to do with
Richard III
brought her majesty with the usual a
plum and diplomatic skill that we've
heard so much of let it be known that
she was following developments with
great interest and a couple of years
later visited Leicester Cathedral the
final resting place of Richard III to
hand out Monday money on Monday Thursday
let me finish with this point Mr Deputy
speaker
in February 1952
when this house debated emotion on the
loss of his majesty
King George
Winston Churchill from the dispatch box
said he hoped that the accession of
Queen Elizabeth would Usher in a golden
age
in response the former prime minister
and then leader of the opposition
clementley said they hoped the accession
of Queen Elizabeth would lead to another
glorious Elizabethan era more renowned
than the first one
my God
she more than surpassed the aspirations
and hopes of those two great prime
ministers
rest in peace
and God Save the King
I know everybody's Keen to get in as
well so there again look at the time
limits but please don't approach the
chair either I mean every time I choose
somebody it means I'm not choosing
everybody else and I know there's a lot
of pressure I know you all want to get
in sir Gary Streeter
very much Mr Deputy speaker it's a
privilege to bring a tribute to our late
Queen on behalf not just myself but of
course my constituents in Southwest
Devon and I want to focus in on her
excellent Christmas broadcasts every
year which has been mentioned by some
colleagues
her ability to connect with the whole
nation was never better expressed than
through her Christmas Day broadcasts in
our household as in many others they
were unmissable events and in recent
years the whole day was shaped around
them and each year as we know she spoke
with great warmth and insight about the
events of the year with ever more
personal Reflections and she never
shirked from touching on painful events
not just the positive knowing that all
of our lives are made up with ups and
downs and in particular she used those
opportunities to remind the nation of
the true meaning of Christmas namely the
births of her savior Our Savior Jesus
Christ
on the 3rd of August this very year she
said this
throughout my life the message and
teachings of Christ have been my guide
and in them I find Hope
it was Mr W speaker a simple but clear
explanation of the influences that had
shaped her life
and in our celebration of her greatness
as a monarch she would not want us also
to she would want us not to reckon she
would want us to recognize the
significance of the Gospel message that
produce such fruit in her
if she was the rock on which modern
Britain was built it was because she
stood on the true Rock The Rock of Ages
and in our pluralistic society
containing citizens of all faced and
none her Declaration of Christian faith
never Jarred nor grated or alienated as
we've heard from the uncle later from
Birmingham ladywood because it was
authentic
and this was demonstrated through her
magnificent Christmas broadcasts but I
believe in my final Point Mr Speaker I
believe it is also possible to discern
in her broadcasts another deep quality
that she possessed that even in her 80s
and in her 90s she did not stand still
or remain static she was moving forward
learning developing year on year she
became more intimate with her subjects
during those broadcasts more personal
ever more bold she had an appetite for
progress and advancement to the very end
so an authentic life shaped by her
sincere faith that produced in all the
visitudes of Life a remarkable woman and
a great Monarch on behalf of the people
of Southwest Devon thank you your
majesty for your life of service on our
behalf may you rest in peace and Rising
Glory Steve Reed
Mr Deputy speaker we've heard some
really wonderful anecdotal stories this
afternoon of members meetings with her
late Majesty the queen but for most
people who met her those moments would
have been more fleeting but they Lodge
in the memory because of the huge
importance the queen has played in our
life as a nation our sense of who we are
I first saw her as a Schoolboy during
the Silver Jubilee Walkabout in Windsor
feeling so excited as so many other
children and will have done over the
years simply to snatch a photograph of
her with my little plastic camera it
would be an iPhone today of course
another was when she came to open the
Lambeth Academy in Clapham the students
were besides themselves with excitement
that the queen had come to visit their
school and it's these little moments
like these through these little moments
that the queen has been a constant
presence Who lit up our lives for as
long as most of us have been alive
the stability of her presence eased our
country through periods of drastic
change as Britain moved from being the
center of an Empire to becoming the
modern diverse and more inclusive
country that we know and love today she
really was in T.S eliot's words The
Still Point of the Turning world where
past and future are gathered
my constituency of Croydon North is one
of the country's most diverse people who
came there from the Commonwealth feel a
special bond with her late Majesty as a
connection between their past and their
future many others who arrive from
outside the Commonwealth would consider
their citizens citizenship ceremonies
where they swore allegiance to her
majesty to be among the most important
moments in their lives during the
Platinum Jubilee celebrations we saw a
great outpouring of love for her late
Majesty in Croydon North as elsewhere
our diverse communities came together to
celebrate a woman who United us as a
community and as a country in a way that
nothing and no one else could do her
loss will be felt keenly and it will be
felt personally
three months ago my father died and the
next day a rainbow appeared over his
house and we took that as a sign that he
was at peace I take the rainbow that
appeared over Windsor Castle in the same
way and as a sign that her late Majesty
has been taken into the arms of God and
has found her
Eternal peace on behalf of the people of
Croydon North I offer my deepest thanks
to her late Majesty for a lifetime of
service my condolences to the Royal
Family on their loss and my loyalty to
our new King Charles III as he ascends
the throne to meet his Destiny and ours
Mark Francois Mr Deputy speaker
we have lost our sovereign
the most remarkable woman
the longest reigning monarch in British
history
who in 70 years barely ever put a foot
wrong
she was
the most famous person in the world
and possibly the most popular too
if the house will indulge me
it's almost a year since we lost our
great friends to Dave and Amos
I mention him because I think it's fair
to say he was rather keen on the
monarchy and on her majesty the queen in
particular I will remember how he was
bursting with pride when the queen
knighted him with an investiture at
Windsor he subsequently told our local
paper the echo who would ever have
thought that a boy from the East End of
London would one day be knighted by a
queen in a castle
if he were here today he would pay the
most fulsome tribute to her majesty so
perhaps I could do that for him in loo
from my own perspective I also had the
immense privilege of serving Her Majesty
as Vice Chamberlain when I served in the
Coalition whips office from 2010 to 12.
it's an ancient office but it
essentially has three modern functions
firstly to act as the Queen's Messenger
to Pond and on the first occasion I had
an audience with her I was complete and
terrified
I think it's to the Queen's credit she
well understood that people who met her
especially for the first time were
extremely nervous and she had that most
wonderful manner in asking you one or
two extremely gentle questions which
even a member of parliament couldn't get
wrong to settle nerves it was a
wonderful skill with people which I
think was but one of the reasons why her
subjects loved us so much
secondly achieving when the house was
sitting the vice changing's duty is to
compile the Royal message a one-page
summary for a Majesty of what's taken
place in Parliament printed off on
special paper to be collected by Royal
Courier at 6 PM precisely
all went well until one evening as the
message was just about to be printed
there was a complete I.T failure in the
whips office which led to a state of
pandemonium
by about 6 30 the Royal Courier by now
drumming his fingers looked at me and
said mischievous so you do realize sir
that if it's more than an hour late
you'll have to go down there and
apologize to her in person at which
point my blood ran cold
mercifully the Lord was kind and five
minutes later a screamable delight
emanated from the whips office when
clearly a senior whips assistant emerged
with the look of absolute Triumph and
said simply we've fixed it and when I
wish The Courier God speed I meant it
thirdly following a further unfortunate
misunderstanding with Charles the first
in the 17th century
on the day of the state opening the vice
chamber has to go to the Palace to be
held hostage as Surety for the monarchs
safe return what I once asked what would
actually happen if some things went
wrong The Courier sorry the Royal Court
here smiled at me and said Oh They'll
probably just cut your head off
this was vague in the back of my mind on
both occasions when I performed the duty
on the first the Duke was unfortunately
aren't well but on the second he
accompanied the queen as they came down
the steps I was standing there in
morning dress with my wand of office and
suddenly he walked up to me and said who
are you
I was stunned but before I could reply
the queen said with slight exasperation
he's the hostage
replied oh jolly good
they got in the coach and went to
Parliament I was there when they came
back and as they passed me I bowed my
head and said well done your majesty
when the the Duke turned on his heel and
walked straight up to me and said I bet
you're bloody relieved
the speaker on a 21st birthday the queen
famously or Elizabeth famously
proclaimed my whole life be it long or
short will be spent in the service of my
people
in modern parliaments she then did
exactly what it said on the tin and my
constituents in radian Wickford and the
whole country loved her for it
we have lost our Queen
but her Legacy lives on
God save
our King
Carol Moynihan
thank you Mr Deputy speaker on behalf of
my constituents of Glasgow Northwest the
people of Glasgow and my fellow Glasgow
MPS I wish to pay tribute to Elizabeth
Queen of Scots
her passing is a time of profound
sadness
Queen Elizabeth was a constant in our
lives the only head of state we have
known
unlike most of the other speakers this
afternoon I've never met the queen
although as a young girl I did go to see
her her Silver Jubilee when she came to
Glasgow and was visiting Kelvin Grove
art gallery of course the crowds are so
big I couldn't see her and my dad put me
up in the shoulders and I was able to to
wave at this beautiful big car and the
queen as she came out and many people in
Glasgow have similar memories as this
and it's right that we remember and pay
tribute to Her Majesty's tireless work
her dedication to her room and her
strong sense of Duty
for members of the Armed Forces she was
their Commander in Chief
and my husband's commissioned parchment
from her majesty hangs proudly in her
home
like many in Glasgow I have strong Irish
connections
and many members this afternoon have
spoken of her wit and her ability to
view a situation with Clarity and wisdom
and I'm reminded of her visit to Dublin
in 2011 in 2011 the first by a reigning
monarch for a century
the queen understood that this was a
historic event but also that it required
some delicacy
she wished to address the president Mary
mcaleese in Irish but had been warned
against attempting this for fear that
she might make a mistake and the gesture
be misinterpreted
undaunted she began
president and Friends
instantly all tension was lifted
president mcaleese mouth the word wow
and the audience at Dublin Castle burst
into Applause
wisdom understanding and respect such as
this was why she was loved by
monarchists and Republicans people of
all faiths and those of none
I'd like to finish by extending my
sympathy and that of my constituents and
the people of Glasgow and indeed our
prayers to the entire Royal Family who
will most acutely feel this loss of a
much-loved mother grandmother and
great-grandmother
Tracy Crouch
a deputy speaker I Rise humbly and with
great sadness to pay tribute
Chatham and out aylesford
the outpouring of love and respect for
her is Harper and genuine demonstrating
her reach into the most local of
communities Across the Nation
given the length of her Reign it is no
surprise she has visited my constituency
several times most recently in aylesford
in 2019 but she has an Ever presence in
a variety of ways
before the news broke yesterday
afternoon I was at Chatham Town Football
Club celebrating their receipt of the
Queen's award for voluntary service
bestowed upon them for their work in the
community in this year's Platinum
Jubilee honors list just one of a number
of people and organizations who've been
honored for the service they have given
it was Her Majesty's love of sport that
I wanted to briefly comment on and by
doing so refer the house to my entrance
in the register of interests
her love of horse racing is well known
her first runner was in October 1949 and
her first winner three days later which
was in fact her first of more than 1 000
British winners
she would have delighted in every single
one but many will remember her pure
thrill when her horse estimate won the
Gold Cup in 2013.
This Joy extended to other sports and
the sports reports of her death carry
countless photos of her smiling face
with sporting Superstars and globally
recognized and coveted trophies
tributes to her have flooded in from the
World of Sport her value to which should
never be underestimated
she was Patron to numerous sporting
bodies crucial to the success of London
2012 hosting all the world leaders
before the opening ceremony
she's authored countless messages of
luck and congratulations and hosted
numerous receptions celebrating
Victorious athletes
but she was also the proud mother and
grandmother of Olympians
I have been lucky enough to meet her
several times all of them because of
sport and most involved a conversation
about horses
the respect that racing football and
others continue to pay to her is a
measure of their appreciation to her and
the support she has shown to them
like many colleagues like visit primary
schools and have been asked the question
have you met the queen it is often
followed with the question have you met
Harry Kane
when I tell my primary school children
that I have indeed met the queen there
is an audible sigh and they are Keen to
hear more stories about her I tell them
the story that I first met her and my
curtsy was awful it was embarrassing and
I get all the children to stand up and
practice their curtsy and Bows just in
case they ever get to meet the sovereign
I'm stepped speaker last night as we sat
as a family and watched the news break
of her death tears openly rolled down my
cheeks and that of my other half
our six-year-old took my hand in his and
said
don't worry mummy
the king will look after us now no he is
right God Save the King
thank you Mr W speaker I Rise humbly
to pay tribute to her majesty the queen
on my on my own behalf and behalf of my
constituency Birmingham very well
I came to this house in 2001 and I was
placed on an esteem Committee of
Commons media and TV committee which was
chaired by The unright Honorable member
for North not in this place at the
moment
the only privilege I think we had in any
anybody knew us was that we had got an
invite to the Christmas reception uh at
the palace
so as a new member who'd just come in uh
I attended to the Palace along with my
colleagues
uh and luckily as as the queen is
circulating I was able to meet her first
uh and obviously introduce myself and
she was very pleased to do that but then
took it upon myself as the school
monitor to be the representative for the
whole of the committee and started
taking them across to the queen and
introducing her uh to them
the petulance of that didn't occur to me
until I'd come back home and thought
about what had happened
but her greatness
was that she wasn't irritated
by what I'd done
you know she wasn't annoyed by what I'd
done
she must have realized that I must be a
newbie in Parliament and just decided to
encourage me to go along and never saw a
harsh expression on her face or anything
else that was the endearing memory that
I have when I first came in uh to this
place as a member of Parliament
she
was the head of the church
and there's a lot of people who said
she supported all of the religions
she does that but she also supported
a lot of other beliefs as well the
maoris the Aborigines and some of the
African tribes
but she also above all
spotted people who had no faith at all
she spotted people
she had trust in people
she gave her life to service in dignity
in humanity
if anything that we are to do today
in paying tribute to her
is that we should rise
not just speak about the eloquent
speeches that I've heard today but
actually dries our own levels and
standards
to at least not if to emulate it to try
to get somewhere close to see how bad
much better we in this place can be that
to me
Mr Deputy speaker would be the endearing
tribute to her as I said she wasn't just
the
Monarch for the United Kingdom she was
also head of the Commonwealth and in
that process only last week
she wrote a letter to the pakistanis who
was suffering huge tragedy a climate
tragedy of floods and that was given out
and she actually Road elected to the
prime minister of the president to tell
her my last word is the Muslim prayer
which has already decided my friend
honorable friend from ladywood in Allah
indeed to God we belong and to God we
shall CERN may she rest in peace thank
you thank you thank you the deputy
speaker if I was asked by primary school
children have you ever met uh her late
match the queen I would sadly have to
say no so there will be no practicing of
bowels and curtses as my humble friend
from uh Chatham
um described although perhaps this
afternoon I've learned finally what the
attraction of being a government whip is
in that in that it seems to be
it seems
not only does it seem to increase the
likelihood of you being called early in
a debate because this but you certainly
got to spend a great deal of time with
her late Majesty Badger described our
easily understood Constitution as the
distinction between the dignified and
the efficient the efficient supposedly
is the government but I will let new
ministers uh discover that in due course
but they're dignified is the monarch and
in her late matches today can be no
greater embodiment of the dignified much
has been said of anecdotes but if I
could just briefly quote from her
majesty in her Christmas broadcast of
1974 because what she said then I think
one of sums up where we are today here
in Britain she said we hear a great deal
about our troubles about Discord and
dissension and about uncertainty of our
future
perhaps we make too much of what is
wrong and too little of what is right
the trouble with Gloom is it feeds upon
itself and depression causes more
depression there are indeed real dangers
and there are real fears and we will
never overcome them if we turn against
one another with angry accusations
we may hold different points of view but
it is in times of stress and difficulty
that we most need to remember that we
have much more in common than is
dividing us
May hermit late Majesty rest in peace
may God console her family in their time
of grief
and may he may God Save the King
and that was within look two minutes so
it can be done it can be done thank you
Mr Rag and David Lam is going to follow
suit are you David
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
Mr Deputy speaker I rise on behalf of
the people of Tottenham who mourn the
late Her Majesty's loss very very
greatly
and on reflecting about her majesty I
want to begin by evoking my parents
generation who arrived and are described
as part of the Windrush generation
my mother was the kind of woman for whom
there were only two important people in
our house
one was Jesus Christ and the second was
her majesty the queen and anything to do
with the royal family many will
understand this involved a lot of
memorabilia in our West Indian front
room but it's also the grace and the
dignity
and the strength with which the queen
approached the Commonwealth that I think
she should be remembered
she guided the Commonwealth
from a community of countries that have
been colonized to a voluntary
Association of 56 countries
she traveled to 117 countries over the
course of those 70 years and while she
was assiduous in her duties there was a
sense that she moved right from wrong
in 1979 she went to Zambia uh it was
controversial at the time and it
heralded the independence of then
Rhodesia and what we now know as
Zimbabwe and of course she was rumored
to be very concerned about the apartheid
regime in South Africa and she had a
long standing uh friendship with Nelson
at Mandela all of that is noted in her
Duty and her commitment to the
Commonwealth but as I said it's also
important to remember her Supreme
governments of the Church of England
she did this quietly but right up and
down the country in every constituency
her at the head of that very important
uh English British institution Anglican
institution is something that we should
hold very very dear indeed I have my own
small story uh if you let me uh Mr
Deputy speaker and that is the privy
Council of course it was the most
important day of my life it was on the
Note November the 5th 2008 and on that
day I was very very sleepy indeed I was
sleepy because my friend Barack Obama
had become president of the United
States the day before
I had not slept when I got to Buckingham
Palace at six o'clock in the evening I
knelt on the footstool my eyes closed I
bowed and I headed towards the Queen's
lap
she reached out and put her hand on my
bald head
she was generous and she was gracious in
all of the privy Council meetings that I
attended afterwards which I'm grateful
she understood the importance of Barack
Obama becoming the 44th President of the
United States of America she carried
herself with great dignity yesterday I
was at Dumfries house when I heard the
news and Prince Charles was unable to
meet with us we were there to discuss
the Commonwealth we were there to
discuss his commitment to skills and
young people he will be a very very good
King indeed thank you very much Stephen
Hammond
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I rise on
behalf of the constituency of Wimbledon
new Malden sorry Morden
raised path to Botsford Park and I want
to stay on behalf of all of my
constituents I wish to pay tribute
to our beloved Monarch and all that she
has done
I also want to express on behalf of them
our sincere condolences to King Charles
III and the whole of the royal family on
the loss that they've suffered for many
have today spoken of not only their
ceremonial but of course their personal
loss
her Reign has transcended as many people
have already many colleagues have
already said including my friend from
Stockport
times of turbulence and Times of Gloom
it's transcended the usage Mass usage of
automobiles telephones
jet travel and the digital age and
surely we reflect as we mourn today it
was her steadfast commitment to duty to
loyalty and to our country and to our
people that helped us
not only overcome and embrace those
changes but shape in a way that we now
see is so much for the better this
country we live in modern Britain
many people as I go around Wimbledon
tell me that they are grateful for the
visit she
made to my constituency
in the Diamond Jubilee Year many much
has been spoken of the fact she is a fan
of horse racing she came to the all
England to watch Tennis
it's not exactly the Queen's favorite
sport she hadn't been for 25 years
before
she watched a game and after she left I
said to one of the members of the
committee well that went well he said
well she was Charming it was wonderful I
said she even appeared to be interested
in tennis
he said to me well she did ask to know
the result of the 420 from Astrid
on behalf of all my constituents my
thought my heartfelt thoughts uh and
prayers are for our new king my thanks
for the life and reign of his mother our
beloved Monarch Queen Elizabeth
God save
the
Lockhart
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I join with
members across the house and expressing
my deepest sorrow and that of my
constituents in Upper bound on the death
of her majesty Queen Elizabeth II to his
majesty King Charles III Her Majesty the
queen consort and to the entire Royal
household our love thoughts and prayers
are with you as you mourn the loss of
such a special Mother
grandmother and great-grandmother
all of us in this place
and right across the country have been a
blessed people to live under the second
elizabethian age we had benefited
abundantly from her leadership her
wisdom her discernment and the grace of
one who for over 70 years devoted her
life to the unstinting service of this
nation and the Commonwealth when the
United Kingdom faced dark moments her
Radiance and fortitude Shone through
guiding her people to better days and
times of Celebration she led the nation
with a sense of fun warmth of style and
a sparkle in the eye Prime Ministers
were to come and go but her majesty
remained constant steadfast unsure and
that sense of Surety for her majesty
came from her faith her love for Christ
that she often spoke of in her Christmas
message that Faith gave her the strength
to fulfill her Earthly vocation and
whilst we thank her for her service
today she receives her Heavenly reward
for service to her King
Mr Deputy speaker this country is the
poorer for the passing of Queen
Elizabeth II the depth of grief is
reflective of the love and affection in
which she was hailed
to her adoring loyal subjects in
Northern Ireland we hold fast to the
wonderful memories of Her Majesty's
visit these were often symbolic and a
testament to her commitment to a better
future for everyone in Northern Ireland
importantly she also ensured that those
who served her in our most troubled
times were sure of her appreciation for
service and sacrifice and those victims
of terrorism knew the caring Spirit of
the queen Mr Deputy speaker every corner
of this Kingdom has now embarked on a
new era we commit to the service of our
new king his majesty King Charles III
his two a life of service his two a
record of commitment to Judy to close my
remarks on her majesty Queen Elizabeth
II I quote a Bible text which is fitting
for her life of service to our nation
second Timothy chapter 4 verse 7
I fought a good fight I have finished my
course I have kept the faith I pray that
God will grant King Charles III wisdom
and good health and history and over us
and that he too will keep the faith as
his beloved mom before him God Save the
King
Victoria Apprentice thank you
in her address to the nation during the
pandemic resplendent you remember in her
NHS scrub-colored dress and brooch Her
Majesty praised and I quote the
attributes of self-discipline quiet good
humid resolve and of fellow feeling
which she felt characterized our nation
these are qualities which she modeled
for us and for which we loved her
but to these she added a less definable
quality a presence a Splendor which came
from her deep faith and her certainty
that the crown is at the very center of
our constitution
this combined with her considerable
Beauty and charm meant she lit up every
room I'll never forget the day she came
to Banbury in 2008 on the 400th
anniversary of the times Charter later
that day she opened the Oxford
Children's Hospital my largest donors
were corralled for really quite a long
time for security reasons before she
appeared the excitement in the room and
some very healthy competition meant that
that was the most lucrative hour I have
ever spent in fundraising it's clear
from the speeches today that we saw in
the queen a reflection of our own
passions for diplomacy for charity for
institutions for the countryside for
racing
we feel that she loved every one of our
constituencies
the combination of service and Majesty
is unbeatable and this will endure God
Save the King David
thank you Mr Deputy speaker soon after
the the general election of 2001 there
was a reception in Buckingham Palace
I had just been elected and I attended
along with several hundred others
soon after I arrived to the bank within
Hall it announced that the queen and the
Duke of Edinburgh had arrived and after
her entrance the queen moved around the
hall politely speaking to a number of
assembled guests
I was chatting to a labor colleague but
then I became acutely aware that there
were hundreds of eyes focused in my
direction
but was because the queen had moved to
my side and was obviously intent on
speaking with me
I introduced myself to her in an
uncomfortable way and we've exchange the
number of pleasantries I then expected
her to move on but no the queen was
obviously intent on having a
conversation with me
and what a conversation about Watson
with me slightly awkwardly at talking
about the loyal yacht and then going on
to talk about the Royal train and how I
recall to her majesty how as a school
boy I was excited to see the Royal train
pass near my home Village of Kevin
cribble but Queen were delighted by
these comments
and then realized by this time what I
was author of William
the queen then proceeded to ask me about
how Welsh Devolution was progressing
these were the early early days of the
evolution and I gave a diplomatic answer
the queen was pleased with real answer
but then moved on to ask me how I saw
things in regard to the assembly in
Northern Ireland
given that the store Bond assembly was
at that time suspended and the situation
was extremely delicate I give a general
response explaining how difficult things
were
I will not say what her responses were
but suffice to say I was extremely
impressed by her
Majesty showed her overwhelming desire
to seek peace and Reconciliation novel
Island but more than that her comments
showed an impressive knowledge of
complex issues
and also a real decency integrity and
compassion
these qualities were in evidence
throughout her long Reign and were
clearly seen in all parts of the United
Kingdom
a few years ago the queen visited Astrid
money in my constituency of kefilia
the people of the area will always
remember her real warmth and genuine
interest in them
but my memory of the Majesty will always
be I'll share time for the children who
met her
the queen loved those children and the
children loved her
undoubtedly Queen Elizabeth II was an
exceptional monarch we all miss her
enormously may she rest in peace and God
said the king
Marcus Jones Thank you Mr Deputy speaker
I uh speak for all of my constituents in
nuneaton when I speak of our deep
sadness uh Queen Elizabeth's passing and
our gratitude for her long and
distinguished reign
on behalf of my constituents I would
like to convey our deepest condolences
to King Charles III and our lay Queens
Family
like a number of right honorable members
today I've had the absolute honor and
privilege of being the vice Chamberlain
to the household and the controller to
the household when I was made at Vice
Chamberlain I was dispatched off to the
palace with my uh right honorable friend
for Pudsey who spoke earlier we did the
exchange of ones of office with her
majesty I was as nervous as a kitten but
it went extremely well and I was very
pleased with myself
moments later I was handed a humble
address
that I was to ask a Majesty to sign and
then I would bring it back to the house
and deliver it in the house as per Norm
I went back into the room and handed her
majesty The Humble address
she looked at me and said
I don't have a pen
I'm then searching around inside of my
jacket frantically and it seemed like
for an age but it was only a few seconds
and I said Mom I'm afraid I don't have a
pen either
um she then quick as a flash said don't
worry follow me
and all of a sudden I'm on this surreal
Journey trailing in the wake of her
majesty Queen Elizabeth II
along this long Corridor stopping on the
way to give a bit of a fuss to one of
the corgis
we then come to the Queen's study and
you could see the volumes of papers the
number of red boxes this was two weeks
before the first lockdown so you could
see the number of things that the queen
at that time was doing on our behalf the
work she was doing
she signed the humble address with her
own pen
she then started to speak to me and
asked me about my wife and my family
and
it was fantastic I came out of that room
feeling on top of the world now I feel
that whether it probably a president a
prime minister
a school child that the queen was
speaking to on a school visit or a
patient in a hospital or a hospice all
of those people will have gone away with
exactly the same feeling
that was one of Her Majesty's abiding
qualities amongst many others
thank you ma'am for your dedication
and service to our nation
God Save the King
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and on
behalf of everybody in the world
particularly in my constituency I extend
our profound condolences to the royal
family we have all lost our Queen they
have lost a beloved family member and we
hold them in our hearts as my friend the
right of a member for wallacy mentioned
earlier the queen first visited my
constituency in 1957 where she visited
the famous Port Sunlight Villages and
the Cottages named the Duke of York
Cottages named after her father since
then many in the world have felt
strongly about the queen and have
supported all that she has done and Mr
Speaker I want to talk Above All Else in
favor of the Queen's constancy the news
of the end of Her Majesty's her late
Majesty Queen Elizabeth reign has felt
like the ground we stand on shifting
beneath our feet all that we have known
is changed down the years our country
has been brought together in celebration
and in Sorrow by her late majesty and it
simply feels impossible to know how to
react without her she had a Peerless
understanding of the country that we
love hard one through her life which saw
our country's growth but also its
emergence from the darkness of war and I
reflect on what her generation
saw in all of them they knew not only
the pain of loss but also the
overwhelming Devastation of war and
we've heard so often about that
profoundly important visit to Ireland in
2011 and her role as a peace Builder the
Queen's example to us all is that
patient constancy and that that is the
best path to change in her twenties she
said she could not do what the men
before her in her role who preceded her
could do but that unlike them via modern
communication she could broadcast across
Nations I think she was a fan of new
technology whether it was speaking to us
all from the dawn of television or
whether it was just recently again as
we've heard on Zoom working from home
during the pandemic she was a Marvel and
in politics it seems so often that
change comes too slowly and when it does
come we fall back so I ask myself in
with relevance to the Queen's Legacy how
is it that our country makes progress
and I think it's not that any individual
can make progress by themselves but
rather it's in our institutions those
institutions that persist when
individuals fail that really shifts our
country from Darkness to the light
that's progress
and it's what her late Majesty made with
the Constitutional role that was hers
she could always see what the future had
on offer and she built a path for us all
it has been utterly humbling to hear
from leaders across the world and I
trust that Global outpouring brings her
family comfort our country is not
perfect but in her late Majesty's
example we have seen not only the model
of service but also the never-ending
hope in our future that sprung Eternal
on these islands through her reign
long live the king
[Music]
Dom
thank you Mr Speaker today marks the end
of an era the modern Elizabethan era the
only monarch that I and almost everyone
in this chamber and most of our nation
have ever known
I joined those who've spoken so movingly
from across the house and mourning the
death of our longest serving Sovereign
late Majesty Queen Elizabeth II and pass
on my condolences with those of my
constituents from South Shropshire to
members of the royal family who grieve
her loss
we reflect today with a mixture of great
sadness and sense of loss but also
remembering with great joy the
inspiration which she gave in devoting
her life to the service of others
her first of 15 Prime Ministers heralded
her accession to the throne as launching
a golden age a signal for a brightening
salvation of the human scene and so it
proved in so many areas of human
endeavor and achievement by her and her
subjects over these past 70 years
as others have mentioned we should
probably all remember where we were when
we heard the news of Her Majesty's death
yesterday
although she was 96 this still came as a
lightning bolt of shock in the midst of
the thunderstorms raging across her
kingdom yesterday
I'm with members of the environmental
audit committee at a half full Reservoir
in Cornwall surrounded by trees
and this seems strangely fitting as I
wish to touch very briefly on the
commitment Her Majesty showed to the
environment
through her love of nature and animals
that others have mentioned she and her
devoted husband Prince Philip the late
Duke of Edinburgh and undoubtedly
planted the seed of their family's
enthusiasm in championing nature and
leading the Crusade to combat climate
change decades before this became
fashionable
only last November in her message to
International leaders and delegates
attending cop 26 she said the time for
words has now moved to the time for
action
we saw her love of Nature and whenever
she was walking or riding in the
countryside around Balmoral or
Sandringham her Love of Animals was
legendary and one of those
characteristics which connected her to
her people in particular horses has been
mentioned it was no accident that the
Royal Windsor horse show was the event
she enjoyed the most each year and we
all knew even if we couldn't always
comprehend her particular love for
corgis
but it was her love of trees that will
be a lasting physical Legacy I suspect
she planted more trees than anyone else
in public life anywhere around the globe
the Platinum Jubilee Queen's canopy
canopy has seen a million trees planted
this year alone in her honor and this
will be a lasting reminder of her for
decades if not hundreds of years to come
her only visit to the Ludlow
constituency was in the year after her
golden jubilee when she came by Royal
train to Telford and visited Much
Wenlock with Prince Philip to take in
the Wenlock Olympian games an early
precursor to her role in London 2012.
she then showed that her priorities lay
with her people by having lunch in the
Discovery Center in Craven arms rather
than the Gourmet Delights of Ludlow she
went on to do a walkabout in the Market
Square in Ludlow where thousands turn
out to welcome the first visit by a
reigning monarch in more than 300 years
most visits by predecessors before that
had been at the head of an army
and while these tributes have been made
today to his mother and matriarch to the
nation
his majesty King Charles III has been
doing a walkabout among well-wishers
outside Buckingham Palace her example of
engaging with us all already being
carried on by her successor God rests
Her Majesty God Save the King five facts
thank you Mr Deputy speaker I wonder of
course some behalf myself and my
constituents and the citizens of
Sheffield to pay tribute to the queen
and to associate myself with the
wonderful Commerce that have been made
from both sides of the house during this
session but I want to particularly
relate to my own personal experience
I've had chance to meet with the late
Queen on a number of occasions as a
member of parliament but I want to refer
back to the first time I met her back in
May 1991 when I was leader of the
council in Sheffield and she came to
open the Sheffield Arena
now to do the opening we had to build a
raised walkway which went into the
middle of the arena and I walked had to
walk alongside her down to the
microphones
before doing the walk Royal officials
came to me and said
councilor Betts uh there's a rather
steep drop on one side of the walkway
make sure you're on that side of the
queen when you walk along
but before we began the official opening
she had a chat
she talked to myself and others with
knowledge and understanding about what
was going on in the city about the loss
of jobs in steel and engineering and the
effect on people's lives and
unemployment and she showed an empathy
for what was happening in our city
and when we walked out to do the opening
we do things properly in Sheffield so we
had a trumpet voluntary went off
and the queen stopped after a little bit
and said um
do you think they've seen us come in
and I said your majesty they don't
normally do trumpet volunteers for
leader of the council
and then she said well do you know what
we do next and I said well I'd rather
help you done this sort of thing before
but she had a laugh she enjoyed it she
just put me at ease and relaxed so my
very simple memories of the queen from
that occasion on future occasions
were someone with a very real
understanding of an interesting the
issues of concern to her subjects and my
constituents someone with a personal
warmth and a lovely sense of humor who
put me at ease with the way they
approached this at a time when I was
quite frankly extremely nervous but she
just took it in her stride what I would
say very simply on behalf of my
constituents is thank you to an
incredible Sovereign for an incredible
life of service God Save the King
John Lambert
um I do want to reflect on the immense
loss we have sustained as the United
Kingdom and The Commonwealth with the
passing offer late in Majesty the queen
like every other member of this house I
can say with pride that the queen knew
my constituency in the Scottish board as
well and visited it many times over her
seven decades of service as our
Sovereign I treasure my own memories of
two of Her Majesty's most recent visits
to Scotland in 2009 Her Majesty the
queen came to the seaside town of imouth
in bericho and in the 9th of September
2015 seven years ago to today Her
Majesty of the queen opened the borders
Railway the day the queen became the
longest serving Monarch in our history
on both of these days the crowds were
large probably much larger than the
organizers had expected I remember the
enormous anticipation steadily building
as a time for her arrival approached
local residents of all ages and all
backgrounds and the thrill of excitement
like an electric pulse rusting rushing
running through the crowd when they saw
her majesty The Joy the disbelief all to
see a global icon they face in every
Coin and Stamp they are in the flesh a
smiling and radiant lady here to visit
them in their own Community those
memories will last a lifetime
as a member of the Scottish Parliament
for a decade I had the privilege of
missing her late Majesty on in more
informal settings after each election
the queen and the Duke of Edinburgh
would host a reception at the palace of
Hollywood's house for the newly elected
msps as she moved around the room the
queen clockwise the Duke of Edinburgh
anticlockwise there was a real sense of
of anticipation the same sense of
anticipation we experienced when she
visited the borders it was amusing to
see how some of my new MSP colleagues
shall we say some of them might not have
been the most instinctive royalists
suddenly religious to a bag of nerves
but it's a queen joined our group we
were all immediately put at ease by her
twinkly eyes and warmth after a brief
pleasantries the queen immediately
launched into detailed and informed
questions about our respective
constituencies now given there were 129
msps plus various other guests how she
was ever able to remember such detail
and knowledge was quite remarkable but
it was her kingdom and it had been her
kingdom for longer than most of us had
been alive
the queen was always fully prepared for
whatever her Duty demanded offer she
never spared herself as we saw this week
when she fulfilled her last Act of
service appointing my right honorable
friend the prime minister in good times
and bad we've always looked to the queen
for guidance and Leadership and were
never left wanting her life spanned the
end of the British Empire and the start
of the age of Internet a few of us can
remember a time without the queen on the
throne our great nation is feeling a
tremendous pain at the loss of our
beloved queen as we come to terms with
that loss let us give thanks to our good
fortune that she reigned over us happily
and gloriously for so long and let us
give our sympathy and support to his
majesty king of the king in years to
come those children wearing Flags in the
Scottish borders will tell their
grandchildren of the day the queen came
to town each of them each of us here and
all of our constituents will forever be
able to say with pride that we are
elizabethans God Save the King yeah
as the beginning of proceedings today
at approximately 6 p.m the house will be
suspended while his majesty the king
makes his broadcast to the nation
members present will be able to watch
that broadcast on screens in the chamber
we will then resume our proceedings to
continue tributes
the house will now be suspended
while the king makes his broadcast to
the nation
the house is
suspended
order
thank you
thank you